uh all right yeah they're on now okay
okay uh so I will repeat
um we are now opening up the hearing for
13.99 for those out listening streaming
wise uh it's an act relative to school
district withdrawal from a Cooperative
school district and with that I'd like
to
open up by having the prime spots do we
have the prime sponsor here yep
okay yes okay uh we have representative
power here
rough Ralph do you want to grab her
handouts
okay represent please go go ahead
am I on now yep you're on thank you Mr
chairman and committee members I
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today House Bill 1399 relative to
school district withdrawal from a
Cooperative school district for the
record I am representative Diane power I
represent the towns of Brookline and
Mason in Hillsborough County District
26.
this bill addresses the disposition of
assets and liabilities and equity in
Cooperative School District Holdings as
it pertains to withdrawal from a
dissolution
withdrawal from or a dissolution of a
Cooperative School District the need for
this bill has been expressed to
legislators in my district for many many
years by numerous constituents
the issue that this bill addresses is as
follows
under current statute when either a
pre-existing School District withdraws
from a co-op or a Cooperative school
district is dissolved the pre-existing
School District forfeits all equity in
Co-op facilities that are not located in
the town of the pre-existing School
District
in other words the withdrawing
pre-existing School District receives no
compensation for the money it
contributed in the co-op schools located
in other towns
consequently such pre-existing school
districts
that have invested taxpayer dollars over
the course of years in other towns are a
severe disadvantage if they desire to
leave the co-op
as such they unfairly face a tremendous
Financial penalty to withdraw from the
co-op due to the mere fact that Co-op
facilities are happen to be located in
another town
undoubtedly this is both unjust and
unreasonable and it needs to be remedied
in statute
the solution that this bill provides is
to amend the current Statute in order to
provide that pre-existing school
districts without Co-op School District
facilities in their Town receive
Equitable share of fair market value
proportional
to their investments in those facilities
notably this bill provides that fair
market value will be number one
determined by an independent committee
appointed by the Department of Education
and by the Department of Revenue
administration number two
approved by the State Board of Education
number three clearly stipulated in the
withdrawal or dissolution plan and
number four available to all voters
before a final vote is taken to act on
the withdrawal or the dissolution
so at this point I'd like to speak to my
handout if the chair would allow yes
this is a complex bill so therefore I
felt that some graphic illustrations
would lend to
um
I guess describing what's going on here
and what this bill proposes so on the
first page I have an example of a
two-town co-op
so as you can see on the left the pie
chart there
depicts investments in buildings land
and Facilities that are located in town
a
and they are combined
the investment is 10 million dollars
under the current statute if town or
pre-existing School District a initiates
a dissolution
and the equity is
determined to be 30 million dollars then
a pays B four million dollars its
initial investment
however if a initiates a dissolution
then under current statute as you can
see to the to the right same you know
obviously same three million dollar
equity
if B initiates dissolution
then a pays B zero nothing
so what this bill proposes is for the
same scenario if either A or B initiates
a dissolution
then
a pays B 12 million dollars and that is
proportional to the equity I mean
proportional to what was invested in the
co-op facilities
so on the following page I have an
example over three Town Co-op and I'll
just run through this it's it's this
follows the same logic
we have um three towns the investment in
buildings land of facilities are happen
to be located in town a valued at 11 you
know million dollars was a total
investment if a initiates the
dissolution then a pays B the three
million dollars in a pay C two million
dollars however under current RSA is B
initiates the withdrawal
and the equity is determined to be 33
million dollars then both A and C pay B
zero
and what the this um House Bill 1399
proposes to um
to amend is that for the obviously the
same scenario of the three-town district
if a initiates a dissolution then a will
pay B 9 million and a will pay C 6
million and finally
um
the last
this bill
proposes that
if B initiates a withdrawal then A and C
become the new co-op and together they
pay B the 9 million so
in conclusion this bill addresses the
unfair and unjust penalties in current
statute against pre-existing school
districts that want to withdraw from a
co-op
and it levels the playing field by
ensuring that all pre-existing school
districts in a co-op receive their
Equitable share of fair market value
that concludes my bill introduction and
Mr chairman I'm happy to answer any
questions if you allow thank you very
much are there uh folks on the committee
that like to ask questions represent a
boom
thank you Mr chairman thank you
represent Powell for taking the question
um one of the problems we've always had
in the past is
every Association Co-op Association has
different rules
uh and that's one of the problems we've
had in the past is there anything in the
Brookline Mason thing that
gives
covers this or where is the school
located and will that make a difference
so thank you for the question
representative you referenced
a term rules and I'm assuming that that
perhaps you're referring to the articles
of agreement for the co-op
and could you restate the question
yeah every Co-op has an articles of
agreement like you said and and and one
of the problems we've had in the past is
every Co-op has different articles of
agreement which makes these kind of law
rules bills difficult so is there
anything in your articles of agreement
that covers this and in the case of
where where is the school located okay
so my my understanding is you know the
articles of agreement serve as the
constitution of the co-op and clearly
with regard to the dissolution or
withdrawal that these types of issues
are addressed in statute so then
therefore we would refer to rsas in
order to
um you know guide or inform us as to how
we're going to handle this I think I
think it's a two part I'm not familiar
with
each and every co-op in the state of New
Hampshire what there are articles of
agreement stipulate but of course you
would have to you know look at those and
in concert with statute and I I hope
that I clearly Illustrated that the way
that the current statute is and I
believe that it was um it was adopted
and signed into law into 1977. this is
you know this is a very complex abstract
um you know scenario that legislators
attempted to address
in in in in statute
and upon you know close inspection of of
this this section of law
you know they did the best that they
could
and I feel that today you know we can do
better because clearly the way that the
law is is written is it's just it's
unfair
and it makes no sense that I would like
in the situation of a you know
withdrawal or a dissolution uh like any
other legal
um you know
relationship or contract like a marriage
if one party you know decides that the
relationship is not working out and
they've invested you know financially
in assets the notion that because they
want to leave that relationship and they
get nothing is not fair
further questions from the committee
represent woodcock
oh you had your hand up first it doesn't
matter go ahead Mary Beth that's fine oh
thank you representative I appreciate it
uh
just a I'm following your chart
um I understand the a
h
if a is where the if I get this right a
is where the buildings are located
correct it's our facility for instance
and we're leaving
right so we have to pay you we're
leaving and we are we we own the
facility is that right
um so
a is the town in which the co-op
facilities are located and so under
current statute yes a pays B the the
initial investment and it does not take
into account any appreciation okay the
fair market value that's not my question
okay the question is okay so on the
leaving the co-op
under
the plate why I don't understand why
they would get paid they the facility is
there they have made the choice to leave
Okay so
leave
if you choose to leave we know we now
have the people left in the co-op have
to figure out absorb the extra costs and
the facilities there I don't understand
if if B leaves first why why they should
get paid I understand I understand if
the school is housing all the work
leaves then you left those two at risk
and yes you should pay for that facility
but if it's if the B decides to leave
um on the wrong why why would you do
that
because the the co-op is is an agreement
in which like for example in this
two-town Co-op both towns have invested
in that Co-op and have
ex raised and appropriated taxpayer
dollars
to to fund
you know land buildings and Facilities
and so they have the the town B has you
know a bona fide
you know interest in they've paid all
along so just because facilities happen
to be located in not their town
it's it's unfair that they would end up
with nothing
follow-up thank you okay just my own
last one so going back to the same
scenario when this two turns out is B
all the time that B has been a partner
with a in this facility they've been
able to use their investment
so it's out there they're getting the
money thing stolen or are they I
understand the loss of my investment but
that was my choice I've been using it
for 10 years we don't want it anymore
we're leaving
as a school district
okay so I would I would respectfully ask
that perhaps you you think of this
scenario from a different different
reference point and that would be that
town a
in which the co-op facilities are
located they have the the benefit of
moving forward with all those assets
they did not pay raise and appropriate
taxpayer dollars exclusively in their
town
tax monies were raised in Pro and
appropriated in both towns so again I
would I would I would you know reiterate
that
for town a to move forward and walk you
know forward
with assets
that they did not exclusively pay for it
yet it was paid for jointly
to me is is unfair and I feel strongly
that we as legislators can do better for
the people the taxpayers of New
Hampshire and that's that's why I've
proposed
representative
thank you so one of the first lessons we
learn as legislators is be aware of
unintended consequences and what I see
before me is kind of a one-size-fits-all
and I think that probably Cooperative
districts around the state have a lot of
different arrangements and a lot of
different ways as to where they got to
where they are and it's not I'm sure
always that they jointly built a
building and as representative Woodcock
said you know they have gotten the
benefit of that along the way say that
building is now 30 or 40 years old what
about the depreciation on that building
if if building is in uh District a and
they are holding the building so my my
concern is is that we have something
that is fair maybe perhaps more fair in
some districts but less fair in others
so with that as a basis I'm asking you
to what extent have you looked at the
Cooperative districts around the state
to know that they're all in the same
situation and they all have the same
investment in buildings and the
buildings are all still not basically
depreciated up because they've gotten so
old
thank you for the question
I the important thing to understand with
with this um bill is that it all hinges
on fair market value and that will be
assessed by a committee appointed by the
Department of Education and the depart
dra Department of and revenue
Administration and so there will be a
committee that is formed to
um to assess the fair market value
and
it's an independent committee and that
there will be you know many
opportunities for the stakeholders to
provide you know input and again I would
I would would reiterate that this all is
about the fair market value
so
so I have a question and that is do we
know that in every Cooperative districts
all districts contributed to the
construction of the building and it's
not that they form the co-op after the
building was built because if only one
District contributed to the construction
of the building and we put this in law
as a fixed solution then I think it
could create an inequity in the case of
if one District built one of the
buildings initially thank you for the
follow-up so
to be clear again the the crafting and
the language of this bill
addresses that the the payout
is proportional to what a town
contributed along the way so that is a
that's a factor and yes that would be
taken into account therefore if a town
you know
didn't contribute or you know
contributed at some percentage the pay
the payout
after the dissolution or withdrawal
would be proportional to what was paid
in and I I feel that that is clearly
addressed in the language of the bill
thank you very much and I'm going to ask
you a question right now seeing that we
have dealt with the cooperative
School District issue for years and
years and we've gone to the point where
in previous years we've gathered in
these agreements and looked at the
agreements which are all based upon
different percentages of different
elements be it value of property via
enrollment be it poverty Etc
um my concern is if District a
has the facility within it
and we'll just take a a two District
Co-op and District B
is a small District but District a wants
to go It Alone
now this District B is located in the
part of this state where there's no
other options available I know if you're
a k through eight school if you become a
k through eight you have the option to
tuition your students out but if there's
no place a tuition students out where
does District B in this process end up
with their students is there a
transition plan where we can ensure that
no student is Left Behind
my understanding with regard to the
process
of withdrawal or dissolution is that a
proposal will be crafted by stakeholders
with voters
input you know at you know
and hearings and that that withdrawal
plan shall be and submitted to the
Department of Education and it will it
needs to be approved and then sent back
to the to the district to the voters of
the district to to to vote up or down my
last follow-up is more of a concern uh
how does that impact District B which
has a minority of students in that
school district and the weighted vote is
always on the side of the larger
District within the co-op
that
the focus of this bill was it was was
you know narrow and it had to do with
the unfairness in current statute you
know as I described with regard to a
withdrawal or or a dissolution that was
the focus of the bill
um these these other issues I I feel can
can be handled and and dealt with
through the process
of withdrawal thank you very much are
there further questions representative
luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much for uh bringing this
forward
um this morning and for taking my
question in the um in the in the
scenario uh proposed scenario on the
first page the a b scenario where's the
money coming from
that for for the the payout yeah it
would come if it would prob it would
have to be a bond
from from I mean let's just go with Town
a would have to pay Town B
so who's paying the bond
the tax it would have to be raised and
appropriated by the taxpayers
through taxation okay thank you
further further questions represent
Lakers
thank you
um
have there been are you
have there been that you know of towns
uh Town bees
who wanted the solution for whatever
reasons and then didn't pursue it
because they got no money and they had
invested quite a bit that that's an
interesting and important question and
if I may
ask to defer that to an expert subject
matter witness who has signed up to to
speak they have direct experience with
with that in a co-op School District so
that individual is better suited to
speak to that thank you thank you are
there further questions representative
Woodcock
yes you may I wrote the question down
but representative luno addressed it as
well as long clearing this so I'm in
town a where we have the facility
count D to my right here
wants to leave and your suggestion is
that we do the fair market value and
give it to her give that share to them
my question is is falling off of
Representative lunar that means my town
and our residents would have to be
re-taxed again
to pay them out so we're paying off the
bond we're paying for the the long-term
maintenance facility which may be too
large what we need and now we have to
raise taxes again to pay them for
leaving
so that I just that's correct that's
what you're telling me thank you thank
you for the follow-up represent
representative
in mind as estimation and in my mind it
would be no different than any other
bond for any other you know purpose
that the that the co-op would pursue
okay but that's that's how it would work
do you yes okay thank you thank you Mr
left further representative Porter
thank you Mr chair and good to see you
again representative thank you um
I'm a little confused here so Town B
contributed to the construction of the
elementary school now they want to leave
over the course of the 15 years they've
been paying taxes in to maintain the
roof to maintain the electricity to do
all those things to that building
um do they so they would according to
your
your scenario here they would they
deserve to get some money back correct
because we're oh I'm sorry but what
happens if
Town B did not contribute to the
construction of the building but over
the years have been paying taxes to
maintain the building and now they want
out so
the the calculation is is clearly based
on what was invested so that all those
factors all those contributions would
have to you know be taken into account
and that it would be proportional to
that which the town paid in
so I feel that that that that that that
takes into account those factors
oh well yeah so that would mean that
somebody would have to go back over the
past 20 years or 10 years and look at
every time of a repair job was done
every time the building was re-roofed
whether the oil tanks were replaced
whether the heating oil prices went up
those sorts of things that have to go
back over the life of
the contract the the Cooper cooperative
and figure out what percentage of that
was paid by Town B and then what would
be the fair market value now and then
that would be
what would get paid out and who would do
that work
representative um thank you for the
question
I can't tell you in a particular SAU who
would be assigned to do that research
but clearly the those those those types
of things are factors and and um
discovery that that would have to be you
know factored in to determining the fair
market value
further questions
thank you very much
the next person to speak on this bill is
Eric power
hello honorable members of the education
committee my name is Eric power I live
in Brookline New Hampshire
and I served as a school board member
for the Hollis Brookline Cooperative
school district for three years
and I do have direct experience with
withdrawals
um and the question that was brought up
earlier but I wanted to mention a couple
of things being on the school board I'm
very familiar with the Articles of
agreement that are in the Hollis
Brookline Cooperative School District
there is no uh provision in there it
says to follow RSA 195 essentially
um
in our case we're kind of town B and
Hollis is town a so they have the
facilities
and
what happens in 2020 is we had an
article on the warrant to initiate a
withdrawal from the Hollis Brookline
Cooperative School District
and there was much discussion about that
there was the the Brookline has grown a
lot
a lot of folks in town think we've
outgrown the co-op it had worked well
but you know as we are considering
getting out but when this issue of
equity came up that we would lose
everything
that was seen as a showstopper to kind
of any other discussion and it was too
bad because we couldn't do anything the
one of the challenges we've had is that
we've had majority votes Hollis has 60
percent of the voters they've changed
the apportionment formula probably the
most I think in the whole state six
times since the co-op was founded
they've done it every five years and
it's always and except for one case
always increase the taxes in Brookline
and decrease it in Hollis
so but there's other educational issues
that go along with that but that was
basically it no one wanted to go any
further because of the unfairness so
that's one of the reasons we're looking
at this
uh we do have an articles of agreement a
article to deal with grade reduction so
if we took a seventh and eighth grade
the co-op is a 7 through 12th Co-op if
we took seventh and eighth out we have a
we have agreements in there but right
now RSA 195 is the law RSA 195 27 and 28
is our one size fits all that we have
right now that's why we need to adjust
the one-size-fits all to be more fair so
that a small school district will be
able to get its fair share of equity
when the co-op decides that it's not
good for everyone and town a having
majority voters will have a big Say in
any plan so if they don't like the way
the plan's going they don't feel it's
fair they're going to vote no on it so
it's really going to be a fair plan in
the end for its work out and also gets
the oversight of the Department of
Education
uh so as I'd like to say is I think it's
a really unfair law right now for the
small towns because it's really
impractical
unless you're gonna you're willing to
take you lose millions of dollars
um in equity that you've spent and when
you look at fair market value
it's taking into account depreciation
it's taking into account improvements it
looks at the contributions that have
been done over time by both towns and if
one town exclusively built it then
they'll get all the equity they don't
have to pay Town B anything
but that's probably not the case in
general they may have paid more but
it'll be proportional so I think this is
a really important law to adjust because
it's a matter of fairness to all the
Cooperative school districts in New
Hampshire thank you thank you very much
are there questions yes represent boam
thank you Mr chairman thank you question
if I remember my history correctly uh
there was the Hollis Brookline Mason
initial agreement
pulled out some years ago remember right
is that correct that's not correct Mason
was with another town we have another
witness here okay that'll speak to the
brook the Mason issue
there is another uh town that I know
also recently had a problem with Sandown
wanting to pull out a Timber Lane and
that was also the same exact problem
that Brookline had in their Co-op
um and so it's been at least two
instances recently that this has been a
challenge where it's been brought forth
gone to a warn article and then stopped
because of this Equity issue
thank you uh representative Porter
the chair so we've been assuming here
[Music]
town is the bigger town
that's what it is in the hypothetical
example yes okay so if county is the
smaller town
but the school is located in it
and town B pulls out
then town a has to pay Town B
and be left with a bigger building that
they don't need anymore
without the support of the taxpayers in
town B to maintain it plus they have to
pay off a bond
to the bigger town to pay off what's
owed on the uh on the building
how does what happens then in that
scenario to town a
is that fair to town a so you're I'm
trying to understand your example here
you're saying town a has doesn't have
buildings or town a no town a is the
smaller town but the school is located
in it
okay it would work the same way I mean
you would step still pay off yes you
would still pay off and you
and a larger chunk of the equity because
but presumably time to be paid more into
the building of it and you would have to
take out a bond to do that
you would have
a few many fewer students because Town B
is the small is the bigger town so they
won't be there anymore so you've got a
building that's bigger than you need
with fewer students than you had and
less people have helping to maintain it
plus you have a bond to pay off for
five or eight or ten million dollars or
whatever the larger portion of the
equity going to the bigger town so how
does that help town a what will town a
do in that circumstances in your opinion
is that fair
I think it's fair because you everybody
in town a in town B collectively as the
co-op voters decide on that and I don't
see that it's any more unfair than
what's happening right now and I think
it's actually probably I don't know if
there would be an example of that it
would be highly unlikely but in that
case I still think it's that's the way
that it should be done
the further questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
uh now we'll have the representative
from Mason uh representative John
lewicki
uh thank you good morning Mr chairman
and members of the committee
um I'm John lewicki I represent
Brookline and Mason and Brookline Mason
have never had any disagreements
um however I don't see anyone here from
back in the day when I uh was before
this committee on a yearly basis before
Mason was able to withdraw and I do have
the perspective of being someone who was
very active in trying to get Mason out
of the Messianic district and I'm going
to use the names of the districts I hope
that's not um
verboten because it's so much easier to
do that
basically Mason was the smallest town in
the district
and we
the district was formed in 1968 I
believe don't quote me on the date and
calling these districts Cooperative is a
misnomer these basically were shotgun
marriages imposed based on somebody's
brain child here in Concord on the towns
and put towns that were not really
similar demographically or in their
goals or whatever in together and said
okay you guys are going to have a school
district together even though they had
been doing just fine previous to that
Mason as I may have said was the
smallest town in a three-town district
and the district was formed in 68 there
was then a bond around 2008 the initial
Bond expired around 2008 and there was a
new Bond to build new facilities
those facilities were expensive state of
the art but buildings don't educate
children and what we had was a
District which really was not suited to
Mason's wants or needs that was
providing an education very different
from what we would have chosen on our
own what we had chosen on our own prior
to the being forced into the district
and so I spent many years I don't see
anybody here on the committee who was
here when I was here back in the early
2000s in any case we passed that Bond
and within a year or two at the next
district meeting it was moved to amend
the articles of agreement
and that was to basically make Mason pay
a larger share of the capital expenses
essentially the bond and we successfully
defeated that but it was year after year
and school district meeting after school
district meeting with people including
myself red in the face yelling at the
opposite opposing side it was a toxic
atmosphere did not do anything to
benefit the students and one point to uh
for representative Porter is that the
budget the articles of agreement
distinguish between operating expenses
would be heating lighting salaries
fixing the roof and so forth and capital
expense which is new buildings you know
significant expenses that would be
bonded and so uh that is uh within the
articles of agreement and not a real
issue when you start talking about
dividing up the Capital Property which
is the stuff that had been bonded in any
case after
more than a decade of hostile uh
situations the state then condemned
effectively condemned one of the
district's buildings and it was a need
for a bond so we were now in the
situation where the other towns wanted
had to build a new building and they
needed to raise money for a bond and
they also knew that Mason was not going
to support a bond for a district that
was toxic toxic and hostile to them and
so at that point they had to let us go
and we did get out and we are in a
better place now so uh you know so much
of this was personal for me and one of
the point is that all of this is
dependent on the 20-year Bond cycle
and so what happens is that uh even if
the district is not providing a suitable
education for students we will have
complete sets of children go from first
grade through 12th grade
um in a district which does not educate
them to the liking of their town or to
their parents and there is they held in
bondage while this is going on and the
only time and way that a town can
withdraw as we did is at the end of a
bond cycle
that's
that's most of what I have to say and uh
I think if people have uh you know
questions they'd like to ask me
personally that may not be suitable for
all of the committee then feel free to
talk to me afterwards but I am happy to
take questions thank you very much
representative are there questions
from the committee
for Delhi uh thank you and thank you
representative
um
is uh you said Mason was the smallest
in the three-town district
um what was the uh per student payment
for the three towns in the district
um from instances that I know of
um very often the smaller town maybe
without the facilities
pays much more in per student costs into
the district than maybe the larger towns
I don't recall it's long enough to know
that I don't have that information but
that would be within the operating
expenses and that was never the
operating expenses were never an issue
it was you know Shifting the bond an
unfair amount of the bond payment to the
smaller town
further questions yes representative
moffatt
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question so
you said that when the bond issue for
the new building came up that the other
two large communities let Mason go
and
um could you elaborate a little bit on
this how they let Mason go thank you
representative we had had almost
annually if not annually it proposed
information to withdraw over the course
of a decade or more
and at that when we finally reached the
end of that Bond
the other towns realized that Mason
would vote unanimously not to approve a
bond that would cause them to remain in
the scenic for another 20 years and so
in order to get and Mason
got out the vote we could always have
most of the town at a meeting whereas
the other towns would have a less
representation and I believe it's
two-thirds to pass a bond and so without
Masons will being willing they could not
get a new Bond approved
thank you
any further questions from the committee
thank you very much representative
you're welcome
so we have no other pink cards on this
particular bill at this time uh is there
anybody in the audience would you like
to testify
not seeing any hands going up
thank you very much we will close this
hearing
a lot of issues
okay is that which one is that foreign
equipment
now today
yeah we're good thank you
oh yeah right yeah
thank you make sure that everyone keeps
that
for any of you guys that go through that
little hole over there
because when
as a past principal you should know you
don't mess with technology
okay good
I don't care who did it just leave the
court alone
okay thank you very much everybody we're
ready to go here again we apologize for
the delay due to our our technology
issue uh we are now ready to take up HB
1366 relative to Cooperative School
Board reapportionment and I'd like to
welcome the prime sponsor represent
power thank you Mr chairman and
committee members I appreciate the
opportunity to introduce to you today
House Bill 1366 relative to Cooperative
School Board reapportionment
for the record I am representative Diane
power I represent the towns of Brookline
and Mason in Hillsborough County
District 26.
this is a simple logical and
straightforward bill
that modifies the procedure for
proposing the reapportionment of a
Cooperative school board by means of a
petitioned warrant article
the need for this bill was brought to my
attention by a constituent
under current statute the composition of
a Cooperative school board can be
determined by one of five methods these
methods specify the number of board
members how they are selected in the
terms of the members
changing any of these is considered
reapportionment of the school board
so at this time please reference the
handout that I prepared for this bill as
I detail the issue
this bill serves to address as well as
the change to current statute that the
bill proposes
first under current Statute in order to
place a petitioned article to
reapportion a co-op school board on the
warrant for either an annual or a
special meeting
signatures of 10 percent of registered
voters in the co-op
are required
second in any other case the case of any
other petitioned article signatures of
25 or 2 percent of registered voters
whichever is less
is required for an annual meeting
or the signatures of five percent of
registered voters is required for a
special meeting
thus the issue at hand is that under
current statute a petitioned article to
propose reapportionment of a co-op
School Board must meet an arbitrary and
out of the ordinary higher signature
standard
such a significantly higher signature
standard pertaining exclusively to the
issue of reapportionment of a co-op
School Board is neither a logical nor
warranted this bill modifies current
statute so that the signature
requirement is the same for any and all
petitioned articles in a Cooperative
School District
in conclusion this bill addresses the
unnecessary and extraordinarily higher
signature requirement for a petitioned
article relative to the reapportionment
of a co-op school board and enacts the
same signature standard as for any other
petition article and that concludes my
introduction of this bill Mr chairman
I'm happy to answer any questions if you
thank you very much representative are
there any questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you
thank you
was this the only other card we have
uh the next uh
individual is Eric power
Eric
hello education committee members thank
you for letting me speak I'm Eric power
again from uh from Brookline
and um I just want to give you a
perspective on this in the Hollis
Brookline Co-op which is the co-op
School District that we're in
uh I moved to Brookline in 1994 and at
that time the school board had seven
members five from Hollis and two from
Brookline and at that time Brookline was
one of the fastest growing towns in the
state
and if you looked at the populations
that was Brookline grew so quickly in
the 90s by 96 97 we were
a large percentage of the co-op but
still only had two out of seven members
and myself and other citizens tried to
get the school board to put
in a reapportionment of the school board
to get another member from Brookline for
many years we tried it for a long time
finally in 2003 there was a article the
article was passed and that's when
reapportioned the board to be for Hollis
and three Brookline
it was impossible for citizens to bring
it forward as a petition Warren article
almost impossible because we at the time
had about 8 000 voters in the co-op that
means you'd have to go get 800
signatures just for this petition worn
article which was ridiculous
but we couldn't do it we just had to beg
the school board please put it on please
put it on they finally did so it was
very slow to be changed and then most
recently recently in 2021 they made an
update to the articles of an agreement
making sort of an administrative change
for some reason to change the dates of
the terms of the school board members
and I wanted to
try to reapportion the board again
because now Hollis has caught up with us
and now they're they're underrepresented
and I know it sounds like I'm not
working but I wanted things to be fair
one man one vote
and I talked to the school district
moderator and he says I'm not going to
allow you to make that Amendment so I
can communicated ahead of time you can't
make that Amendment just put it on as a
petition worn article like you do other
ones and I'm like do you know what that
means now we have over 10 000 voters in
Hollis Brookline that means I have to go
get a thousand signatures that's not a
trivial thing to do the standard of 25
is a high standard but it's you know
that takes some work especially in a
pandemic so it's essentially right now
without this change we're sort of at the
mercy of the school board to decide when
they need to be reapportioned and I'd
also like to point out the relationship
with this bill to the next bill coming
up from representative Litchfield House
Bill 1646 that
if that if if that bill is uh passed the
only the school board again would be
controlling when and if they reapportion
the school board the citizens wouldn't
be able to do it unless they meet this
really high standard
so I think that having 10 of the voters
to call uh to to put it on the warrant
is a is a ridiculously high standard I
hope that the education committee can
see that and we'll uh vote ought to pass
on this uh Bill thank you very much
thank you are there any questions
from the committee
not CNA thank you very much
are there any other uh individuals
within the audience who would like to
testify on this bill
not seeing any hands thank you very much
I'm going to close this hearing
can you understand
yeah I'll call upon you to make the
motion too
okay before everybody disappears we are
going to go moving forward now we're
going to exec a bill
yeah here we are
okay the bill which we're going to be
addressing uh is 15.75
relative to a waiver of tuition the
university system and Community College
system that's a bill we addressed
yesterday I believe
time's flying here
so I'd like to we are an executive
session
I'd like to uh recognize represent
cordelli for a motion
uh thank you Mr chairman I would like to
move
ought to pass on Amendment uh
20220060h an amendment to House Bill
1575. representative Woodcock would you
like to second that yes sir I would
appreciate it thank you
so we have a motion to approve ought to
pass on this amendment for 1575 the
amendment being zero zero six zero H
further discussion from the maker of the
motion
thank you Mr chairman
um uh yesterday as we discussed uh the
language in the bill uh it was pointed
out really pertained only to the
university system and should pertain
also to the community college system uh
so that's uh what is done in this
amendment it just adds a second section
uh placing that change in the community
college statute
that's correct it's on line eight right
there of this amendment representative
woodcock
may I speak to it yes yes thank you sir
um I also remind the committee that this
is a very limited bill in its entirety
it was passed last year for the system
uh
civil a child that attends under this
bill either the community current foyer
system or the two-year college system
has to be this in this particular case
is the Son and Daughter of a hundred
percent disabled veteran uh who's been
uh who's been
vetted by the VA and it only extends to
their 26th birthday so it's a very very
limited window and a very small number
of people we'd appreciate the support on
this thank you thank you very much is
there further discussion from the
committee members
not seeing any Madam clerk can we call
the role on this amendment please
repetitive cordelli yes
representative bone
representative
yes
representative Hobson yes
representative Ford
representative Litchfield is a yes
representative luno yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative Ellison yes
Mullen
she's not here
yeah yeah
representative Woodcock yes
representative
yes
representative Waltz
and then um representative Hall yes
and me excuse me and representative Ladd
yes
16 to zero
sixteen to zero is there in favor of the
motion
okay uh I recognize the same people
again here represent cordelli can I have
a motion please
okay thank you
um yes I would like to move ought to
pass on House Bill 15
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 1575 and the amendment is number
zero zero six zero H that we just passed
thank you uh repson Woodcock like the
second motion thank you is there any
further discussion from either the maker
of the motion or though the individual
who seconded no I don't see that okay uh
Madam clerk we're ready to go ahead with
the action as soon as you're ready
rough
representative cordelli yeah first of
all for everybody's clarification we are
now voting on this bill HB 1575 as
amended thank you
go ahead representative cordelli yes
representative bone yes
representative lakis yes
representative mark
yes
representative Hobson
representative Ford
representative Litchfield is a yes
representative luno yes
representative
Cornell yes
Representatives
yes
representative Ellison
representative
representative Woodcock yes
representative Porter yes
and representative Hall yes and
representative Ladd yes
excuse me Madam crook you did not call
on me
okay I'm a yes it's representative walls
but I just wanted before you did the
count I want to let you know
thank you
and that is 16 to zero
consent any objections not seeing any
we did have one of the build which we
addressed yesterday we did get that back
representative Tanner would you like to
make a motion on that Amendment for uh
let's see 1521 uh thank you Mr chair I
would like to make a motion to uh ought
to pass for Amendment
2022-0079h an amendment to 1521. is
there a second represent cordelli
yes
thank you
representative would you like to speak
to your Amendment yes this is the uh
Bill uh asking for the copies of the
current education laws and rules and
we've added
and internet link as one of the options
uh simply because we felt that uh some
of the computers like the iPad which
many of us have does not have a place
for a flash drive or portable storage
device thank you yes sir further
discussion from the second
no
okay so folks we have at for the
committee now is there any further
discussion from committee members
not not seeing any uh Madam clerk would
you please call the role on this
amendment to 15 one
yes
representative phone yes
representative Litchfield is a yes
representative luno
yes
representative wall
representative Allison yes
yes
and
it happened all the time
okay and that is also on 16-0 thank you
very much rep Santana can we have a
motion now please
thank you Mr chair
I would like to move ought to pass
for HB 1521 Dash FN as amended
thank you representative cordelli I'd
like to second that motion represent
Tanner do you care to speak to your
motion again this is a motion to allow
us to have the adequate information
through the law books and Rule books
from this Department of Education that
we need thank you any further discussion
from the second
no thank you further discussion from the
committee not seeing any
yes
so may I ask you to repeat the bill
number please okay the bill number is
1521 FN
the amendment is zero zero seven nine h
M okay and I have
and secondary
that's correct okay
okay
any further discussion
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll yes
yes representative
yes
Senate phone yes representative lakis
yes representative Moffett yes
Hopson yes representative Ford yes
representative Litchfield is a yes
representative luno yes
representative Walsh Walt yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative Ellison yes
representative
she's not here okay okay um
representative Woodcock yes
representative Porter yes
representative Hall yes and
representative lab thank you yes
okay that would be 16-0
and so the motion ought to pass this
amended passes is there approval for
consent from the committee
okay we're good to go we'll put that on
consent and we're now going to close
this executive session and we will take
up the next bill at 10 45.
get a little break
[Laughter]
we'll just do a couple minutes
um I don't know why not because they
have all these different things on one
so this was this bill and it was the
amendment which
care of them there's the bill itself
which you have
and uh
well I think for
like uh the first one was the veterans
thing
it was me and I I haven't done much as
either I would have the adoption of the
amendment in the uh
I did this for a day and a half so
so I have to fix it quickly yeah so you
get you get time now to get all that all
right so I have the 15 20.
foreign
we'll be starting this in a second we're
just trying to get our Clerk
new clerk ready to go here well the
current car presents the bill
Mr chair yeah I understand that I was
falsely accused by my colleague
representative woodcock
about being the reason why the
technology was interfered with and I
just want you to know that I feel
exploited by my colleague because he
made this accusation when I was out
greeting a school group
so
um I so noted to the chair we'll put
that in the record as you're not a
person that's part of this crime yes
that is exactly what I I believe you
could uh file a complaint with the
speaker's office as well all right if
you would help me with that
representative cordelli I would
appreciate that thank you we all know it
was your representative sitting right
beside you
well I I will tell you she was she
however was the first person to violate
your directive first thing she did she
came back in was unplugged it well
I
we're gonna get on to uh the works that
we're supposed to be doing while they're
uh
we're we're yeah we're being heard
throughout the world
uh so at this point in time I'd like to
open up the hearing here please for a HB
1646 it's relative to representation on
a Cooperative School District board this
is the last of three Cooperative School
District board uh uh bills we have today
so I'd like to uh welcome representative
Litchfield
thank you welcome
so first of all thank you all of you for
having me here
so I'm here today to present bill number
1646 this is relative to representation
on a Cooperative School District board I
am representative Melissa Litchfield and
I am District 11 Brentwood New Hampshire
so I I'm hoping that you you all take
mercy on me because this is my first
bill and I am very excited to present it
uh for me personally just so that you
know I'm very big on process and all
voices being heard and that's why I've
brought this bill forward today
this board is this particular bill is
just regarding Cooperative school
districts which we've heard much of
today and I think that we've heard a lot
about the disparities between if you
have a larger population in one Town
versus another
um and whether or not it's Equitable
regarding whether or not each town has
an equal say in what's happening on that
particular School Board
so I personally am part of the Exeter
School Board
um that one's Incorporated in the
mid-1990s at the point in time that that
was incorporated they were very good
intentions that were set but they had
just picked you know let's have this
many members from this town this town
this town and at this point in time
populations have changed but yet we do
not have let's say equal representation
for each of the different sending
districts and quite honestly that's my
concern
um and it's funny because as I sit here
I was I was getting ready this morning
thinking about how I wanted to present I
do do my best thinking after my shower
so probably I should shower four times a
day not once a day and I'm sitting here
telling you how I want everyone's voice
to be heard yet I have a husband four
children two 100 pound dogs and a cat I
have to tell you I'm really good at
tuning people out so I'm feeling a
little but uh but I wanted just to say
that I I'm using that particular board
as an example we have nine members and
some of the smaller sending districts
they don't have the say that they feel
that they really should have for example
some of them have one person that
they're sending and they just aren't
feeling as though they have a voice at
the table and to take it a step further
in looking at that and I I won't
apologize for continuing to go back to
that District that's what I know best
but I would welcome anything that you
have to say because I've learned it
quite a bit today actually with other
bills as far as unintended consequences
so I want to want to thank you for that
teaching moment actually but I would
like to say
that when it comes to electing members
one thing that has also happened and I
don't think it was by intent or design I
think it was by default is you have all
of these towns in a regional district
and for us anyway every single town is
voting for each individual Town's member
so I'm going to give you an example we
have you know one town that has let's
say we have 15 000 voters but yet we
have another town that has 3 000
registered voters the town that has the
fifteen thousand voters they also vote
on who the board member will be for
those smaller towns and at this point
it's come to my attention that the
smaller towns are saying hook hey look
we just don't think it's fair that some
of these larger towns are deciding who
our representative is going to be it's
very important to us that we decide who
that representative is going to be so
the bill is twofold I'm looking to have
equal representation Nation per town on
these Cooperative school boards and I'm
looking to say you know what when it
comes to voting in ascending District
may we have that sending District simply
be the only one to vote on their
representative and um and I want to say
first of all thank you for listening and
I am open to anything as far as
construction criticism or amendments I
do have to say though if for some reason
you decide that you want to exec this
today that would really make for a great
story
but uh that's it
well thank you very much
representative and we'll open it up now
to questions from the committee
representative cordelli then represent
Allison uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative for bringing this
forward
um would it be the case if all the towns
are voting for
Town voters are voting for the member
from each individual Town
it would be hard for
some of those towns to know the person
on the ballot for a town maybe on the
other side of the
co-op District it
would that be a problem in your view
I would absolutely view that as a
problem and I would say just just as an
example right now for example it's we're
coming up on Election time in March
right now people are filing it's a large
district and we're looking at rather
than let's say a person from the smaller
town let's say buying buying their signs
or getting their word out to the people
in their individual towns they're
looking at needing to go out to six
different towns the only thing I can
equate it to is I look at it like our
town has one State Rep yet you know the
senator
represent several towns I almost feel as
though that particular board member
that's going out it's almost as if
they're running for a senate seat you
know they're going out and they're going
toward-to-door in each different town
do you have a follow-up go ahead uh
thank you
um do you think that that uh the current
system as you describe uh favors the uh
incumbent greatly as well
it
it could most definitely favor the
incumbent I'm sure but my concern
truthfully my concern is and I've heard
this over the years
is people that are out there and they're
saying you know what if we can get this
larger town in this larger town just to
support this we can forget about the
other three or four towns and I just
don't feel that that's fair equitable
does that answer your question
representative
representative Ellison uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh just some clarification on
uh
equal representation your concept of
equal representation it looks like in
the bill that we're talking about at
least one
person
so
that and I would assume that would be
from smaller towns
are you talking something beyond that I
mean are you talking some way of
deciding that
Exeter is going to have eight and
somebody else is going to have one based
on population or am I getting this wrong
so my preference would be for it not to
be based on the population
the only thing I can equate it to is
maybe the popular vote versus the
electoral vote and I look at as though
some of these towns the larger towns if
they have 20 000 voters versus a smaller
town that has 1500 1600 voters many
times they're out voted so let's say for
example there's going to be a capital
improvement with a bond that costs 20
million dollars for example those
smaller towns aren't necessarily feeling
as though their voices are being heard
and if I may take it a step further
because I am open to suggestions for
this
it was difficult in trying to decide how
much representation should every town
have and I'm going to go back to and I
hope that's okay this particular example
Exeter there are nine board members
right now which relatively speaking that
is pretty large when you're trying to
get a decision made some towns have
three reps some have two a few towns
only have one representative
it's difficult to say you know part of
me is okay maybe one representative per
town would be sufficient because then we
would have a board of let's say six but
I can understand why some towns would
want two or three members but if we were
to consistently have two or three
members per Town it'd be like herding
cats I think right we'd have potentially
18 board members
thank you thank you thank you are there
further questions
on Jefferson luno
sure thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much representative
um uh for taking my question it
to to follow up on representative
Ellison's question I just want to make
sure I understand this
um this actually deletes the words at
least
and and and
every pre-existing District would have
one resident representative is that is
that how I'm reading this
that is how you are reading this yes
thank you
but but representative as I mentioned if
this board feels that it is imperative
that there is more than one member per
town I would most definitely be open to
amendments I mean it's I think we're all
learning every day sure sure they know
thank you very much thank you
representative Woodcock you had your
hand up and then I see represent Porter
put her hand up as well thank you
representative
almost good afternoon uh you mentioned
in the uh introduction that there is an
increase in population in the district
are you talking the student population
uh from the from the sunny towns where
you're talking the resident population
it's okay if I say both but specifically
I would say student population I'll give
you an example one of the much smaller
sending towns it's interesting they've
had a large increase in student
population
um since
since the co-op was formed and probably
because it's an excellent school system
if I can just say that right probably
because it is such an excellent school
system that being said though the
population has increased
to about 20 percent let's say we're
sending 20 percent of our students we're
in a difficult spot though because we
have 80 percent of our voting population
that does not have children in the
school system too so it's a little bit
of a balancing act but what's happening
at this point in time is some of these
towns and this is a whole other issue I
don't want to go down the rabbit hole
but due to the equalization property
values industry all of that we're not
all paying the same amount right to send
our kids and it's very difficult because
these smaller towns end up spending more
per pupil
so I like I said I just feel they should
have at least some say at the table
follow up thank you chairman
um so if I understand and following up
on representative luno and Allison's
comment so the board would go to I think
he said six thousands in this case would
be six
so the bill as structured this would be
applicable to all the districts in the
state correct
yes so towns that are having no problem
have multiple people on the board
they're going to reduce it down to three
or two or five
without their without their knowledge or
consent
is working
well they'd know once we pass about no
just kidding
um no but I see I see absolutely I mean
that a respectful way it's just my sense
of humor but
yes you're absolutely right there could
be some places that are not having any
issues right now but there's one thing
that I want to go back to and that is
always I'm not big this is my only Bill
that I'm sponsoring I'm not big on
adding more laws or bills even policies
in the school district I'm not big on
adding them but one thing that I always
do say to folks is simply because things
are running well now we don't know how
they're going to be later you don't know
that you're going to have the same
superintendent or the same board member
down the road so sometimes it's best I
think if we take these things on head on
thank you thank you chairman thank you
thank you uh representative Porter
thank you Mr chair
um so I thought of a question while I
was listening to um the other question
so Hillsborough during my school
district is Hillsboro daring Cooperative
School District we have two towns
would this bring our school board down
to two members
yes so I'm going to say this as we
discussed earlier you had brought up
with another bill unintended
consequences
um which I'm I'm learning more and more
about today
um
I do believe at this point in time
probably I would need an amendment to
fix that also in talking and I think it
was representative Woodcock that made a
very good point if we were to have six
sending towns we would have an even
number of members and potentially that
would be an issue as well so I do think
that I would need to work on that but I
would ask you as being the education
committee and is being seasoned I would
really welcome any suggestions you have
to improve this bill because I think
it's a very important one
so I'm I'm mixing my my uh apples and
oranges here but Hillsborough Deering is
also part of SAU
34 which includes the towns of
Washington Windsor Hillsboro and Deering
and when we have the school board
meeting for the SAU
which is different than the school
district
the different towns have different
weights of votes
so that might be something that you
might consider Hillsborough being the
largest town
could have a weighted vote which counts
more than the vote from
you know it might have a value of two
while the vote from Windsor has a value
of one in the vote count we don't it's
not often that it's used but it is
available as an option when Hillsboro
wants to get its way it can pull it out
usually doesn't but it can so I'm just
throwing that out there as a
is it all right if I were to ask you a
question back
um uh well
it's not really where we want to go uh
with uh people at the podium there
asking questions back uh you could
always uh phrase your response and a
response without having to use you know
the question methodology Okay so
I'm just thinking in terms again of the
current board it's what I know best and
I do believe that there is a type of a a
weighted methodology that we could use
and when I have reviewed it
um I believe it's come down to tenths or
something it's very confusing and I feel
as though it's not often
utilized I don't know that it would be
very impactful but on top of that let's
say in the moment of when I'm doing the
executive session right now and I'm
counting up the votes I think it can be
cumbersome in the moment for people to
figure that out and necessarily to make
sure that that is done correctly and I
do wonder if we consider the weighted
vote if we're back with the same issue
that we're trying to correct
how does that chair it's fun any further
questions from the committee
yes representative Mullen
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking the question
so
um I'm going to make the assumption that
the original
proportion of school board members to
school population was based on the same
reason why we have towns that have seven
representatives and towns that have 11
representatives and that is that
uh one School Board member would in fact
be representing a certain number of
residents slash students so in your case
I'm not sure how many Exeter how many
school board members Exeter has but
it would stand to reason that it would
be more than Brentwood is that correct
so
the second latter half of that is
correct as far as the initial paperwork
is concerned I have a copy of that and
it's signed by and apologizes seven or
nine members I should have counted first
I have actually interviewed a couple of
them several times to try to figure out
how the number of representatives were
determined and at this point
they they it's just it was arbitrary you
know that was their response it was
arbitrary we're not we're not even able
to find paperwork any place at this
point in time that
explains to us why each of the other
towns is voting for that particular
District sending member and so I think
to go back to let's say our state house
I don't know that it's fair if members
from Hollis would vote for who the
Brentwood representative is going to be
right I think that so the the bill is
twofold so I don't necessarily I don't
necessarily think that that would be
fair
follow it all sure thank you
um I I certainly understand your issue
with
one town voting for another Town's
representative uh I I certainly
understand that what I was getting to is
the original language in RSA 195 19. um
indicates that the number of board
members would be based on the total
student population or community
population or whatever much as we're
you know we have 3 400 people that we
represent as Representatives I'm
wondering how a school district that
currently has two or three
board members because they're that large
I'm wondering how that school board
member is going to feel if they're now
the only School Board member from that
town
you understand what I'm saying
I live it I've lived it first six years
so I completely understand
and it's a very difficult place to be
um
so my example and I don't know if it's
the best example I just look at it let's
say for example national elections
um
I just look at it as as though where if
we go straight by population the larger
States I feel as though are always going
to determine what happens for the entire
country and I don't know that that's
fair
I'll take the other questions
without seeing hands thank you very much
thank you
and thank you you were all very kind
thank you very much we have one other
card up here uh bear Christina from the
uh School boards Association
foreign
thank you chairman Ladd thank you
members of the committee bear Christino
from the New Hampshire school boards
Association we're opposed to 1646 and
I'll get into a couple reasons why
um first I want to thank representative
Litchfield for her dedicated work on her
local school board you know we were
always appreciative of that as well to
representative
um the the concerns that we've heard
today relative to Cooperative school
districts uh we've heard from different
Cooperative school board members
different communities
um not just recently but over the last
I'd say number of years there was a
study committee I believe it was the
summer of 2017 if I'm not mistaken that
took a look at changing some of the
procedures for withdrawing from
Cooperative school districts I think
that's RSA
19425 so nhsba's larger proposal and I
representative chairman lad and I had a
quick conversation earlier this morning
nhsba would certainly support
um a study commission over the course of
a couple years to look at the entirety
of RSA 195. we've heard about some we've
heard some issues about the withdrawing
uh withdrawing and who has to pay for
what some concerns about how school
board members are elected within the uh
The Cooperative school district and some
of the other challenges with some of the
other the other bills those are just
sort of scratching the surface um I
think with the totality of RSA 195 and
my concern is if we change a little bit
here in this statute and change a little
bit there in that statute
um there's always interplay between
these things you can't just change RSA
195 25 and not necessarily see how that
may impact colon 9 colon 22 so on and so
forth so that would be on hsba's
proposal
um I'm happy to work with you chairman
lad and put together some graph language
for the bills uh the committee's
consideration about putting together a
study commission my estimation that it
would probably take a couple years
um to really do a deep dive into into
how we can um amend these statutes one
of the challenges is the the statute um
RSA 195 as we know it today was
initially drafted I believe in 1963.
um the educational landscape of New
Hampshire was obviously significantly
different in 1963 than it is now
population changes
um uh demographic changes school funding
obviously I will tell you that one of
the purposes of the Cooperative School
District statute was to put
um property poor and property rich
communities together to have sort of a
shared
shared understanding of public education
was for the greater good of New
Hampshire and we also know that it
didn't make sense for every little town
and every little community of maybe two
or three thousand people to have its own
high school or have its own seven
through seven through twelve school so
they would have an elementary school
they would you know uh send the kids to
the Cooperative High School to share
costs share administrative Services
things of that nature to the bill um
itself specifically
um by limiting um only to one method of
of Elections for
um uh School Board officer excuse me
school board members in a Cooperative
School District
um we think that further we have a lot
of talk about choice in this room don't
we um maybe giving the voters more
options to uh to to how they want to
elect their their their their their
members on their Cooperative School
Board completely understand
representative litchfield's concerns
about the larger Town dominating the you
know the when a smaller town has maybe
one vote on the the larger board and the
larger town has three votes I guess I
would liken that to Concord is going to
have more State Representatives than
Chichester
correct
um also within um the the statute
um the the voters have have the
opportunity RSA 195 19a lays out what is
it four or five different ways in which
um the the school board members can be
elected within that Community RSA 195 uh
colon 19B
views and boy states that um
any Cooperative School District pursuing
to any uh created under RSA 195 at a
regular or special meeting can change
the number compensation method of
selection in terms of office so on and
so forth
um I don't think that this needs
requires the 10 petition number
signatures to to get on on the warrant
like the previous bill that we were
talking about I think this could
probably be submitted via petition with
only the 25 voters that are required
under RSA 197 I think it's colon six
um so if if the voters in the in the
co-op don't necessarily like it there's
a method for them to change to one of
these other there's a process to change
to one of the other methods and I guess
the other challenge to more sort of
operationally
um if this bill were to pass and we
um the statute limited the the the the
method of selecting
um members of The Cooperative School
Board to only that one that one method
when does that become a fact active or
what do we do with sort of people that
are with currently within their terms of
office you've got a nine member people
on the on the Cooperative the Exeter
Cooperative School Board I presume three
are up every year for election so you
have to find a way to is that you know
from this point forward we're going to
do that what happens with the remaining
six members is it retrospective those
are someone that I think the other
operational challenges with with the
bill before us
um but regardless
um I I I think that we need to review
um nhsba excuse me things out a
comprehensive review of RSA 195 would be
appropriate
um I'll work on some language and would
maybe ask for the the committee's
support and uh and having at least
having that discussion anyway and with
that I'm happy to answer any questions
the committee may have
thank you very much for your remarks uh
Barrett are there any questions or from
the committee on on the nature of this
bill
sure
go ahead represent Luna so thank you
very much Mr chair and thanks thanks
very much Barrett for um for joining us
this morning thank you um
you you had mentioned I and I noticed
this too as I was sort of looking
through the statutes that um 190 I'm
just looking at 195 18. on planning for
co-ops
formed in 1963 that's correct as you
said and um and yes I mean amended
several times beginning in 71 going
through 2021 but probably most the
language is
from 1963 1963 and
and uh I know we've had there's been a
lot of discussion not just here in the
education committee but um but um in you
know our school funding colleagues and
and those meetings with regards to
smaller schools or or smaller districts
versus larger districts do you think
maybe some of this language
um because it's so because it's you know
more than 50 years ago
um might be impeding
um school districts from considering
um more
um organized agreements thank you for
the question representative
um you know we've seen a trend in New
Hampshire right say over the last 15
years or so
um where rather than consolidation to
save costs we're seeing districts
breaking up saus or breaking up
um we know that there are some
communities that would like to withdraw
from their Cooperative School District
but it's either
financially prohibitive or they get
through the process and realize maybe
isn't worth it as you for an educational
purpose or a financial purpose
um it's very curious too we know that
Maine underwent forced consolidation
2008 I believe that was my understanding
is that really didn't save many costs
and the committee may also want to be
aware that Vermont is just underwent
forced consolidation
um two or three years ago I think
they're kind of in their first or second
year they went from like
160 saus or whatever they call it in
Vermont to like 60 or something like
that so
um I guess New Hampshire however seems
to be trending in the opposite direction
whether or not that has you know
um uh you know the fiscal impact on that
I mean the reality is I mean my guess
you know just from hearing from some of
these it the town that wants to withdraw
always feels that they're paying too
much and not getting enough
it seems to be the the gist of of what
seems to be driving the desire to
withdraw from The Cooperative School
District property it comes down to
property taxes are not much they're
paying
thank you thank you very much is there
for the comment yes representative
Tanner hi
um thank you for taking my question uh
do you think that there's any
um advantage to tying reapportionment on
school boards in Cooperative districts
after the census uh like every 10 years
when we look at the new representation
uh for you know state representatives
thank for the question representative I
had not thought about that but that's
that that may be worth exploring
thank you further questions
uh uh Barrett uh if you could get that
information to us uh regarding the
possible commit for a commission now
we're not talking a committee we had a
committee back in 2017 that I appointed
which had I believe representative Jim
Grenier uh as chair we came back and
made some recommendations to kind of
sliced and diced around the side a
little bit but never really got to the
heart of the issue
and we need to do this uh I know that
Maine has gone ahead and tried to do
some consolidation they got one District
to consolidate that was Rumford and
Mexico right on either side the
Androscoggin river that was kind of a
natural happening nothing else occurred
uh Vermont has a similar
ideology of organizing over there uh now
all their districts must have a high
school within they ran into problems
with Thetford Academy which is kind of a
private slash public and they're still
struggling to get some resolution there
as well so this is a huge issue
throughout we have issues in our own
state with the intergovernmental
districts I know of one
intergovernmental District that's really
upset because the majority of the people
live in Vermont and Vermont is driving
the property taxes in New Hampshire
that's a sad scenario but that's fact so
there's a number of areas where we have
to look at and if you could please get
us that information that you're
suggesting that a commission a two-year
commission which is not a committee
comprised of people that come with
technical background and other members
of the public as well as representatives
and Senators that I believe is this is a
heady topic a very heady topic if if I
thought it was something we could get
concluded in the next two or three weeks
uh through a subcommittee work session
I'd do it but it it's not going to
happen you know it's just it's gonna we
don't have the time to do this and we
don't have the opportunity to bring
people in and really get that
information we need so great if you get
that to us we'd appreciate it certainly
well for the last I'm wonderful seeing
all of you again in person great to be
here thank you thank you Barrett I don't
believe we have it oh we have one other
okay I didn't know we had
uh Eric power
come on forward
thank you I'm Eric power from Brookline
as I said before I served on the halls
Brooklyn Cooperative School Board
I know a lot about Cooperative school
boards might be a subject matter expert
in some people's opinion and I do like
the intent of this bill
um I do like the fact that I think
there's a problem if there's members if
if a large town if all the towns are
voting for the members for all of the
uh member districts I think that that's
not a good thing I think that in a
representative government I think it
makes sense for
town a voters to pick their
representatives from town a and town B
to pick their voters from town B
um I do think that there should be more
than one member though I think which
that's a good tweak because you know in
Hollis Brookline we would only have two
school board members and that's not
really going to probably work
um but it should be proportional I think
to the uh the populations and
representative Tanner just brought up
thing I was trying to drive with the
moderator that I just was looking at the
Census Data from 2020 and saw the Hollis
Brookline split is not accurate and
there's a more suitable way to
reapportion it says go ahead and do a
petition word article I mean where that
went and go get a thousand signatures so
um I'd like to also point out that 195
19B doesn't specify a method of
reapportionment it's it's actually 195
22 which was the subject of the previous
bill that does require 10 percent of
Voters so that is a problem it's really
up to the school board Because unless
somebody can get 10 of signatures which
is a very high bar
the other thing I'd like to point out is
when there's a vacancy on the school
board we had one of our school board
members become an assistant
superintendent and she had to resign
with one of three members from Brookline
and the current law is is that the
members from Brookline picked the
replacement
so we had three members then we became
two so there was me and another
gentleman that got to pick the
replacement because it was a board
member from Brookline so it makes sense
that voters from Brookline should pick
their the Brookline reps so I think that
that's a very good thing for this bill I
think that does need some amendments but
I think it's got some good good ideas
and intent in there and the one man one
vote principle should be followed I
think to make sure that you have
proportional representation and you know
we also got to consider co-ops that have
as few as two and I know there's some
that have as many as 10 and you have
co-ops that have
um you know 1400 voters in a case of
Lincoln Woodstock and you've got
winnekonet that has over 23 000 voters
so it ranges all over the map so you got
to really look at a rule that would make
sense I think that you know I would look
at this in the committee to put possibly
modify it to do before emotional but
ensure that there is you know that every
District elects their own members so
that's my feelings on it I just want to
provide that to you from my background
and experience and I would be interested
in helping out with the commission if
there is such a one um in the future
thank you thank you very much for your
input and I sat with a rep from
Brookline for many years in the house
here and I heard this story over and
over and over again and uh it's time to
get some resolution it really is we're
there so thank you very much for your
remarks today are there any questions
to ask Mr power
nope thank you very much thank you
okay there's no other pink cards right
Mr clerk correct so we're going to close
this hearing
and
we are ready
yeah we have a few seconds don't we here
what time is it about quarter at 25
after 27 27 okay
so we're going to be starting the other
one up in about three minutes thank you
nailed me all the time Chris Chris Adams
if you remember him from our committee
oh yeah Brookline has been hammering on
this topic for years
that was Jack Flanagan's big deal yeah
oh yeah yeah and uh uh Jim Belanger
sure
over there
foreign
so much
right
now
asleep
nobody
else
crazy
oh nice
[Music]
projects
no it made it worse
thank you
we are going to go forward now with the
last bill this morning it's HB 1276
this is a bill allowing for school
district budgets and warn articles to
include include cost per student
information
for clarification purposes I understand
there's an amendment on this but we're
talking about the bill now these the the
not the prime but a sponsor the bill
here can allude to the fact that they're
they're suggesting some changes to the
bill that Amendment will not be acted
upon until it becomes ours at an
executive session
welcome
uh good morning uh
chairman Ladd and committee members of
Education my name is Doug Thomas I'm the
vice chair of Science Tech and
Technology committee but I'm here to
introduce House Bill 1276 and Amendment
[Music]
2022-0044h the prime sponsor
representative Harley had a last-minute
issue at home and unfortunately was
unable to attend she severely is
disappointed because this would have
been her first bill that she would have
submitted but I'm gladly
uh I'm happy to introduce this bill and
the amendment I'd like to correct one
thing you cannot introduce this bill to
this committee it has to be introduced
by a person on the committee during the
executive session
so you can allude to it and discuss the
contents of what you're suggesting be
amended but it's going to be have to be
introduced to this committee by a person
on the committee during executive
session
my apologize Mr chairman I was given
incorrect information by several people
within the state house that anyone could
introduce and an amendment to the bill
prior to it being introduced you can
bring it forward and provide it to a
person on the committee and it will be
introduced at that time absolutely yes
if
with your pleasure I would like to speak
to the amendment if if I could yes you
can okay thank you the amendment was
needed because there was an oversight in
OLS as to the intention of the original
Bill the intention of the original bill
was to make this a requirement and it
came out of OLS as being an enabling
bill so the amendment that that I have
here speaks to it as a requirement which
is really the only major change in this
bill the the impetus for this bill is
that we feel transparency is extremely
important uh in today's age and we feel
the voters are owed information when
they go to vote on a school warrant on
the school budget it would be very good
information to have on the cost per
students it's a very simple math on this
bill it basically it says that you would
take the the school budget amount on the
warrant article and you would divide it
by the number of students at the school
district reported to the state and that
would be your cost per student that
would be determined of course by the
school district
before it gets onto onto the warrant
article we realize there are other costs
involved in in schooling but that's not
the issue here the issue is on on the
school warrant article the budget amount
it's good for for voters to know what
that amount would be per student
um
there's not much else to say about this
bill I think uh again I want to
reiterate it's important for voters to
know uh what they're voting on and this
knowledge I think is important I think
there are people that are coming behind
me that will support this bill I I did
present this to one of my school board
members who was in complete agreement
and if there are any questions involving
the technical aspects of of how this
would happen you could you could ask
questions there
other than that I think um done if
there's any short question I know your
time is limited you have a lot of bills
this year so I would defer questions to
the people behind me and I thank you for
your time thank you very very much
representative uh are there are you
willing to take short questions or we we
do have one hand up over here on the
side uh two we have two hands up so
representative Porter then represented
is your
thank you Mr chair and I'll promise not
to make it too long of a question the
figure that you want on the Warren
article is including special education
costs Transportation heating maintenance
of the building all the whole budget of
this SAU
the school district divided by the
number of children or only the
educational part teachers teachers aides
purchases of textbooks things like that
which one are we using my understanding
is whatever amount whatever dollar
amount appears on the warrant article
that voters are voting on that number
would be divided by the reported number
of students for a cost per student I
would defer any technical questions to
the latter to I think we have a speaker
coming behind me that could probably
better explain that
thank you representative Litchfield
I have a similar question I'll ask it
and if it needs to be deferred that's
fine
um I I had a similar question and this
directly goes against what the doe does
for a and I'm sorry because you're not
the prime sponsor it directly goes
against what the doe is presenting as a
cost per student the doe does remove the
cost of Transportation it does remove
special education and it does remove
Food Service which should be
self-funding so I'm just curious what
the response that I just I my concern is
that the number wouldn't be accurate so
I my question to you is why are we going
directly against what is posted on the
DOE
well my point would be is that whatever
amount is being shown on the warrant
article and let's say uh uh for a sake
of argument let's say you're showing uh
15 million dollars to vote on on the
warrant article that figure
no matter what it includes is on the
Warren article that's what the voter is
voting on and if you just divide that
figure by by the number of students you
would come out with a cost per student
realizing that's not the only cost
they're you know the state puts in money
and other and you know Federal and there
are other issues involved here but on
that Warren article that people are
voting on if they're voting on 15
million dollars and let's say it comes
out to be
argumentally speaking 16 000 per student
that would be good information for the
voter to know it gives them some idea of
what they're they're voting on in
response to any other technical
questions about what you just mentioned
representative I would defer to I
believe I have a school board member
coming behind me who could probably
speak to that
thank you very much are there further
questions of Representative Thomas
thank you very much
oh I can see it representative Woodcock
thank you representative
um on the first I'm looking at the I was
looking at the amendment that we're
alluding to which is different from the
bill in my mind beyond beyond the uh
enabling legislation
and that on line three it talks about
that it says all budget items or any one
article having an impact on the budget
so
if the school board is bringing a budget
through
that would be every individual item on
the budget
this is all all budget items or any worn
articles there's two different documents
so that would that would mean to me
anyhow every line item on the budget
which being some becomes the warrant
number we'd have to also have a notation
on it not not in the uh Amendment but in
the original bill
right my understanding is that the
amendment that was done just in the last
couple of days uh
the intent is for just the total figure
not a line item okay but the bill itself
has if if that in fact is found to be
what the bill actually says I'm I would
hope the committee would take action to
uh to interpret that to be just a total
figure we wouldn't want it line by line
that would not that's what it says
though thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you further questions
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman for your time have a good day
thank you
next
next uh is Bob is it Slater s-l-a-t
welcome
thank you Mr chairman and committee
um I'm on here on behalf of Londonderry
School District uh resident long-time
resident and uh currently a school board
member
I'm in support of this uh House Bill
1276 and just wanted to uh come up here
see if anyone had a question on how we
arrive at this or or why but I think the
transparency of this dollar amount is is
good for the community members as this
question comes to us
several
I won't say hundreds but a lot of
question comes to this during the budget
season and during the school year
um on just what it costs per student to
go to our school district so I'm here
for any questions again I'm in support
of this and would welcome any questions
representative Porter
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question are you here
representing the Londonderry school
board or are you just here as a
Londonderry School Board member I am
just here as a Londonderry School Board
member and a resident of Londonderry
does the Londonderry School Board
support this bill I I we have not talked
about this I'm here just representing
myself thank you represent a boom
thank you just to clarify what I I read
in the uh in the article it says the all
School District budget to any school
district warrant out of having the cost
impact
the num uh notation printed next to the
affected article stating so in other
words the main article saying you will
spend 15 million dollars that's the cost
if there's another article saying we
want to do this and that's going to be
the cost is that is that correct
um I will go back to our representative
that presented this I'm not sure what
they mean in their language here
um but basically what we have on the
warrant is our budget to operate then
we'll have several warrant articles that
are voted on separately and approved so
I would say the main cost would include
at the end of the day the budget
definitely you could take that amount if
approved by the voters or the default
budget that would give you a dollar
amount listed on the warrant for voting
yes yeah just reading it said
on that every one article Faithfully
says next to the affected article will
state the course for students so
yeah and that could very well be and
that would be another part of
transparency that if you were to vote
yay on this of say you know three three
hundred thousand dollars it would be
this much per student
you're welcome
further question represent uh Tanner
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
in the calculation of Simply taking a
figure a number dividing it by the
number of pupils and I'm not sure
whether you're using like average daily
enrollment or not is not really an
accurate uh picture
uh of what the school is using the money
for
um don't you think wouldn't you think
that perhaps on the Warren articles and
a lot of towns do this put at the end of
the warn article the effects on the tax
rate in other words article Warren
article number one is going to raise
your your tax rate 0.01 or whatever
would be a more accurate way than trying
to include or trying to make this simple
math
which does not include as representative
Porter had said before special ed costs
um costs of homeschool students coming
in and using different facilities like
the sports facility or perhaps chemistry
lab doesn't include
um
Transportation Food Service
toilet paper you know all kinds of
things so
um don't you think that the having
simply on the Warren article the
percentage of increase on the tax rate
would be a more accurate figure for a
voter and a taxpayer
yes per that's a great Point um the main
the main Budget on the warrant could
have cost per student because that's
basically the operating the Warren
articles from that point on could have a
percentage added to the cost per student
uh the individual items beyond that
because those are not incorporated into
the original budget so to your point
um doing it on the budget
um the I think you could come up with
the easy formula 4 000 students on 80
million is is X on the warrant articles
you could do a percentage would would
increase by this because there Warren
articles now do tell you spell out it's
two cents per on the tax dollar if
approved already every individual
warrant article as well as the budget
sets the tax rate so I think simple math
on the main budget and then you could do
a percentage on the additional line
items
you have a follow-up on that yes you may
um so yes that and that in fact is what
the town I live in
um actually tries to tries to do
um but they don't do the per pupil the
simple math what I'm what I'm trying to
uh convey I guess or ask is do you think
the simple math of taking and again
there are various ways to compute who
how many pupils are actually going to
your school and being paid for by your
school the simple Act of dividing one
number by another number is not
transparent does not reflect
uh the true cost per pupil Johnny Jones
might be twenty thousand dollars a year
you might have somebody come in with a
special ed student that was a hundred
thousand dollars a year and yet you're
then by the simple math just just kind
of massaging it over the the whole thing
I think what this bill is trying to get
at is to the point
um I I think this representative here
had spoken about is at the department of
Ed Transportation uh special ed is not
included I think for transparency for
the taxpayers this is a is a Formula
across the board per student and I I
agree with you special education some
cost per student are much higher than
than regular students or or some may be
outsourced but we still hold a
placeholder for any homeschooled
children so if they decided at a future
time they wanted to come back into the
building we have to have that position
so I don't think that but I think this
is just basically to tell the taxpayers
we're at 20 000 per student All In
you know as an average And if every
every town was able to do this you could
see where that is there are different
formulas and that that would probably be
have to looked at and make sure the
state that they're all going by the same
formula to come up with this cost per
student and and just to have it on the
warrant gives a taxpayer an idea of what
they're paying per student at that point
reps on luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much Mr Slater for uh being
with us this morning and also for your
uh for the service to your community and
and School District in Londonderry
um would um would the um
um
would the numerator here the cost of the
the budget also include the um the
district special education costs that it
covers for students who attend charter
schools
um that that is a good there would be if
it's a cost to the district I would
assume it would okay oh would and a
follow-up yes so so would the
denominator in this in this simple
um um equation also include the um the
number of students that attend charter
schools
if if I assume that whether they attend
the charter school or home school I
would say it would because we have to
include them as well in our budget okay
thank you very much thank you
representative uh Porter and then
representative Litchfield thank you Mr
chair and again thank you Mr Slater sure
um I served on my school board for one
term and it's a number of years ago so
I'm forgetting how the budgeting worked
but I know we got a significant amount
of federal money that came in that we
used is that money that Federal money
that comes in is that part of the budget
figure that people are voting on
you're saying the yes or grants that
we've recently got that's right but
there's other things too that would come
in that were part of our budget paid for
by the federal government
are they included in our Revenue they
are are they included in and then
expending them is included in the
expenditures so if that budget figure
includes Federal money
that is not going to be taxpayer money
is that
also included in your cost per pupil it
would be yes okay yeah that's how we
arrive at our budget as the revenue is
offset and then that breaks down what
the taxpayers
are
uh representing you know our tax dollars
and then is all added in for our total
budget and we would break that down per
student but that would that not give you
an inflated opinion about what was being
spent per student if the money was not
coming from taxes I mean I I presume
your issue here is to let people know
how much tax revenue how much your of
your taxes how much is costing you per
student but if it's Federal money or
state money that's not directly being
paid by your taxes but it would be
included in your figure that that's a
fair question and and that's a great
point you could you could do it at that
formula you could say whatever the what
the rate is you know on the taxpayers
this is our cost per student I think
what they're trying to do here is just
what the overall cost is for student
Pursuit uh per Community all in okay
thank you
thank you uh represent Litchfield do you
have a question
I do thank you
rather than this being placed into law
where we are mandating that this has to
be in a war article could this message
be complete conveyed at the deliberative
session and or the town or School
District meeting
it that that is definitely uh should be
done at that time as well but it would
be nice for the people that aren't
attending the deliberative we don't as
you know a lot of towns don't get much
activity at the deliberative sessions or
even budget we have our public hearing
tonight we may have 20 people in in the
town come to the public hearing tonight
to go to the deliverive so we just
looking at this if the number was there
when they go to vote they they see
exactly what that cost is per student is
is the reasoning for this bill
yes
just
if a question representative Porter had
I just want to make sure that I
understand so the number that is on the
Warren article let's say for example
this coming year in March that is the
number that needs to be raised and
appropriated for the following school
year
that number is just including expenses
it is not including any type of revenues
as she mentioned
so wouldn't that number possibly be off
because for example special education if
you have someone that could potentially
be 250 000 could we be getting federal
aid or could we even be getting Medicare
Medicaid payments excuse me plan and
then you would look at the deductions of
Revenue off of that to come to your tax
rate for the for the community
thank you yes thank you
are there further questions
representative Moffett famous share is a
co-sponsor am I allowed to ask one quick
question of this uh of the speaker
you're not presenting are you uh no go
ahead thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question thank you for being
here uh again as a co-sponsor obviously
I'm very much for transparency and
that's the intent of this uh which is
why I signed on but my question if you
could clarify this for all of us in
terms of cost per student if there's a
warrant article that is for a new roof
for the building that uh is pretty easy
to understand that that is a cost per
student that affects every student if
there's a Warren article for new band
uniforms say uh
it sounds like the intent of this uh and
I know there's an amendment the intent
is to divide is is uh has been said all
the students into the cost of the Warren
article but if the only beneficiaries of
the Warren article of the band members
would this not should this not be
divided by just the band members as
opposed to the whole student body can
you clarify that a little bit
um
and and In fairness nobody knows this at
the time and it's it comes out of the
budget
so whether it's the band section there's
a lot of other areas that certain
students or or Falcon faculty will not
touch of that budget but it's an overall
budget for the school district to
operate so in simple math everybody pays
a little bit of for everybody to be able
to be educated and do co-curricular
activities or sports or whatever it may
be so for simple math that's what it
takes to run the budget whether someone
does sports or or does band everybody in
their own way is is paying with this
with tax dollars got it thank you
very much are there further questions
thank you very much for coming here
today thank you Mr chairman
uh Barrett Christine of the School Board
Association
thank you chairman Ladd good morning
again is it still morning just under the
wire I think
um nhsba is opposed to House Bill 1276
and I do have a copy of the amendment
here first I would like to as always
thank Mr Slater for his work on his
local school board we certainly
appreciate that
um a couple different points I hear the
word transparency
um being used as one of the
justifications for this
um to the extent um that that is a
driving uh desire behind this bill and
to the extent this committee can make um
a uh an amendment that impacts towns we
would also ask that towns then be
included to this and the cost per
resident of that town
um be included on the warrant article if
transparency is good for school board
that should be good for all elected
officials so why school boards are being
singled out here I don't necessarily
know
um representative Moffett you asked the
question
um that's sort of I was asking you know
if if we're putting a 500 000 hours to
do a roof what does that have to do with
the cost per pupil and you asked on the
question about the band uniforms my
larger concern was about
um school districts raising and
appropriating 25 000 to put in a special
education trust fund are we going to
figure that out for just those special
education kids if so
um I would find that a little unseemly
to be quite to be quite honest with you
so um you know I think some of the
language is a little bit I know there's
a definition of budget in RSA 32 colon
I think it's three
um but your budget for purposes of RSA
32 is different than your than your
budget your budget includes Federal
money grants things of that nature
whereas your budget for RSA 32 is you
know your money that's being raised
locally
um and being monies of being raised and
appropriated locally so
um those are on hsba's concerns with
this RSA 32 is intended to apply to all
local government towns Village districts
school districts so carving out these
exceptions or these Provisions solely
for school districts I don't think fits
into the scope of intent excuse me of
RSA 32 it should apply equally to towns
Village districts water districts and
whatever else
um and then again concerns about
um you know the cost per pupil of the
band uniforms or the special education
trust fund or improvements for the
football you know the football field or
things of that nature so with that I'm
happy answer any questions
are there any questions of a Barrett
Barrett I have one question for you
um the Department of Education puts out
every District every each year has to
submit the doe 25 form correct which
reflects your assets your expenditures
and your revenues
they also reflect a cost per pupil
would that be a better figure if a
figure is released to what it costs to
educate a student in District a district
B whatever thank you for the question
representative one of nhsba's long
standing frustrations with the use of
cost per pupil for any determination is
that it does there's a difference
between a cost per pupil and a cost to
educate a child
your cost per pupil includes your
gasoline your heating oil
the roof maintenance
um your payments of New Hampshire
retirement system things of that nature
it does not reflect the true cost of
actually educated child
if we want to talk about the cost to
educated child
guess we're talking about adequacy Aid
it's in 3 700 bucks a kid for the
state's determinations all the other
stuff that it takes to operate a school
district does not necessarily mean we're
educating a child so I
apologize when I need to get that off my
chest if you're looking for a static
number a stable number I think yeah I
mean go to go with some dra reporting
form or the ms-25 or things of that
nature but if we're going to talk about
cost per pupil we're going to talk about
cost to educated child those are two
very different things
yes they are any further questions for
Barrett
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you very much sir do we have any other
so with that I'm going to close this
hearing
yes
you have it
okay represent Bauer
is that the only one we haven't done or
thank you uh my name is Eric power I
live in Brookline I served on the
Cooperative school board for Hollis
Brookline for a three-year term
and I'm in favor of this bill I'm also
here representing the school district
governance Association of New Hampshire
I'm the vice president
we're an organization that seeks
responsible governance of academic
opportunity with accountability
transparency choice and fiscal prudence
I think this is a really important bill
because it provides transparency to the
voters and you you know I know that
there's presentations out there and
there's information on websites but
there's a lot of Voters that out there
that either come to a traditional
meeting and are looking for information
and all they see is the warrant
or you have voters that come to the
deliberative session see the warrant and
then in the sb2 towns we have in school
districts we have the sb2 ballot which
has the only thing some people see if
they just if they don't go to the
deliberative session so making this
information present on the warrant I
think is really important because I
think for a lot of Voters that's what
they see and that they make decisions on
that so having this information
available is very uh it helps spread the
information increases transparency
I know that I talk to people around town
and I said you know we're spending
twenty three thousand dollars a student
like what they don't really understand
that that number and you get the
argument about what the Department of
Education says well they only say we
spend sixteen thousand but the the truth
is is that the costs that the taxpayer
is actually 23 it's how much money are
we raising and appropriating divided by
the number of students average daily
membership reported to Doe
then you say well you're getting
revenues from the state and the federal
government
what I'd say that's also our money too
we've paid the taxes that's money we
paid to the federal government we pay to
the state government we pay locally so
it's really all of our money so I think
to take that out and say it's not
something you have to worry about I
don't think makes sense
I'd also like to mention that tax impact
is uh not mandatory on School District
warrants it's something you have to vote
to actually put on there some
school districts put it on there by good
practice
um in Brookline we did a petition Warren
article and got it passed last year so
this year they have to put it on they
didn't want to put it on so there's a
resistance to show how much things cost
and I think making it mandatory or at
least making it enabling legislation as
originally proposed is important
um
I'd like to say also that um
I did send in a uh to the chair and vice
chair I sent some suggested language
changes to this bill potentially to make
this enabling legislation just like the
others were proposing and also for your
consideration when you get to Executive
session having enabling legislation so
that you could actually publish the
Department of Education proficiency
numbers for the highest grade in the
school district under the idea of how
much is it costing and how much are we
getting increasing transparency I think
that's a very good thing for people to
see I think that helps people make
informed decisions how much are we
spending and what are we getting for it
using a metric that is measurable every
year and use the last grade that's
reported because that's the one sort of
the terminal grade so like grade 11 in a
uh you know a 7 through 12 School
District
and
um so I would encourage that the the
committee look at possible amendments
but also look at putting this out there
to help the taxpayers we have a big
challenge here in New Hampshire where we
have some most places are seeing
declining enrollments and we had rapidly
increasing School budgets this will help
inform the voters that that they're
they're spending their money in a wise
way and it also helps them make good
decisions when they're whether they're
at a traditional meeting or they're
voting on sb2 at The Ballot Box thank
you very much thank you very much uh
representative are you willing to take
some questions here
yes I will okay representative Porter
thank you Mr chair and again thank you
Mr power
um the original bill is enabling the
amendment is is not enabling
it's a requirement that all towns school
districts do this
is your intention to have it be enabling
or a requirement that's my first
question
the school district Governors
Association wants to make it uh
uh required
I I personally would be good with either
way if it was enabling like we have for
tax impact now you have to vote to put
it on there and then the the amendment
that we talked about make that enabling
where you would choose the school
district would choose or not to report
the proficiency scores
so I'm a little confused
um so then could you tell me again the
name of your organization and where I
might be able to find information about
it's where you get your funding and
things like that we are an all volunteer
organization
sdga and H
School District governance Association
New Hampshire
okay thank you
are there further questions
not seeing it thank you very much thank
you
are there any further uh folks in that
in the audience who have not sent in
pink cards or who have
thank you very much we shall close this
meeting
okay we'll come back and start at one
o'clock
pretty tough to get some of these
figures they want you know I I think
people need to be aware what it's
costing
but we kind of get kind of some kind of
system where it's done uniformly
throughout the state or else it's going
to be okay
foreign
this is
all right
mistakes were made
okay good afternoon everybody uh we're
the education committee is ready to go
for the afternoon docket here we have
one o'clock HB 1298 FN relative to
eligibility for the education tax credit
representative cordelli's already seated
in waiting to present so welcome
representative cordelli
uh thank you very at the floor thank you
Mr chairman and uh honorable colleagues
for the record I am a state
representative Glenn cordelli
representing Tuftonboro Moulton Borough
and sandwich in the beautiful Lakes
Region
um HB 1298 is a very simple program
the tax credit scholarship program has
been in existence for going on uh 10
years and there have been a growing
number of similar programs around the
country a number of them I think
something like a half a dozen just in
the past years have been implemented in
other states
this legislation makes one very simple
change uh changes one digit it changes
the 300 percent family income cap to 500
percent of federal poverty guidelines
up until now it has been 300 percent
and concentrating really on lower income
families
but as with way too many government
programs we forget people who might be
categorized as lower middle income
families
I believe that they should have the
opportunity as well to find the best
education option to meet their child's
needs
and with the new education Freedom
accounts legislation that went into
effect this past summer
the one
problem that has been communicated to me
about the program is the income cap
um so rather than uh deal with an income
cap and a brand new program I thought it
was wiser to take a look at this program
and raise the income cap here as this
program is well established
and I'll remind everybody that this is
based on donations to the tax credit
scholarship fund and uh in return the
business or the family would get a tax
credit against their income there is no
government money involved in this
program at all
um
in the past year the report issued by
the scholarship children's Scholarship
Foundation they have to add issue an
annual report to the Department of
Revenue Administration for anyone who
wants a copy I have some here
but there were 640 scholarships uh
issued
based on the donations to the fund and
in law 40 percent of those scholarships
have to be for people for children who
qualify for free and reduced lunch which
is a family income of 185 percent of
federal poverty or less
but in actuality in 2021 school year
63 percent
of the scholarships issued went to uh
families act that 185 percent of federal
poverty or less
so
the point I think it's in the fiscal
note from the Department of Revenue
Administration
the number and amount of scholarships
awarded is a function of the amount of
the donations received that's very
important and if you look at the fact
that there's a requirement for 40
percent free and reduced scholarships
but 63 of the scholarships went to those
families I I think that if there is any
concern about
um uh wealthier families getting
scholarships uh I think it is uh not a
real concern I think that
scholarships will go to uh people with
lower family income
so uh I would ask you to um consider
raising this cap and providing funds for
some of those families who are looking
for assistance for their children to
find a better education and who possibly
don't meet the current 300 percent of
federal poverty figure for either the
education Freedom accounts or this tax
credit scholarship program
I thank you very much for your attention
thank you very much representative
cordelli a question representative walls
thank you very much
um so if the money is primarily going to
low-income students why is it we need to
raise the cap
uh I am hopeful that
um the number and amount of donations
will grow in the future providing the
ability uh for uh scholarships to be
awarded to uh families whose income is
over the 300 percent figure
108 000 per year
at the top the marker for the top 20
percent of income earners in the US
right now is 20 so you were raising it
so that the family the income earning
cap is going to be probably so probably
the top
up to anybody except the top 19 percent
of earners will now be eligible for this
so when you say it's not going to higher
income people by raising it to the 500
level by breaking that 20 threshold
isn't that then allowing higher income
earners to take advantage of this credit
um again the number of scholarships
awarded
um is based on the amount of donations
received
um it's not you know anyone who
qualifies uh excuse me anyone who
applies can get a scholarship
um and also um when I looked at the
census bureaus American Community survey
five-year average for 2019 it appeared
that the
income threshold of 500 percent
for New Hampshire
would exclude about
one-third of New Hampshire families so
the qualifying I'm not sure where the 19
percent came from but for New Hampshire
it looks like
um
one-third of families would not meet
this new income cap to answer your
question it's based on the federal
numbers where the threshold on the
national level for the top 20 percent of
earners is one hundred thousand dollars
so by breaking that one hundred thousand
dollar Threshold at least on a national
level you're allowing people in that top
20 percent to qualify for the
scholarship
again my my numbers we're looking at the
New Hampshire figures for the five-year
average from the American Community
survey
representative Porter
thank you Mr chair we all have different
numbers here because I looked at the
federal poverty level for 2021 for a
family of four and the federal poverty
level is 26 500 according to them and if
you take 500 percent of that would bring
the family a four income up to 132 500
so we have all different figures going
around that's the number that I uh found
as well okay so um my second question is
you said that you were hoping that um
you'd get more contributions however one
of the
one of the ways that people can
contribute is a percentage of their um
interest in dividends tax and that's
being phased out the New Hampshire
budget so that would indicate that those
people would not be able to contribute
any longer where do you see anticipate
the increased funding coming from uh yes
you're correct um I think it's a
five-year phase out of
um that interest in dividends tax
so those people no longer be donating to
the scholarship fund
um but uh
My Hope Is that businesses
will be contributing more and I think
that um
uh honestly the um
maybe Scholarship Foundation and and
others can make businesses aware of uh
the program and increase donations that
way I think that there is
um uh or a lack of information to some
businesses around the state that this
program exists
further questions representative Tanner
thank you for taking my question is the
giving and going Alliance still part of
this tax credit scholarship
organization
um I think that that is a a
registered group with the uh dra but I
think that their funds are their
programs administered for them by the uh
CSF the scholarship children's
scholarship fund of New Hampshire
they are a registered program with the
ra for this yes I believe so
um the uh director of the children's
scholarship fund could not be here today
because I'm an ill child but um we can
have that confirmed
yes so what was the pool of
that the
uh because I believe your report is from
2020.
yes um I can give you a copy
okay thank you um I have 10 or 12 copies
and I can
send
um and I'm sorry you can I I didn't keep
a copy for myself actually so uh
could you
kind of like it for the record
keep a copy for the be on yourself
um
and my apologies it looks like there
might be a page missing from
the copies that were made
yes I don't seem to find out what the
page page two is missing I'm sorry what
I I will send electronic copy of the
report to everybody this evening
are there further questions
representative woodcock
thank you chairman
thank you for hopefully giving me some
more information
a a parent is currently involved in the
voucher program
are they eligible for this as well
um the education Freedom account program
you're referring to yes
um
uh
I would have to go back and look at the
uh final version of the education
Freedom accounts
um in the uh the house version that did
not uh get passed I think that they were
eligible for both
but I'm not sure uh the final version
that is now in law I'd have to go back
and check that
that further further question
representative
yeah it's more a point of order I've
been giving to the Scholarship
Foundation from its very beginning and
we did not it was not at at that time
allowing for anything other than
businesses to get the tax credit we
didn't do it for the tax credit so I was
just saying that anybody can give to
this the tax credit incentivizes people
to do so but anybody can and I would
certainly uh recommend to anybody
because the con the kids who get this
are okay what we all knew that needs to
really be a question to the presenter
right now
uh yes I did
um and uh you are correct um uh I
probably should have pointed that out
because uh we also have uh donated uh
without taking the tax credit
trying to get the my other part of the
question
there are limits oh
a level uh for businesses
uh
I do not recall uh seeing that but um I
will double check that as well there is
a total I think there is a total yes
there is yes
for a business for all the program okay
yes yes okay so so I just want to get
back to my actually get to my question I
have the fact thank you in the
background
for one thing
for representative Tanner's benefit
right now RSA 77 is not in the statutes
rehab right here one of the things that
you talked about the other day
go ahead represent thank you if I could
um just um I was just handing a sheet of
paper from the Department of Revenue
Administration and it says not more than
one million dollars uh in any given tax
year for each business each business yes
okay so
so I want to understand this correctly
in the program the the program that
benefits from that of the company
is losing that over the next five year
period of the phase out
is that correct yeah for individuals
you
if I there's a company contribute up to
a million dollars a year to the tax
credit to go to this program
now indeed I'm sorry the donation goes
to this program and you can get 85
percent tax credit on that amount that
you donate okay so my so my question is
it your comment of it's not doesn't cost
the state anything
because it costs the state up to one
million dollars per year per thing if
they go that far is that correct no okay
um that's that's
um that money uh never goes to the state
um you cannot uh
deduct that that all is not going to is
going to go to the state in any way
shape or form it could be used for uh
investment it could be donated to other
uh Charities and so forth so
um I think that um it is uh uh been
found by the courts that that is not uh
government money in any way shape or
form
you cannot assume that that money would
go to the government
okay
Allison
uh thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question uh assuming that your
your projection or your hope that
the amount of money does not grow in
this fund
and we move the threshold up to 500
percent would there be families who
would qualify under the current 300
percent who would not be receiving money
because some of that money which is
going to be the same amount is now going
to families that are making up to 132
I don't believe that that would be the
case
yes
uh
well let me follow
if you've got the same amount of money
and you've got more families applying
for it because now the threshold goes up
to 500 percent
are there going to be families that
would now qualify it seems to me if
you've got more the same amount of money
and more families are going to be some
families who aren't going to qualify are
going to get less money is that was that
correct
um I I think uh I don't know if I'd
agree
you're hypothetical that the amount of
money going into the scholarship fund
being donated to the scholarship fund is
not going to increase at all
and that there will be more applications
um maybe due to this bill I
um I think that's a hypothetical
assumption that I wouldn't necessarily
agree with
thank you for further questions
yes representative Mullen
thank you for taking my question
representative sure in uh quickly
looking over the report that you just
shared with us
um I I noticed there's a page in which
it States minimum and maximum
contribution distribution
uh of scholarship funds for instance uh
at Acton Academy which is the first on
the list the minimum amount given in
scholarship was 2248.26
you on the page that I'm on I believe so
okay so also um on this page there's an
entry for uh five thousand dollars to
Kimball Union Academy and it's one
scholarship so I'm assuming that that's
one student who received that I'm
wondering if you can tell me
what's what are the qualifying criteria
that would have one student get five
thousand dollars and uh a student at
Nashua Catholic get
174.38 cents I mean how is that
determination made between who's getting
what
um
I'm not sure if uh someone behind me can
answer that but um I think there are
Provisions in statute um related to that
um including there's a required average
um scholarship amount that's in statute
um as well as looking at uh family
income and uh
um the cost of uh scholarship excuse me
cost of uh an education option that
they're looking at I think there are
different factors that are weighed in
that determination
further questions from the committee
not saying thank you very much
is this the next card right here thank
you
uh do we have Sarah Scott here
welcome
all right uh thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the
opportunity to provide testimony here
today my name is Sarah Scott and I'm the
director of Grassroots operations with
Americans for Prosperity New Hampshire
and on behalf of AFP New Hampshire and
our activists all across the state I
want to urge you to support House Bill
1298 a bill which would provide an
opportunity for more Granite State
students to access a personalized
education by increasing the eligibility
requirements for the education tax
credit scholarship
especially over the last couple of years
we've seen so many families taking
advantage of new and Innovative
education options for their kids whether
it be remote learning micro schools
within their local public school pods
within their neighborhood or
homeschooling families have had such
varying needs and are really going to
continue to and students are finding
environments that better fit their
learning style many of these families
would not have had the opportunity to
pursue these options if it weren't for
the education tax credit program
so in talking with a lot of the families
that are currently participating in the
program they are absolutely ecstatic to
have been given the chance to have their
children learning in an environment that
really helps them to thrive
these are students who struggled in
their old learning environments for a
variety of reasons whether it be
bullying learning disabilities or even
just a difference in surroundings and
learning styles
at AFP we really believe that empowering
New Hampshire families with greater
educational options is critical to
giving every child the freedom to
discover develop and apply their talents
in order to find fulfillment and success
in their lives and since it's beginning
in 2013 this program has helped
thousands of students and with this
legislation we would have the
opportunity to expand this to families
who are still struggling and not able to
pursue these opportunities on their own
I know it was brought up earlier about
why the cap needed to be raised based on
some of these families incomes I just
wanted to give an example of throughout
the past summer when families were
looking at the EFA program I talked to a
number of families and one mother came
to me because her kids were struggling
in their current school one of her
daughters had been bullied pretty badly
and she was looking for another option
the problem is that unlike most people
throughout the first year of covid her
income actually went up I know for a lot
of folks their income went down during
that time but for her her income went up
it was a one-time thing her income went
down again the following year but
because of the way the income
requirements work she actually misses
the eligibility based on fifty dollars
so raising the income cap would provide
for families like hers where she is
again going to qualify but not until
next year so this would give an
opportunity for those families to take
advantage of these options and find a
different option for their child
so it's for these reasons that we ask
that you recommend this legislation as
ought to pass and allow more families to
choose the educational environment that
works best for their child
happy to take any questions thank you
very much Miss Scott represent Porter
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Scott you might be the wrong person for
me to ask this question but my
remembrance when the education tax
credit program went was passed that the
children going to other schools
there was um a lot of flexibility in how
you would measure their achievement and
the one that I remember being the only
one was parent satisfaction survey
in your statement you mentioned that
this allows children to have better
educational outcomes and I'm wondering
do you know if there has been an
increased um
a different way of measuring the
educational achievement of the children
who are getting this money other than
just parent satisfaction survey uh thank
you for the question
um I don't know what the scholarship
organization is using for that I believe
they have some kind of record of that
I'm just not sure how public it is but
I'd be happy to reach out to them and
get you the information I would really
like to know like is there any kind of
testing that's being done like in the
public schools or is it just um
conversation that people have I believe
that
for the kids who are in private schools
they go through the regular testing that
the school chooses for the kids that are
homeschooled they go through the regular
assessments of either a nationally
recognized standardized test uh
portfolio reviewed by a certified
teacher or the New Hampshire State
assessment as well
representative Ellison uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh would it be your position
that additional students would be served
by this program if the total donation to
the fund does not go up it stays level
uh if the total amount of money stays
the same then I would assume that we
can't grow the program to expand any
more students I don't believe the number
would drop for those currently in the
program thank you
for the represent Woodcock thank you um
you may be the wrong person uh my
question it's about money I might be but
you probably you may have the answer all
right
I have two questions or one question two
parts the first question is the
application for the scholarship program
is that an annual application or is once
I receive a scholarship it's good every
year assuming I stay in that income
level
um I'm nearly positive that it's
reviewed every year okay that's one
thank you may finish the circle yes
thank you
um
do you know if the the number of folks
who met the criteria last year the
income criteria and did not get
scholarships
do I know if they met the requirement
but how many didn't get it yeah like the
wait list I'm not sure what the wait
list is I know that they have definitely
reduced the wait list over the last year
the program went from serving 600 kids
up to over a thousand so I do know that
they increased it quite a bit I know
they had a waiting list of probably six
to eight hundred students last I checked
so with that increase of over a thousand
right now I think that they have served
a large portion of that waiting list
thank you thank you thank you further
questions
not see any hands up thank you very much
thank you
thank you so we have gone through all
the pink cards of those that are asked
to speak today
uh not seeing any others coming in I'm
going to close this hearing
and the next one
next starts at 1 45 so we have a few
moments before that time
I'm gonna go look in the old one
I thought it was
thank you
foreign
oh yeah
sure because
my question all right good thank you
questions
as far
everything
else
yeah
before we converge
okay
a little bit
foreign
okay we're going to get ready for the
next hearing for our members of the
committee uh I have some information for
you here
during the course of every year we
receive an annual report from the
Department of Education regarding
bullying in the uh various schools
throughout the state
I have the annual report here I got
multiple copies for you I will place
them in the office and just grab one on
the way out there's plenty for you so
that we're good with that
there's also a report here on the use of
school restraint and seclusion for the
2019-20 year we've got that also made
for you copies of it so these two
reports will be in the office available
rather than you know they're pretty
heavy so rather than pass them all
around here we'll have it out there for
you
yes
they're they're all for that year it's
no excuse me the one for the school
bullying is for
2020-21 so that's more current
and this one right here is 2019 20.
I have had a couple requests by way of
email for this information so this is
available
exactly exactly
yeah
okay
um
we're going to go ahead here with the
next bill which is HB 1676
relative to making incentive grants for
school districts that improve in certain
assessment scores
welcome representative Moffett
thank you Mr very happy to be here
looks a little different from this seat
for the record my name is uh uh
representative Mike Moffett for
Merrimack District 9. the beautiful
towns of Canterbury and Loudoun uh so
very simply this measure would make
funding available to Department of
Education to award uh and reward schools
that show Improvement
uh in standardized test scores
it's intended to identify reward and
reinforce uh achievement
now currently is is most of you know we
provide funds that essentially uh in a
sense reward failure in that third grade
or schools that have third grade test
scores there are lower deficient they
get they get money
um and I understand the logic behind
that uh the intent being to try to help
schools that are that are struggling
with with reading and yes understand the
intent there but uh some folks are
concerned that that approach is a
disincentive as opposed to an incentive
to um
to achieve
so we originally drafted some language
that identified specific assessments
um to to use as part of this initiative
uh and also percentages of improvement
um using 2019 scores is a Baseline
pre-pandemic
but after meeting uh with a team of four
uh doe Department of Education officials
including commissioner we opted for Less
prescriptive language the language that
you see in front of you uh which will
allow more discretion to doe to
implement uh the concept
and it cost a million bucks uh you know
and there is a FN there's a financial
note which you see
but knowing of all the sentiment here
and elsewhere to find ways to enhance
school funding we thought this incentive
based the smartest very modest incentive
based initiative would be a good way
to try something Innovative that could
reward achievement and get a little bit
more money to some schools and that's
the essence of it and I'd be happy to
take any questions if there are any
thank you very much uh representative
walls
thank you
but I haven't
been from the revenue stabilization
account which we all know is the rainy
day fund and if you look at section 9
colon 13-e Roman 3 it makes it clear
that the money is specifically to be
used only when there's a revenue
shortfall and I'm not sure that what
you're proposing is permitted under
current rsas and I'm wondering if you've
examined that issue sure thank you
representative for the question
um in terms of a revenue shortfall uh
I've heard a lot about Revenue
shortfalls in in public education so
that I think is part of the logic behind
uh applying this in terms of there being
a revenue shortfall and I I did we did
have the Folks At Doe in OLS you know
review all the language ahead of time so
hopefully that kind of answers your
question
yes so we know it's not the job of OLS
to determine whether something's legal
or constitutional they put out bills all
the time that people requested are
unconstitutional so I don't think that
that's a valid reason to view this as
being constitutional but there is a
hundred and twenty I get the revenue
notices several times a month there's
over 120 million dollars in excess
Revenue that's come in that's over and
above plan right now so I think we would
be very hard-pressed to say that the
statements any sort of Revenue shortfall
quite the contrary the state seems to be
Awash in money right now have you seen
those numbers and are you aware of that
uh yes thank you representative very
aware of the the revenues
um overall that the state has in fact as
they come in we're hearing some nice
reports uh in terms of some of the
business tax revenues coming in
um the the notes which I already
mentioned the notion of a revenue
shortfall uh has to do with uh the
education Community uh again uh I pray
we've all heard that there is uh
you know trying to find ways to find a
little bit of extra money here there or
however to send in the way of public
education
um and this is a way that we saw is
being able to do a little bit of that
and at the same time identifying and
rewarding achievement
so the uh the ass the fiscal note has
been addressed in the the legal piece of
it has been looked at as well and I'm
sure it'll be continued to be looked at
as you're doing right now
well I commend you for a creative
interpretation of the RSA
[Laughter]
representative woodcock
thank you representative good afternoon
um I have I have two two points or two
questions one question one point
um
I take concern with the language of
talking about that we reward failure in
our schools
clearly we have schools that are
underperforming
I'm not sure we were rewarding them and
trying to help them
but to that extent I would ask you
if we really want to improve scores
why wouldn't we want to with your money
invest more in Innovative programs or
Innovative programs that may help
schools that are already
less funded or less successful
particularly when we know there's a
correlation between schools that invest
more money in their students and their
performance scores
thank you for the question and in terms
of innovative programs first of all uh
in terms of the notion of rewarding
failure that
that is a phrase that I've heard used a
lot and I would
uh stand by that in the sense as I've
already said that clearly schools who
have low third grade test scores get
more money and that's something that
some of us are not that comfortable with
uh
also you know if students are identified
in terms of special needs
um
that I think is something that deserves
uh support and so forth
um but
I think we need to look at
when we offer funds for certain things
if
we create disincentives uh and and we'll
once we get to exec session and down the
road we'll talk more about this but in
terms of innovative approaches uh I
think we think this is an Innovative
approach to you know find some money uh
make sure that it's uh
you know in accordance with doe policies
and rules in statutes and once that's
done to make this money available in
terms of
uh rewarding success
representative are you have a follow-up
I do okay just a short one
we know from the data we've looked at
over the last year
on scoring
the schools that have the ability to
invest more money
are showing a higher percentage of
proficiency
than schools that don't so what you're
saying in essence is let's give more
money to the school districts that
already have more money and their kids
are already doing better already
thank you for your question and I don't
see it though I think that schools would
be would be competing against themselves
they're not competing against any other
school all they're doing is competing
against their own Baseline of test
scores so yeah I would disagree with
that premise I think schools are not
compete against each other they're just
simply competing against themselves and
if they improve their own test scores
then they'll get a reward for that is
that one last question does that in that
I didn't see that in the bill it said
that that they're doing an analysis of
the annual scores and looking at an
ingredient Improvement sure the initial
language that we had put together is as
I already mentioned was was very
prescriptive we trying to have some good
definition to this concept this
initiative and I think I already
mentioned that we uh had identified
specific assessments and specific
percentages of improvement for the
schools to achieve in order to get up to
a fifty thousand dollar reward but after
we met uh several of us met with the
team At Doe they looked at that proposal
and came back and and they asked for at
do we asked for this language which
would enable them to have some
discretion into how they uh developed
the criteria to make the awards so
hopefully that answers your question
thank you yes it does thank you
represent Porter
thank you Mr chair and I have a couple
of questions if that's okay
um
I'm remembering research that I've seen
in the last years
that
indicates
over and over that the best indicators
of how well a child will do on a
standardized test
is the income level
in the educational level of their
parents
the second thing that I know is that in
places where Merit Scholarships I mean
excuse me Merit pay has been
um suggested for educators
Educators themselves have roundly
said no we don't want that because we're
not here for competitiveness we're here
to work together to educate the children
in your concentration looking at this
bill did you ever think about other
measures of achievement for schools
other than a standardized test score
for example in my school district the
scores are traditionally low but we had
a lot of children graduate and do
wonderful in the Arts and Music and that
sort of thing which are not measured on
any standardized tests but certainly
they are achieving at a high level with
that on those things
did you think about another measurement
for achievement other than the state
tests
sure thank you for your questions uh two
of them the first one you mentioned uh
media uh median income and and
um income level and educational level
especially educational level of the
mother but the income level and the
educational level of the parents
sure income higher educational level
better the kids going to do in the test
sure and there is a correlation between
income levels which has been well
documented in achievement but I kind of
touched on that when I responded to
representative woodcock's question in
that uh the schools were this to move
forward in some fashion would be
competing if if you want to use the word
competing
um and try to think of a different word
they would be simply uh
working looking at their own scores and
trying to find ways to improve those
scores however that may be locally and
were they to do that
then they would be identified and
rewarded in terms of your uh point about
other measures of of
achievement or whatever you'd like to
call with students you know are doing uh
very valid point and uh
I do think uh that in the mix of
measures to be identified and is is uh
to reward you need some metrics uh I
think many of us think and without some
uh numbers without some metrics uh
that's a problem so this uh as I said
initially had some specific prescriptive
metrics that Doe asked that we not
include in language so to answer your
question uh without numbers or metrics
uh it's hard to how do you know if
you know it's and I know there are ways
to qualitatively identify Improvement
but I think there is a place a little
place a small place for some numbers and
metrics in addition to that and that's
what this would try to do
yes okay so when you're using the
metrics that within the school itself
are you measuring
are you measuring the Improvement of the
same group of children from year to year
or are you taking this year's third
graders and comparing them to last
year's third graders which are two
different groups of children with two
different groups of family education
levels and income levels sure thank you
for that question and there are all Yes
or else to answer your question uh we
are aware there's all kinds of variables
and the intent that we conveyed to doe
uh was to use the 2019 scores
and I won't go into the assessments that
we recommended that they use because
they ask that they have discretion to
identify the assessments so the intent
was for example uh fourth grade you know
there are certain annual exams tests as
you know for fourth graders eighth
graders 11th graders that that type of
thing so
if the average score for the fourth
graders in 2023 uh
improved by whatever metric doe
identifies over 2019 then they would get
in a an award or reward according to the
to the uh to the formula that would be
established
and and just to again to make sure I
answer your question completely
um so you're asking about like a
longitudinal situation where the same
students would be tested and the answer
would be that's not the vision of this
the 2023 third grade or or fourth
graders 20 the 2023 fourth grade scores
would be contested compared to the 2019
fourth grade scores by a different group
but the pedagogy uh would presumably you
know uh different pedagogies would be
tried to see if they could improve the
scores so different different groups
representative Mullen
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um I'm not sure how I feel about the
implication that
teachers might work harder or students
might
experience a higher quality education
because a cash prize is being offered
but
um I would Echo
representative Porter's concerns over
this year's class of third graders being
identical to next year's class of third
graders and therefore being able to be
compared that seems like apples and
oranges to me to a to a certain degree
I'm wondering if uh you have asked
somebody from the Department to be here
today to discuss the criteria and
whether or not socioeconomic class rural
versus Urban uh what what sort of
elements for evaluation are going to be
included I'm wondering if uh if there's
somebody here that can do that
well thank you for your your points and
your question I'm not sure if uh you can
see behind me Mr chairs is there someone
is there one person here from doe today
we have one yes sir there is one person
here from doe uh and that back to your
your question uh it's philosophically
um
course I come from this is an athletic
component to my journey and the
rewards Athletics by definition you keep
score and there are rewards for success
and I believe and many others believe
that that model is one that certainly
Bears consideration and application in
the academic realm as well
um and an incentive uh if this incentive
um prodded or encouraged some schools to
perhaps try some different uh mode of
instruction or you know perhaps in
seeking such an award uh you know
parents may get more involved for
example uh it depends upon how this is
presented but uh press I I and folks
like myself have have no problem in fact
we like the idea of incentivizing
success
and having some measurable metrics and
goals
um as opposed to you know a nebulous
situation where you just uh you know
trust that that uh everyone's going to
do a good job which I I think happens in
most cases but to have this additional
Dynamic out there uh many of us think as
great Merit we would like to
um
let doe try something Innovative I guess
to use the word some representative
Woodcock used earlier
thank you uh I have uh one question and
uh you know let uh represent cordelli he
has of course apparently too uh several
years ago when we rewrote some of the
accountability statute uh we
wrote it so it doesn't uh strictly uh
point to achievement
it also appoints to points to growth
and when we introduced legislation to
try to get accountability for the third
grade reading proficiency levels that we
have that under differentiated Aid
we did compare we were requesting that
the third graders that were in the
previous year
be compared to that same group of kids
that's next year in the fourth grade so
it's Apples to Apples
um I think that that so I would ask that
that be a consideration that we're
comparing this child same child to the
in both years there another issue which
is associated with that that we've got
to be very careful on
there is a high transcency level in some
of these districts and schools such as
Manchester
and you definitely are not going to get
an Apple to Apple there and then on
Converse there's some very small
districts that only have
less than 40 kids in the district or 60
kids
I I hesitate in trying to
get give an award out to something so
small where our statistical data starts
pointing to a specific student
which we know that we don't do with any
aggregate testing for less than 10 or
less students
so um and that our achievement tests are
done at these grade levels where
oftentimes there's only seven or eight
kids in a class in the in the grade
level
so somehow there should be some
accountability built into that how we're
going to do it for those small districts
and then and taking account the
transcency and and care and comparing I
would think Apple to Apple
yeah thank you Mr chair and and that I
understand the thinking and the point
that you're you're making
and uh
if you follow up on what you just said
take staying with as I said to
representative Porter if you stickle the
longitudinal approach even that uh
you're going to have students who come
into a fourth grade who weren't there
before students who leave so that would
not be perfect either in terms of uh you
know your your sample group or whatever
so there's different ways to to do this
you could have the longitudinal approach
or the approach where you just have uh
the
specific grade not the specific body
which of course is is going to change as
well
um but as I've said a couple times
already
um
we don't though the sponsors did not
want to be overly prescriptive with doe
we wanted to give doe as we want to with
localities uh local control if you want
to put it in those terms and make a fund
available for doe to have to reward as
you said earlier districts that for
whatever reason somehow do things
differently or better and their their
scores improved in a measurable fashion
so great questions uh again uh
I we the sponsors have chosen to uh
listen to doe and to trust doe and so we
backed off from imposing our original uh
as I said fairly prescriptive approach
and just let them have some latitude to
try to come up with something
Innovative and different that could be a
model that could get some more money to
schools and uh
perhaps provide some some inspiration
and uh
and a model for other schools
representative
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
the question are you aware With No Child
Left Behind the federal government was
evaluating different grades but third
grade for example for the next year is
third grade and and that was their
method of achievement
not swallowing the same kid they were
following grades
thank you representative right uh of
course No Child Left Behind his normal
effect but their approach
was non-longitudinal right
yes and I'm aware of that
representative
on the other side there representative
yeah
thank you um thank you for taking my
question uh Sports were a big part of my
journey too both as a participant and as
a coach in public schools and
um we're not professional sports so we
don't get rewarded with money we got
rewarded with medals or
achievement awards and clearly
achievement awards can be given out at
any time uh representative Mullen and I
both had schools that were designated by
the federal government as outstanding
schools and they received an award
the doe was there as well but uh
certainly
um I I would ask why
why put money on the table when
the usual and customary
procedure in education for awards is
non-monetary and a school that a
gets an award for being a high
functioning school you know I think they
got a flag and you know they were able
to have a ceremony involve parents and
parents came in to see how great it was
I would think that that would be
and it certainly has a set of criteria
that they evaluate schools on and the
doe does part of that evaluation
um I'm wondering why all of a sudden we
need this big chunk of money that we're
going to give doe to hand out to schools
thanks for your question representative
um well in terms of a big chunk of money
it a million bucks used to be a lot of
money uh you know I today it's uh it's
not so much
um
I well it it
really I remember when that was a lot of
money and uh but it is kind of a it's a
nice round figure to uh to put out there
as part of this uh you know possible
proposal but I I gotta say when you talk
about rewarding achievement
um scholarships inherently reward
individual achievement
um that's uh that happens all the time
if if a student individually uh
demonstrates academic proficiency or
success then then they get scholarships
so this is uh not a scholarship per se
it's a it's a different approach uh to
award some some rewards some collective
success and uh I
not sure again what the criteria
ultimately would be we want doe to have
the freedom to to develop a formula
criteria that they think would work uh
we did put a limit of fifty thousand
dollars uh to a uh
to a reward reward or an award to a
school
um but again uh this is a way to reward
the team uh the school the community as
opposed to just uh having individuals
when uh Financial reward
my second question really uh is there is
there a committee At Doe or you keep
talking about this group At Doe that is
helping you develop this is that going
to be the same committee that's going to
decide uh which School receives how much
money or or whether is there going to be
a committee set up or are you just
simply going to take the yearly reports
of schools by ranking and just chop off
the top five and give them the amount of
money well I'm not sure if you
understand the the
the program is described the schools
would be competing just against
themselves not so the notion of the top
five that's not part of the equation at
all your question about the the uh the
team At Doe uh again that as I've said
several times we want to allow
discretion to the uh to the department
to uh create uh using their own
expertise and human resources and
background and to develop the ultimate
uh formula criteria for the uh Awards
and uh honestly I think when if this
moves forward
a school that uh
in seeking to uh
distinguish itself and and improve some
scores and if they were publicly
rewarded uh then there may be some best
practices that would flow from that that
a neighboring school would would say
they would see school a uh did something
different and they improved their scores
and they get a fifty thousand dollar
what did they do
um and so I see value to to that that's
part of
it's part of the historical American
competitive uh ethos that some of us
think uh the education World which I
most of us might myself certainly been a
part of that ethos I think might serve
the education World in a good way if if
we give it a chance
representative Cornell
thank you and thank you for taking my
question you seem to be using school
district and schools interchangeably and
I don't know which you mean because
Manchester we have 21 schools
so is it a Manchester schools will be
competing against each other for awards
or is it Manchester as a whole school
district competing with 12 000 students
competing against a town that has a
hundred students
sure thank you it's a great question and
the uh the division he attended this was
for a school uh not a the district comes
into play in some cases you have to work
through the district
to make an award and it I Manchester
certainly is different from certain
other schools but the uh intent was for
a school
um to Simply improve that school's
standardized test scores
right right so uh
there are some schools there are
districts under themselves but like I
said you make a great point that I think
doe would
as as if and when this moves forward
they would need to you know clarify
District versus school you know who or
how they would be competing for an award
they'll be
needing to be defined sure and this is
just
just school districts
the intent was
originally for uh school districts
and if you look at line three it says
rewarding school districts so any public
school district uh is opposed so so
parochial schools would not be eligible
would have to be Public Schools
representative Ellison uh thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
I'll make this quick uh I would not have
gone down the road of of using Athletics
for this argument but I my specific
question is are you aware that the NFL
the NBA and the national basketballs
baseball association all set up their
annual drafts and give priority to those
teams that have done the worst in the
previous season
uh yes a very aware of how
that works and and um
again as you know the the intent there
is to try to improve the the bad teams
that have done poorly yeah I that that's
a
that's but of course with public schools
New Hampshire
or Far Cry from the NFL the NBA but but
I yeah I'm tracking you sure
thank you
okay we have room for one more question
and then we've got to move on here
represent Porter thank you Mr chair uh
Mr representative Moffett are you aware
that we had two public schools in New
Hampshire who received the national
School of Excellence award this year
no I couldn't tell you off top my head
about that no so don't you think that
that would be an incentive to folks but
yet it got no publicity
I I think that any school that wins
Awards should I used to be in PR and uh
I've spent so much time uh the universal
system and Community College system in
addition to teaching to doing everything
I could to get attention from the media
for uh academic success and and I that's
been my world so yes I I think that
that's wonderful I think that that type
of recognition uh is a place for it and
we need to shine a light on it and this
I think would uh would complement that
it would be another arrow in the quiver
in terms of uh
recognizing achievement the Department
of Education might have made a big deal
out of it do you think
I would support uh shining a light in
success any way that we can thank you
very much
thank you very much uh representative
a Moffett we do have one other person
here and that's from the Department we
have Nate Green from the Department of
Education
and he's willing to
um come here as as technical advice or
answer any questions we may specifically
have of the department in relation to
this particular bill
is there are there any questions for
represent moan from Manchester
Bedford Bedford excuse me oh hey
everything south of Concord is it
wonderful wonderful representative Vlad
I will indulge you the error because I
was born and grew up in Manchester and
it is near and dear to me still so I
will indulge you that slip of the tongue
thank you for that kind remark you're
quite welcome uh thank you for taking my
question and uh Nate actually uh sat
with representative Tanner and I at the
educational Excellence award dinner so
welcome to House Education it's uh good
to see you again thank you
um so I have questions about uh the
paragraph that is Roman 2 in the bill
that talks about the criteria to qualify
for the awards
um I I guess I would like to know what
the process for application will be what
the committee who determines
who who's going to receive the awards
will look like and what the demographics
are that will be used to evaluate or
rank or uh for instance
socioeconomic status size of the school
whether or not the school is urban or
rural
um maybe uh you know sort of previous
Trends in standardized testing and what
measures would be used
sure
um so for the record my name is uh Dr
Nate green I'm with the New Hampshire
Department of Education uh one of the
many hats that I wear at the department
is uh director of the accountability
system for the Department there are a
couple of different avenues that we
could go down so I don't know exactly
how this would be implemented I do see
uh further down that there is a 541a
ability so it's possible the department
could adopt uh some rules around this
and and really spell out the procedure
when we talk about things like growth
um there's two different ways that the
department measures growth right now one
is just a standard growth across all
students and that looks at two years of
growth on our state standardized
assessment system and when we're talking
about comparing grades to grades or
students to students it gets down to
actually an even finer level of detail
there so we take students and we put
them together into a group of all the
students in their grade who got the same
score as they did and then we look at
how that particular population of
students did across two years so it's
both longitudinal but it only Compares
students with other students who scored
in the same score range that they did
and then looks at an average growth of
that particular group of students and
then we take those averages together
when we create School profiles and
District profiles and put them together
as averages so that's your standard
growth indicator that's one way that we
could look at this and we do rank
schools and we look to see which schools
are showing the highest levels of growth
and which schools are showing the lowest
levels of growth
um and I do want to point out the growth
is not the same thing as proficiency you
can have a school that has a very high
level of growth but a very low level of
proficiency we measure proficiency on a
scale of one to four four being most
proficient one being least proficient
you could have a school that has a large
number of students move from a level one
to a level two so their students are
still not proficient but they showed a
large amount of growth similarly you
could have a school that has a high
proficiency and still has a high level
of growth if a number of students move
from a level three to a level four so
that's one way another way that we
measure growth is called our growth
Equity indicator and that uses the same
formulas except it applies a weighting
system to particular subgroups of
students so it applies a heavier weight
to free and reduced lunch students
students that have IEPs and are
receiving Services Under special
education and students that are English
language Learners and so that particular
looks at the growth of the school but it
waits heavily in favor of subgroups of
students that we know traditionally are
underserved
so both of those could be a way that we
could rank schools and looking at this
particular Bell
follow up yesterday
correct me if I'm wrong Dr Green
uh
schools that are already
highly proficient
May in fact have lower
score lower on a growth model if there
is not
a whole lot of room to grow if you will
to the ceiling for that grade level is
that correct
it's it's possible but because we're
looking at two years worth of data the
standardized test scores go up each year
in terms of the score ranges and so even
if you had a whole school that scored
level four in the first year that we
were looking at it we know not every
single one of those students will score
a little for the second year and then
the third year when we're looking at the
data so there's still a lot of variation
in there
one more thank you Mr chair uh
representative Moffett indicated that he
had been working with people at the doe
are you in fact one of those people
uh yes so myself uh one of my colleagues
Scott Courier who's the administrator of
the Office of Public Schools uh and
Caitlin Davis I believe have all met and
discussed this bill okay thank you very
much you're welcome
we have uh within statute rrc 193 e
which has the indicators for acquiring
an adequate education
most of those indicators apply to high
schools or the end end of the term of
K-12 were going on for
future work and post-secondary joining
the military uh percentage of uh kids
that are not suspended or expelled
attendance rates all that's in the
indicators to identify whether a school
is meeting some of their goals that
we've set out in statute might that not
be a way to identify but I'm also
concerned that do we already have a
process in the schools for excellence
such as the small school just north of
us the bath Village School we received
one of those Awards several years ago
and the criteria was that we look at the
instruction we looked the building we
look at security we look at all the
components of education and and talk
with parents and and we have a school
that's really shining bright
um would that be another way of
identifying without having to award the
money
it's one of the things that we do to
identify Schools of Excellence in our
state yes
the program is a federal program it's
the Blue Ribbon Schools of Excellence
program one of the drawbacks however is
that we're Limited in the number of
schools that we can nominate and award
each year we're limited to a maximum of
three as a small state in New Hampshire
so we might have 10 or 15 in fact we're
going through the process right now
looking at the Blue Ribbon Schools for
this coming school year and I think we
had about 16 or 17 schools that all met
the criteria but at the end of the day
we can only choose three of those to
give those Awards out to
so a follow-up might it be another way
of doing it though that we have our own
State School of Excellence program and
rather than identifying just those that
are based on that National Standard to
develop our own standard and recognize
that way
absolutely
thank you
Braxton Woodside wood
getting tired we're back thank you
the governor is back okay um
Dr Greene good afternoon and thank you
for helping me through this
um in looking at the document in the the
range of the student performance on the
Statewide education Improvement and
Assessment program you were talking
about growth and assessment in this
particular case when you're when you're
ranking schools with the student
performance be be the same as the
student proficiency
yes
so that would be an academic proficiency
score we wouldn't be looking at the
growth
so the growth is the amount of growth
students have shown on the proficiency
scale yes okay
and it's two separate indicators so
elementary schools have four primary
indicators there's the growth and the
equity that I spoke about we also report
just the level of proficiency so that
the percentage of students that are
proficient within the school and then we
have a fourth indicator for elementary
schools that looks specifically at our
English language learners
so
the Improvement in student performance
that should be rating for this
particular Merit uh cash reward would be
the academic performance
strictly yes
thank you thank you are there further
questions
yes represent luno thank you thank you
very much Mr chair thank you very much
Dr Greene for joining us this afternoon
um but the um is it am I correct that
the bill excuse me in um
and uh uh Roman 2 does let would allow
the department to consider other
replicable data
it does yeah and follow-up such as what
representative Mullen suggested uh
possibly socioeconomic um conditions
absolutely okay and we do that with a
variety of other programs where we might
start with the assessment and the growth
data but we consider three or four other
five variables in addition to that when
making final selections so and one final
follow-up on on that so would a um could
potentially a school district that that
is under um social you know has has low
low socioeconomic conditions seeing
seeing modest growth or modest
Improvement in in performance that could
be considered say a bigger move than uh
than a larger increase in performance in
a district that had let's say it's just
more affluent sure okay yeah and in fact
as we were talking about the Blue Ribbon
Schools so we nominate three schools a
year but one of the requirements is also
that one of the three schools must have
greater than 40 percent free and reduced
lunch student populations so another
program that takes into additional
factors beyond academics and a final
follow-up on that one Rick and you
probably know what I'm going to ask
have a hot clue sure you do so so with
with with with frpl data
um uh
sort of cratered right right now
how is how is that
um you know what what are you using as a
as a metric for socioeconomic
conditions because and this is a this is
a thing that is a question yeah that's
that's why I thought you'd yeah
that's a that's a question though I have
a larger answer than I could provide
I think we're looking at a number of of
different uh variables uh because that's
what you raise actually touches a large
number of programs at the department
that all rely on federal funding that
rely on those numbers
um and so the the impact of not having
either good numbers or or you know what
we've gone through in the last two years
with free reduced lunch numbers just not
coming in because we've had other
avenues
um we're we're working on that thank you
very much I I probably that does touch a
lot of programs like even Career
Technical education that whole Carl
Perkins is based on f p pre and reduced
uh program it is yeah
so are there other questions for
Dr Green right now at this time
thank you very much thank you chairman
do we have any other cards for this
particular bill
thank you so at this time we'll close
this hearing and prepare to go into the
next one
you know a kid in basketball though down
to Linda there what does the coach do
coach benches
but but we also have different divisions
for our kids to compete in you know a
small school cannot compete against
this bill doesn't speak the school at
all anyways
read it
right right yeah you know you just do it
because
my school was up where I was on the old
Iowa Test basic skills California
achievement tests we always scored in
the 90th percentile it was
Community where a lot of parents
we've really never showed much growth so
because we're always there so we can
improve yeah and that's where
representation was right
yeah
no
fourth floor episode
this is kind of contrary to where we
were going
and getting weightless from Strictly
rope
yeah I like
yeah
we're seeing a little bit of growth
State program to recognize the schools
oh that's right
it's a pizza party
or the robin sticker on the work when
you finish remember that
Oh wait we're waiting here I'm sorry
excuse US Representative cordelli we
were in our little because
discussion up here
does everybody have one that's going
that way
no no we just we just do what we do
okay thank you that's okay we're ready
to go ahead with HB 1137 this bill is
relative to the duty of school boards to
provide education and representative
cordelli is ready to start so welcome
again
thank you very much Mr chairman and uh
committee colleagues for the record I am
state representative Glenn cordelli
representing tufton Borough
moultonborough mine sandwich in the
beautiful Lakes Region
um
HB 1137 is about local school boards uh
I don't think we've ever seen local
school boards in the press as much as we
have seen seen them in the past year
um and they're uh
some common themes
arising from these reports many people
many parents are upset
for various reasons everything from
critical race Theory to issues related
to public comments to mask mandates and
curriculum access
for many there is the feeling among
parents that some school boards have no
interest in hearing from them or
communicating with them
even we have seen
a national attack on parents as a
domestic terrorists
HP 1137 deals with some of these issues
as well as the lack of specified duties
or responsibilities of local school
boards and our statutes
we try and address these issues
via the themes of Parental engagement
and transparency
I'd like to just
go through the bill briefly if I could
and highlight a few things if I might
um
on the first page everything in Bolden
is is new text
we talk about responsibilities of the
board
including
review of the
curriculum textbook approvals
measurable standards
and we outline other things that school
boards should do
such as and I imagine in most places
they do develop Implement and vote on
District policies and that should be
done in public session
all public auction all meetings of the
board and subcommittees
should be held pursuant to 91a laws and
I know uh just locally in the past
um we had a finance committee of our
school board who met with no minutes no
public notice of their meetings uh
anything and I think that
that is not proper
or legal
over on page two
we specify that the boards are
responsible for conducting annual
performance reviews of the district
superintendent I think in too many cases
school boards don't realize that the
superintendent reports to them and
sometimes the superintendent doesn't
realize that
um
the board doesn't report to them
they should provide an opportunity for
comment from board members
I think in many cases board members are
muzzled
by local policies and that's not right
every elected official should have the
ability and the responsibility for
speaking their mind and presenting their
opinions
uh we move into a section then related
to parental engagement and it should be
the duty of the board to encourage
public attendance at board meetings and
to provide for public input
at multiple times during the meeting
and also to allow that input for agenda
as well as non-agenda items sometimes
that is not the case at some board
meetings
the boards should also develop and
Implement a policy
to allow for classroom visitations
then into a section related to
transparency and I think this is
um a key area also and we call for
posting of manifests on the district
website as well as curriculum and
competencies should be made available to
the public
um posting of professional development
and workshop topics so the public can
see what the teachers are being
instructed on or uh
development days are being devoted to
there should also be on the district
website
student achievement information
enrollment information
per pupil costs
and that would be either on the district
website itself or a link to the
Department of Education website I think
would be viable as well
and I also think when we're talking
about transparency and parental
engagement
that there should be an annual end of
year parent survey as to
their beliefs and opinions on what is
going on in the school district I think
that that's key we we call for that in
other programs we we just talked about
the tax growth tax credit scholarship
program a few minutes ago and that's
required
in that program
and was in the original EFA
language as well
um
in the packet that I handed out there
are a number of exhibits uh the first
couple are related to parents being
arrested
at school board meetings
there have also been a number of
instances here in New Hampshire where uh
summonses have been given out to parents
unmasked parents for criminal trespass
I know when my local Regional School
District in Wolfeboro
parents were given a criminal trespass
summons for not wearing masks at the
public board meeting
um they filed a complaint with the local
police commission and they worked out a
deal you know we'll drop the police
complaint and you drop the criminal
summons
however a day later
they got an email from the town attorney
telling them that if they did not drop
their 91a requests for curriculum
information they would be reported to
the State Attorney General's office
how is that possible in New Hampshire
next are exhibits related to the need to
communicate and listen to parents first
as a policy brief from the Nea
then there are three documents related
to the spring
603 Bright Futures survey done by the
Department of Education uh this is in
the family survey section
um and I draw your uh attention to the
state survey and the question do you
feel School the school values your
opinions
response was 44 thought that that was a
positive statement
this is further evidence that school
boards cannot ignore parents
another reason New Hampshire school
boards have to pay attention to and
respect parents and for the parental
recommendations that are on page two of
the legislation school boards have to be
accountable
they have to reset represent the people
in the district the parents in the
district and there has to be trust
between the board
taxpayers and parents trust is a vital
component to improving board community
relations and improving what goes on in
the school district and I believe that
this in legislation is intended to help
us move down that path to restoring and
improving trust between the community
and the schools
all right thank you very much thank you
very much representative cardelli are
there questions for representative
cordelli
yes representative Tanner
thank you thank you for taking my
question sure could you speak to on page
three
you're uh dropping of approved
non-sectarian schools
oh I'm sorry
yes um that is consistent with uh other
statute that we have passed uh in the
state as well
further questions
Mr Jefferson Ellison uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question sure
um
on page two uh let's see
H1 which refers to encouraging public
attendance at board meetings which I
think is a great idea uh then it gets
into providing multiple public input at
multiple times during the board meetings
I'm wondering how that's going to get
set up if you have if the public has the
right to multiple have multiple inputs
on not only agenda but non-agenda items
and you have as we know to our award
meetings how how do you see that playing
out
um
a couple of things there
um I think multiple times is important
because
um very often boards schedule pump
public input at the end of the meeting
and if it's two meeting two hour meeting
it could be 10 o'clock uh parents have
left to attend to matters at home I
think that that is a problematic for for
many parents in terms of the agenda
items or non-agend items
um there have been times when boards
have told parents that um their public
comment is out of line because they are
discussing uh
some a topic that is not on the agenda
for that evening that's what I was
referring to
um in that regard parents should be able
to comment on items that are not on the
agenda for that meeting
well look Mr chair yes uh I'm talking
more I think or asking more about the
process
which if I'm in a school board meeting
and a school board member said something
and I can I jump up and say I object or
I need to ask you more questions I mean
this seems to be a wide open
process that would allow someone many
many people to become involved I mean
you've got to have some regulation right
now I you know I I view multiple comment
periods for input not okay
um although uh I am aware of uh even
school districts that I knew back in
Connecticut
um where they would allow for public
comment
um after various agenda items so that if
um you know something came up during the
discussion uh parents should be able to
comment on that that item as well
cordelli again
um I'm wondering
I've spent a lot of years on the
municipal and County government
committee and one thing that we learned
that I learned over that period of time
was that sometimes communities have a
problem
they don't like how things are running
so they come to us to make a law to fix
it
when many other communities in the state
don't have that problem and making the
law is going to make it difficult for
them to do their jobs so in other words
we didn't like one size fits all laws
for the whole state
um and we would often vote them down and
I'm looking at this and remembering my
time on the school board and all of
these things that you have listed were
things that we did
and we did them because we had been
trained and how to Be an Effective
School Board
and I'm wondering if maybe a little
carrot
or a training thing to get some
districts Bill no okay if if it would be
a way to encourage school boards to do
these things without putting it in
statute where it is a requirement for
all School boards to do them
I think this legislation would try to
make all School boards as effective as
your school board was
but in some communities it might not be
the best for them to have all these
things for example we heard today
several times about how deliberative
sessions and budget hearings were poorly
were poorly attended in their
communities and then we have this
section in here that encouraging
parental involvement those things seem
to be conflicting if you can't encourage
people to get involved if people were
encouraged to get involved they would
come to this deliberative session or if
people were inclined to be involved they
would be coming
it seems like it's
You're Expecting
more than can be given for some
communities to do
make a hardship for some communities to
do
I don't view it that way I think that
um
parents are very concerned about their
children's education
now more so than maybe in recent years
past but that
in promoting parental engagement
encouraging attendance policies related
to that policies that give
parents the opportunity to participate
in their children's education I think
will help to improve that involvement
are there further questions
representative woodcock
thank you representative
I'm thinking
president for taking uh my three
questions
um the first one I'm looking at uh the
topic on Glen on page two it's the eight
dealing with Community interest other
non-agenda items the community interest
s I'm wondering if the community
interests topics uh would be could be in
your in your regulation or your law here
limited to those that impact public
schools of public education
I mean this the the way it's written
um
it opens a whole plethora of of
opportunities to voice support or
discontent on community interests I
would be glad to work with you on an
amendment to include uh that that
Community interest would be related to
schools and not potholes or something
thank you I was thinking more like we
have the bathroom issue here in North
Conway yes
um the second one for me there's only
three second one um
on I'm looking at line 12 developing
thank you developing and implementing a
policy to allow classroom visitation
my question there is on by whom
parents so is that going to be specified
as parents
um
I'm making a note of that now
uh and then the third part if I may I'm
looking at line 20 uh
which actually
uh
concerns me particularly the talk about
and review academic curriculum
I have two questions the the general
topic of review I have no problem with
reviewing this reviewing that put on a
website I don't know what you're going
to do
after you review it but the opportunity
to review it is up there I mean we have
we have the the uh quick off there for
the most part but when it's an academic
curriculum I'm concerned about how
detailed you're looking
uh we can't for example if we're doing a
civics class
uh uh contemporary civics and today for
the second semester
we clearly can't have put on the website
all the topics we may be talking about
or the material they may be using on a
current service class I mean our English
101 basic grammar absolutely but on ones
that have that deal with a lot of
particularly I think youngsters get
older as those courses have more uh
Socratic method uh we can't with this I
don't want what detail are you looking
for there what are you actually looking
for
um basically the general curriculum not
looking for lesson plans or anything
like that if that's you know where
you're I don't know where you're going
that's what yeah right curriculum
what does that mean just general
curriculum
the curriculum for the course English
101 what is the curriculum what topic
should be covered
um what are the criteria what's the
subject matter
um
that you I I think the board
my experience anyway from back when I
was on a school board the board approved
the curriculum right and an outline of
what was to be covered as part of that
curriculum
um
and I remember uh specifically
um objecting to parts of that curriculum
okay and having to change
showing uh just I
um
early 20th century America curriculum
they wanted to show as an example of
that period of time The Godfather movie
okay which I objected to and and they
did pull that out of the curriculum so
if we may see your so you're actually
getting into the lesson plans and what
they're doing uh they listed um the uh
any uh audio visual that would be part
of the curriculum to be shown to that
class for 20th century America for
instance so you're in in this case then
you really are getting in the detailed
Russell plan the curriculum because you
want to know that
um so any based on that once it's in
annually anything that changes during
the school year uh an instructor
wouldn't be able to use if they have new
more contemporary or more authentic or
undocumented data or films or books or
whatever because it wasn't in the
curriculum
uh I I think that they're all always
things
um speakers that might come up or uh
something in current events that might
come up
um that certainly would be uh discussed
in class but not necessarily part of the
curriculum the curriculum curriculum
doesn't change month to month or
necessarily year to year
the student handbook the student
handbook of course selection I'm
starting out with up a little I don't
know what happens down at one two three
four but at the upper level in the high
school the student handbook identifies
the the curricula from what you're
asking it has the mission or the
objectives of the class and those things
so you said that's all that's what you
all you want is you want the crafty what
they're actually teaching uh or how
detailed that's you said just general
that that would be mission
okay that's a question right
it goes beyond just a mission
um for instance in our handbook uh so to
speak
um there's an outline of what each uh
each committee is to do
um which you could see uh possibly as a
mission but um for the curriculum I
think it goes a step below that so the
objectives the mission and the
objectives objectives and some detail as
to what's to be covered uh an objective
might be to
learn about
um the Apollo space program I I would
think that the curriculum would have a
little bit more detail than that
oh I would suggest that would be the
lesson plan supporting the curriculum
thank you thank you I'm done
thank you uh representative Mullen
thank you Mr chair I promise to be brief
that would be helpful thank you thank
you you're you're quite welcome thank
you for taking my question
representative
um my question has to do with Logistics
around the uh multiple times during the
school board meeting and the phrase
about allowing classroom visitation
um I can see where different school
districts would interpret that
differently you know one might have
public comment at the beginning maybe
then again before they go into
non-public session or whatever and then
non-agenda items at the end somebody
else may do it differently
when you um when you talk about
encouraging public attendance and
providing for are you do you envision
school districts
sort of tailoring this to their own
methodology yes okay and would that also
apply to classroom visitations yes okay
because I uh I I
there's a difference between a scheduled
sort of classroom visitation day which
lots of schools have and visitation at
will and uh I think I I I would expect
that a visitation would have to be
pre-arranged
um but I know even
um I just received uh correspondence
from a special ed parent who would like
to
is being prevented from observing in the
classroom because they want to see how
the IEP is working in the classroom for
their child and so I was concerned about
not being able to view the child in the
classroom to see how things are going
so you would
then see that as just being some sort of
thing that would be worked out between
okay one final question we're in line 11
on page two
um where you talk about involvement with
classroom and at home learning
are we talking about homeschooling or no
we're talking about like homework right
I
homework and maybe even summer reading
and things like that's why I
um I tried to use something other than
homeschooling and that's why I said Home
Learning perfect thank you very much
thank you
are there further questions for
represent cordelli
seeing any thank you very much thank you
okay uh we'd like to invite Eric power
power honor
he wrote better in the morning
thank you Mr chair and my name is Eric
power I I'm from Brookline
served as a co-op School Board member
but I was also a parent
I am a parent still and I just wanted to
talk a little bit about some of the
bills very positive aspects I think this
is a great bill I I think you guys I
think that the committee should pass it
recommend Auto pass I saw as I started a
school board I know I felt you know by
the way they passed policies I felt like
I was muzzled that you know you had to
speak as a board as one voice and a
dissenting voice was not really allowed
and I think that that was
um I was a little less uh knowledgeable
about everything back then but uh you
know I grew to be able to start speaking
my mind a little bit more you know you
don't you should be able to have that
discussion and have be able to express
that you don't speak for the board but
you do speak for yourself as a member of
the board
um I know I've talked to other parents
and myself where we've asked for answers
made comments and public comment at the
school board and there's never been any
follow-up or the follow-up's been vague
and I think that that this bill helps
address that problem
there's also a problem where the school
board wasn't really aware of what was in
the curriculum as representative
cordelli talked about and uh there was a
book English book called The Glass
Castle which some people thought was
pornographic
and they objected to it and the board
members except for one didn't even know
it was part of the curriculum so I would
imagine under English curriculum you
would list the books that might be read
as part of the English clerk home in
grades 9 10 11 12.
I had made an objection myself to a book
called Ender's Game and that was made in
approximately January my son was still
forced to read it they met finally with
a with a committee and decided in June
that it was okay
they didn't even know about it but it
was just uh it was a problem because of
awareness in the school board and I
think that this bill helps address that
I've personally made multiple inquiries
on policies
to our school board
and I've gotten no reply or
acknowledgment it just goes in and
nothing it doesn't ever come up as a
policy to be changed even to be looked
at
they just don't respond
I've also had times where they stopped
us talking about items that weren't on
the agenda
if it's not on the agenda you can't talk
about it
well when can we talk about it
when it's on the agenda how do you get
it on the agenda
the chair decides
so you have that kind of problem so you
know that shouldn't happen that also has
happened with the school district budget
committee that we have as well but this
is not the scope of that but that's also
a problem there
and
um I think a good practice is not to
have
uh
there should be designated time for for
public input I would say minimally one
but it should be several times but it
shouldn't be a free-for-all they should
make it over any important issues so
maybe you know at least two to three
times where parents can be able to speak
and they could also be able to speak on
non-agenda items they should they should
be able to maybe they won't have a
detailed discussion on it but at least
it will be there and the board can vote
whether or not to put it on the next uh
next meetings agenda if necessary
but overall I think that this bill helps
ensure all boards do the minimal things
that they should be to encourage uh
positive interaction with the community
especially in the last year or two I
think it's a very important bill for
helping guide school boards and what
they need to do as boards and also what
the rights are of parents and taxpayers
I think that would go a long way to
making things work better in New
Hampshire so I would encourage ought to
pass out of the committee thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions for Mr honor
at
p-a-u-n-e-r yeah correct
I I do have a question for you when you
got on the board
were you providing any information as
far as
what are the responsibilities and duties
of a board member and giving some of the
parameters that are exist right here
within this legislation
we were given some of them but certainly
not all of them there is some you know I
read through the rsas the RSA is
obviously not complete and there was
some training that was given by the
School Board Association at the time and
I attended that but I felt still it
wasn't proper and it you know it did
train me to say well you can have a
dissenting voice and you can quietly
vote no but beyond that don't speak
about it and that's not really right it
should be a board members was I was
elected by the the people I should be
representing people and I should be able
to have my opinion and not be muzzled
and this bill helps Rectify that by
putting it into law thank you
representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair thank
you very much for joining us again how
often did your board vote on
superintendent contracts
when I was on the school board the
superintendent had just been hired
he got hired in the previous year in
2014 and I started I wasn't part of the
contract
he had just gotten approved before I got
on the board but when we when I was
there we did uh one one contract every
member that we had to approve and we
definitely deliberated on that
so there was one in the three years I
was on the school board okay thank you
I'd like to follow
up paying for were you given the
opportunity to uh evaluate the
superintendent uh I threw you know a
personal form that you filed and that
went in with the group on the board and
the board then Consolidated into uh
annual evaluation
yes I was given that opportunity in um
Hollis Brookline SAU 41 we have the
halls Brooklyn Co-op which I was a board
member we have Brookline in the Hollis
school districts and they have their
boards so the 17-member SAU board so I
was one of 17 voices that made that
contributed to the superintendent's
evaluation and I yes I did have the
opportunity I do feel feel that my
comments were watered down to some
degree when there was things if they
weren't you know 100 positive they did
some of the things did make it in though
so I can't complain too much about that
but there's definitely was pressure to
say things are all okay and you know I
don't think there was that we have you
know we did a good job but that I did
have an input thank you very much
down the line at represent Tanner thank
you and thank you for taking my question
were you are you aware that in New
Hampshire that any parent can object to
material or books that a student has as
part of their curriculum and provide an
alternative of their own so I don't
understand how your son was forced to
read a book that you objected to
yes I don't believe that was that was
the case that law was not in place at
that point I don't remember when it went
into place so this is I'm talking about
probably the 2009 time frame when my son
was a freshman in high school
but I did complain about it and they
said yes we will convene a uh committee
to look at it and it went at the speed
of government to be honest and so I
complained I believe in January and they
finally met as a committee in June and
to add a little bit of insult to injury
they said just because you complained
about it and the committee met and found
that it was okay no one else can
complain about this book for two years
so that that was what that was my
experience
as a follow-up that's not the case now
that's great if it's not the case now
representative Porter
hour again
um
when you were on the school board
did you set standards for behavior for
both the school board and the public in
attending the meetings
standards of behavior
the I did not I did not do that we had a
I think we had an old policy but we
never visited it that was how that would
run
would you say that it would be
reasonable for school boards to be able
to have a standard of behavior for
school board members and attendees at a
meeting
I believe there should be some standards
yes and I think that but I think having
school board members being able to
respond
directly and not just the chair to a
public inquiry
is appropriate and that's not the case
that we were under
I guess my question is
if
people come to a school board meeting
and are disruptive interrupting loud
um
yelling out at inappropriate times
what recourse do you think a school
board would have
in dealing with that person
I believe if a person is being
disruptive then they should be asked to
leave and then you may have to get law
enforcement involved potentially if
that's the case but I would take the the
the the the the the asking approach
first
further questions for Jefferson Woodcock
thank you good afternoon sir just a
quick question I'm glad about listening
to your dialogue about your uh concern
or your
experiences on the school board I also
said I sat at a school board for 20
years I I understand a little bit what
you're saying but it seems to me that
the bulk of the year are concerned thank
you sir that the bulk of your concerns
with your interplay within your own
school district is a school local school
district local school board
superintendent discussion you're a
muslin or a lack thereof or your ability
to put your hand up quietly or ask
questions that that's a local school
board auction you have a responsibility
to speak up to that I'm not sure we need
a state law to tell you or the members
of the U.S school board or any school
board how to interact they're weak boys
or strong boys the sweet superintendents
a strong superintendents that Dynamic is
built every time they have a new
election
um so I just find I find that your
concerns are legitimate without question
legitimate I just think they're they're
uh prescriptive to that one particular
board that you had a difficulty time
negotiating and not like a a whole law
as as here
well I think a lot of the policies
derive hopefully from Department of
Education rules and and also New
Hampshire RSA and a lot of those
policies are not developed necessarily
by the board but they're the draft
language is received from sources like
the New Hampshire School Board
Association maybe not looked at in
detail that it needs to be and maybe are
sometimes approved without careful
thought and I think that was one of the
cases with this particular time when I
was on the board
um so I think that that you know you
have to look at the policies and you
need to revisit them periodically so I
think that's a good thing to do and I
think if the law
causes the right thing to happen it will
follow that policies will follow and I
think that that's why this this law is
so important
last question like wouldn't it be the
reason your mind wouldn't it be the
responsibility of the school board to
create their own policies and make sure
that they work accurately and that
they're evaluated and they're seen on a
regular can review on a consistent basis
I mean it wouldn't that be responsible
your own board for your policies
the school board should be doing that
and they follow the guidance of the law
and sometimes the law needs to help
guide that a little bit to to allow the
right thing to happen in terms of the
right to speak as a school board member
the right to have a dissenting opinion
and also the all the other things that
uh representative cordelli's bill has in
it
further questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you for the opportunity I'd like
to invite bear Christina the school
boards Association
welcome again
thank you very much chairman Ladd good
afternoon members of the committee
here I am let's have the conversation
what do you want to know
I'm I'm serious with questions let's say
let's let's ask them
let me ask a few questions then
um we know we're living in an
environment where
there's a lot of political conflict
is what uh is being communicated to us
a result of an ongoing issue prior in
all this in the last several years other
the communication the the the issue
about comments to the school board uh
comments of a person that's a minority
on a school board sure Etc is that
something unique to this Frame of time
we're dealing with right now in our life
or was it preceding that and have you
got any information back from Statewide
school boards referencing this sure
thank you thank you very much for the
for the question represent Senator
Vladimir my introduction was just to get
the conversation wrong I may or may not
ask that directly but relative to some
of the comments that were made earlier I
want to go through some of the sample
policies nhsba has
sample policy Ka School family and
Community Partnerships
sample policy KB family and Community
engagement
sample policy kcb Community involvement
and decision making
sample policy KDA Public Information
Program
policy ke public complaints
policy Keb public complaints about
school Personnel employees students or
Administration
I've got some more
we have sample policies on reviewing
instructional course material we have
sample policies about if a parent
doesn't like a book in the library they
can come and make a complaint or make a
a request for it to be reviewed we have
public comment policies
um you know
the things that are in the bill is I
believe representative Porter it was you
that was that said your school board was
already doing these things and
representative Woodcock I presume that
was some of the same representative luno
I presume that was some of the same
representative cordelli were on a school
board in Connecticut I believe sir I
presume they were already doing these
things representative Litchfield
representative
so ask yourself if your board was
already doing some of these things if it
was fantastic and if it was why not was
it because the law didn't you require
you to do it was it because your board
didn't want to do it which is a
completely different issue altogether so
to your question representative Ladd I
guess about the public comment issues
um
you know covid really engaged really the
one thing that I think kovid if there
was one band I'm trying to think the
right way to say this if there was one
benefit from covid I think it got
parents more engaged um with attending
local school board meetings now
obviously the virtual option certainly
helped that out right we couldn't go
anywhere and go outside anyway so we sit
and sat and watch the zoom meeting but
that was also very issue specific
because we wanted to know about I'm
sorry representative Hopson I forgot
about your work on the school board as
well too I did not mean to exclude you
from from going around the table
um you know
parents wanted to know about masking
they wanted to know about social
distancing they wanted to know about
remote or in-person or virtual or things
of that nature that's why we had so many
people attending school board meetings
the last couple of years
um you know I have I have some of my own
thoughts um about
um some of the events at school board
meetings I guess mostly this past summer
and fall
um they were disruptive people were out
of order school board members were being
called Nazis they were being called uh
uh uh Communists they were being accused
of of uh illegally restraining children
under RSA
126-u I believe it is
um so you know I I
social media Stokes a lot of this it's
easier now to get a message out it's
easier now to be anonymous if you will
keyboard Warriors you don't have to come
to the school board meeting you don't
have to write a letter to superintendent
you don't have to write a letter to the
principal or make a phone call and be
polite and be respectful and follow some
rules of decorum you can crap all over
people on on Facebook and and and and
and and and and engage and and let your
anger flow there without any you know
without actually having to deal with
anything or reach any sort of resolution
so that's to one question
I mean we have policies that address all
of these things some school board
members are involved in curricular
decisions or some school boards take an
active role in in in in curricular
decisions others don't
you know I always ask you know we have
educational experts as well too we have
superintendents and principals with
Advanced degrees who know about
curriculum assessment and instruction I
know about the law I don't know anything
about
assessing students when I get those
questions from school board members who
do you think I passed them off to so you
have to talk to your superintendent and
your principal I'm not an educational
expert fortunately we have Miss Wilson
on our staff now who has
um multiple certifications from from the
Department of Education so if we get
something questioned from a school board
member that relates to curriculum
instruction or assessment Becky can also
often often handle it because she has
that background and expertise I don't
have my attorney handle that I certainly
don't handle that
so you know I school boards have been
under significant attack the last couple
of years these are elected officials
just like you half this committee has
been on a local school board
were you trying to silence your
constituent or were you trying to do the
best that you could do and are people
trying to do the best they could do in
times of a pandemic in times of uh
fabricated allegations of what's being
taught in our Public Schools it's not
easy these people volunteer their time
how many hours a week representative do
you spend dealing with your local school
board 10 15 possibly
easily and you do it for free and you do
it without being at home with your kids
right you know the behavior that we've
seen at school board meetings last
summer and last fall
that would never be tolerated in this
room it would never be tolerated in this
room
if I stood up and started yelling and
screaming or representative cordelli was
introduced in this bill
somebody would have called security that
would have been escorted out of here
I have strong objections about the bill
it impacts my livelihood impacts my
family
I don't get to yell and scream because I
don't get my way I don't get to yell and
scream because I'm being disruptive
about something that I don't necessarily
like especially in front of a group of
five people that are your neighbors that
are doing the best that they possibly
can
you know we got very little guidance
about masking
from the state
no mandates what were we told what were
we told by the governor and the
commissioner local decision local
decision
so it's left to the local school
districts I won't get into my own
thoughts as to why that was done
but you know we were told by people in
charge that we were on our own
and lay people not MediCal experts not
educational experts people overseeing
the budget adopting policies trying to
do their best
are disparaged by some of our
politicians not always supported by our
bureaucrats not always supported by the
media
disparaged on social media
and here we are so
I thank you very much uh Barrett you
know I I think that just goes through
the the what's going on and
I for one want to thank you the state
New Hampshire school boards Association
for quickly responding
to the National
and how you did that
and
that set at what I think
uh us on the right path
and I understand how difficult it is on
these school boards they are elected
officials
coming from all kinds of walks of life
and they're human
we got to resolve our issues our
problems there's got to be a way of
doing it and the policies I've seen many
of your boilerplate policies
and therefore the local school boards
then to make them more relevant to their
particular Town correct so with that um
I'm going to open this up to other
questions that may come from the
committee here represent boom
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
I agree most of these when I was on the
school board we did most of this stuff
but now it's the some School Board need
my own where some of this stuff
the theory lead us then they know better
than anybody else so don't you think
that putting this stuff in law will help
you
at school bus for the policies and
whatnot your policies can point to this
thank you for the question
representative I mean I suppose that's
one way of looking at it if but you know
relative to the concerns you have with
your local school board that's an
election issue that's not a statutory
issue you vote for different people
there's also a provision in here about
um uh uh adhering to I believe ethical
standards or whatever the languages we
had a school board ethics uh bill I
think two years ago and I believe
there's another one coming back this
year I remember you saying your ethics
are between you and your constituents if
they don't like the job you're doing
they'll vote for somebody else I think
that sums it up perfectly sir
yes representative Woodcock thank you um
Mr typically at the start of your
presentation you indicate a little bit
differently than you did today you can
only give us your uh your association's
position on the bill we haven't heard
that
um we're not taking a position on this
bill representative Woodcock if we
oppose the bill we're going to be
labeled as being anti-parent if we
support the bill we're going to be
um it's going to be that we support all
the things in here so I'm not taking a
position on this bill so there's no
position on the bill okay thank you for
that I have one more yes you may um I I
concur with your your thinking when you
talk to representative a moment ago and
local school boys should take care of
local school boys
um
is there and I know from listening to
you over the last couple of years
there's a more
85 you notice that I don't know number
of school boys are affiliate your
organization
certainly there were 176 school boards
in the state we have 161 members that
are school boards most of the most of
the districts that are not members or
some districts that do not have schools
they don't operate a school some of this
thing up in the mountains some of the
smaller restaurants and I appreciate the
fact that your boy does put out sample
policies and that the local school
committees then can use those as a stock
as a guidelines of Base play my question
is have you does your Association
typically work with superintendents or
school boards uh in an orientation
package for new members and those things
also included in there uh thank you for
the question representative yes we do
um
we do multiple trainings every year
between my staff attorney and I anywhere
between I'd say 50 and 80 trainings for
local school boards every year we do a
number of webinars uh most of our
training is when I say the 50 to 80
those are in person where
um a superintendent or School Board
chair will call us and we will go out to
visit their local school district and do
a training on whatever topic that they
want we do do what we call our new
school board member orientation training
It's usually the end of April beginning
of May following March elections we let
the board members kind of get come on
get used to it
so we used to do that in person in
Concord
um around that time of year we'd get
about 120 people on average from across
the state when covet hit obviously all
of our training went virtual and zoom so
we're continuing that now last year we
did a zoom in this year we're doing all
of our webinar we're still doing those
via Zoom there's no point in asking
somebody to travel to Concord when we
can hop on on a hop on a computer and do
a webinar that way but we do in terms of
the roles and responsibilities and
orientation type training I've already
done a couple
um you know Manchester has their
elections in November we already went
down into training for them
um I did one for Dover
um maybe a month or so ago I had one
scheduled for Portsmouth because their
cities do elections um unfortunately
that had to get canceled something else
came up but we do dozens and dozens and
dozens of these a year
thank you and thank you for your work on
behalf of the state thank you
thank you uh further question
representative Ford
your your mic on Oliver
yeah I have to find it first okay
oh
we uh
we seem to be stuck on an air thing that
occur I haven't really heard of the
express
and I'm wondering if something in the
law discussing a requirement
that people be
civilized and that irritable language
angry language and all will not be
tolerated yeah it's not tolerated in
courts of law
it's not tolerated really even in
churches they'll get you for disruption
however heartfelt your anguish
you have to express it clearly calmly
respectfully to someone with whom you
may disagree
we do it here all the time every day
however exciting thing might be on the
point
but
it doesn't seem to me to be
too high a thing too hard a thing to
require that people comport themselves
civilly in a public discourse such as a
school board meeting sure and then would
it I guess I'm asking you would it be
helpful if that were in law for school
boards to Simply say You must calm down
or we'll have you removed and just
simply not move until the person
thank you thank you for the question uh
representative we certainly saw a lot of
that last last summer and fall
um the challenge with crafting a public
comment policy is that you run into a
myriad of First Amendment issues you
cannot mandate somebody to be quote
unquote civil
um you know and as elected officials uh
you know you can regulate
obscene speech vulgar speech is kind of
that's on that's that's a little that's
a little bit iffy
um you know some courts have said vulgar
speech can be disallowed other courts
have said it's going to be a matter of
context
um you know if you know if I'm walking
away from the microphone I go
representative 40 or an a-hole you know
that's that's probably not going to get
me arrested if I walk up to you and put
my finger in your face and yell and
scream and say the same thing I might
you know
um
so um anyway you know any nhsba we did a
very comprehensive webinar I want to I
want to say it was the middle of
September
um on how to manage your meeting rules
for public comment and walking through
the steps of if you have to call the
police because there are most of these
in my understanding is people that have
may have been arrested it's a disorderly
conduct charge under whatever RSA is it
644 colon 2 or 664 colon two I forget
what it is but you know we certainly
told our our members that's the absolute
Last Resort that's the absolute Last
Resort just having a you know call the
other challenge too is that as you said
you know wait until they become civil
I mean we had school board meetings with
150 200 people who had no interest in
being civil the purpose was to disrupt
the meeting and the purpose was to
prevent the school board from doing
their business
so you know
representative the bill has some some
Provisions about public comment periods
multiple public comment periods through
the course of the meeting and I believe
representative Cordell you had mentioned
some boards will have them at the end of
the meeting maybe 10 or 10 30 and
parents you know I have to go home and
intend with the kids if we have multiple
public comment hearings the meeting's
going to last until midnight anyway so
at one point I mean that's sort of the
purpose of
of of putting parameters around public
comments is that it's a business meeting
of the board the board has to get this
business done it has to approve its
policy it's have to approve its budget
accept reports things of that nature you
know to say nothing of the fact that
there are other avenues of communication
you can always email you know ever most
School boards have and I get there were
concerned that they don't email me back
they don't email me back many school
boards will have the the the the school
board members phone number and email
address on the website and if you don't
get a response from back from your
elected official
come March they're going to hear about
it because they're not going to be
they're not going to be reelected again
personal demeanor but I would ask you
respectfully
what if you had as an alternative we
will tolerate this to a point at which
point we'll go into oppose me and simply
do it and go into a closed meeting sir I
mean the right to know law doesn't allow
that right the public has a right to
attend a meeting
that's the RSA 91a the public has a
right to attend a public meeting
I mean
there's nothing in law that requires
right now there's nothing in New
Hampshire law that requires a public
body and let's that's another aspect you
know can we if we're going to be talking
about public bodies having
having public hearings can we please
incorporate that to include towns cities
and you know this committee doesn't take
public comment either respectfully
I say that so but I'm just you know
school boards are the target for this
when you know if we're going to be
talking about public comments and
implicating the right to no law in First
Amendment law it should apply to all
public bodies equally
thank you thank you very much uh further
questions of
not saying thank you very much Barrett
representative
use me right beside me
hi there thank you for taking my
question thank you
I just want to start by saying I hear
your passion
um
and I agree you're in a no-win situation
regarding this bill and after listening
to you speak today we've been working
together kind of for years I wish I had
reached out to you years ago to be
perfectly honest with you
um
so
I'm trying to wrap this concern into a
question
um and and basically let me start with I
do believe that there is for example a
sample agenda out there a policy of a
sample agenda that does state from the
New Hampshire School Board Association
it is suggested that people do not make
excuse me that public comment be related
to items on the agenda so I want to put
that out there first secondly new school
board members they do receive if it's
still being printed there's a pretty
thick manual a yellow manual
um right what is expected or how to be a
good school board member and I know
because I carried about four years how
to be a better okay becoming a better
board member board member um it was my
Bible for years but to be perfectly
honest with you I felt it was quite
vague there is initial training by the
School Board Association but yet
um I find that within that training and
it could be by default board members are
often led to believe that they work for
the superintendent and not the other way
around so that being said with this
particular piece of legislation
I'm at a loss at how this is not a good
thing because it could be incorporated
for example into that publication that
is given to board members it could be
incorporated into the training and if
you're suggesting that we don't go with
this piece of legislation how do you
suggest that we convey this message at
this point in time sure thank you very
much representative
um first to to your first question about
NH and nhsba Sample policy recommending
that uh uh public comment be limited to
agenda items only
um that was necessary because we had a
period in time when
um we had many
um we had people coming to public
meetings and publicly disparaging staff
members calling out third grade teachers
calling out the principal
um which when school boards deal with
employee matters as you know their own
non-public session everything we do
hiring firing investigations all done in
non-public session so
our rationale was that it did not make
sense for the school board public
comment
portion to be a vehicle for people to
come and publicly disparage
publicly disparaged School District
employees so by limiting public comment
to agenda items only you're never
putting employee matters on the agenda
are you your agenda will say non-public
non-public session following the meeting
so that was a way to ensure that public
that school board meetings did not
become vehicles or avenues for people
just to come and complain publicly
complain about their teachers as we said
there are other avenues for discussion
if you have a problem with your teacher
talk to the principal if you have a
problem with if it's not resolved
perhaps talk to the superintendent
um you know
depending on the nature of the issue it
may come up to the school board for a
conversation or a hearing or something
along those lines as well too becoming a
better board member um uh you know
that's a national publication I mean
it's certainly not going to fit every
state because every state has its own
you know various laws about school board
governance and things of that nature
it's helpful it's intended to be a guide
it's not the end-all be-all you know
we're relative to that though you know I
often say that being a school board
member is an art not a science you know
it's not going to be black and white
it's not going to be
um you know rigid rigid rules that you
follow every single time there needs to
be Nuance there's going to be history
there's going to be local communities
and local customs and last I guess to
the the issue to your question about you
know would this bill sort of help the
nhsba training and some of the other
training docs and whatnot you know I
guess if we're talking about the bill
specifically you know where it says the
school board shall be responsible for
curriculum textbook approvals adoption
of educational standards I mean I guess
it sort of gets back to some comments I
made earlier that your average School
Board member is not an educational
expert curriculum instruction and
assessment are typically left to to
Educators to people that hire to have
higher degrees in this sort of thing I
mean that's what nhsba recommends if it
relates to education you know textbook
approval yeah if the board wants to do
that it can nothing prevent nothing in
law prevents a school board from from
adopting a policy or a directive that
it's going to review curriculum select
textbooks you know Vote or otherwise
adopt the curricular standards the
question is do school boards want to do
that and do they have the expertise to
do that some probably do and some
probably don't
so and I think you know I think I guess
I would come back to I forget if it was
representative Woodcock or
representative Porter and I think
representative Bowman I talked about it
some of the concerns that have been
brought up
are is not because of the law being
unclear it's because of the way
individuals or a local school board has
chosen
chosen to proceed and if that's the
issue you know that that's a political
issue that can be rectified at the you
know in March
yes you may
first thank you for the in-depth answer
and I want you to know that I absolutely
heard every I did I heard everything
that you were saying my question to you
is um I heard what you were saying that
you're feeling that not every bullet
point in this bill maybe is appropriate
I would like to kick it back to you
which may not be fair because I'm
putting you on the spot
what would you support as the New
Hampshire School Board Association with
this bill sure
um
I'd want to give it a little bit more in
depth I'll follow up with you
representative you know I'm looking at
you know the paragraph three this is I
guess page
page one line 24 where it says elected
School Board shell develop Implement and
assess District policies conduct
meetings and their right to no law I
mean most of those those most of those
Provisions are already in law so I
suppose we support you know those
aspects if you if you wanted to you know
if you want to just reaffirm that the
board you know I'd be careful with the
ethical Behavior standard because ethics
one person's ethics is another person's
you know male Behavior one person's good
governance is another person's
micromanaging so just be mindful with
that but you know about reaffirming the
right to no law proposing the the budget
um be mindful with that some towns have
budget Community Municipal budget
committees where the municipal budget
committee is the one that actually
proposes the budget that goes to the
voters the local school board has a
responsibility to still develop a
proposed budget and give it to the to
the budget committee but in communities
with the municipal budget committee it's
the bud com that's bringing the budget
to the voters
um conduct annual performance reviews of
the of the district superintendent
that's already in law that's already
Department of Education rule 3-0
3.01
k l anyway it's in Department of
Education rules and most boards have a
policy that speak to that and as I'm
sure most members of the members that
have been on superintendents know that I
haven't seen every superintendent
contract in the state but I know
everyone I've ever seen has a provision
in the contract that says you're going
to evaluate the superintendent
conduct contract negotiations I mean
again that that's that's already a law
provide an opportunity for public
comments for board members
um some boards do that many boards some
many I don't know where that number is
but we'll just have sort of an open
board discussion where boards will you
know board members just have an
opportunity to to bring up new issues or
ask for stuff to be put on the agenda or
say oh this happened last night is there
something we can look at it
um you know the policies promoting
parental engagement as I've said we we
have sample policies on that already so
I don't know if I'd have any significant
objection to that um the posting all the
stuff on the on the website
that's time and effort that school
districts do not have right now and it's
as simple as that dude they don't have
time we're trying to deal with the
pandemic we're trying to deal with are
we closing our schools or not I mean
it's all public information anyway yes
the more you know the more electronic
access we can provide people it's easy
is I so totally agree is easier just be
mindful about what everything has to go
you know put up on the website because
that's somebody that's your I.T guy
sitting there putting up every manifest
and every Bill and every invoice and and
so on and so forth so I mean you know
I could go on for hours about this if
you haven't noticed
thank you representative
thank you very much again Barrett um
it's caution us not to get down in the
weeds too much on the state level I'm
looking at
20 RSA 21 in colon one the first
literature underneath the chapter of
Education in the state
and it reads the general court finds
that the students parents General
citizenry
local school teachers and administrators
local government local school boards
school administrative units and state
government have a joint and share of
responsibility for the quality of
Education
all the ones that precede state
government are local
and so many of these issues need to be
resolved
at the local level
and I I can't say any more than that
other than you know that's a
responsibility that we all share
and we're going to have to work some of
this out we believe in local control in
this state
walking to this level and saying State
resolve it for us
now we can agree that you know we're not
maybe where we want to be but it's going
to have to be resolved locally and I
think Barrett's right
if you don't like your school board
members or get rid of them
we got election coming up
or if you want some change work with
them
or run for or run for school board or
run for it yourself God bless you if you
do
because it takes a lot of time
a lot of times we need substitute
teachers too well I've got the
microphone
and this thing's applicable to municipal
government as well yeah you'd fit right
in on that committee Mr chair
well okay thank you very much again
Barry thank you to everybody I
appreciate you greatly appreciate it I
would like to speak and I'd like to have
everybody have the opportunity to do
that
uh I I have a card here from a Tim
kroliski g-r-a-r-g-a
oh geleski okay
welcome Tim
so good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee um my name is
Tim galitski and I'm representing the
school district governance Association
of New Hampshire or sdga so the sdga
supports HB 1137.
so I'm a rep I'm a resident of
Kensington New Hampshire where in the
past I've served as the chairman of the
school board and in my school board
service I always put in much effort to
ensure that our board performed its
educational duties
this effort included refuting
misinformation purporting that it is
somehow inappropriate for a school board
to set educational goals for its
District
of course the truth is that it's the
affirmative Duty of any school board to
set educational goals for its district
and to follow up on them
and all this is these facts are set
forth in administrative rule at 303.01 G
which names six specific duties that
each School Board shall perform
so the sdga following up on on
experiences like this and others studied
the performance of these six educational
duties by the Exeter region Cooperative
District or School Board Laconia and
Timberlane school boards over several
school years starting with the 2018-2019
school year
so the details of this study are in the
written testimony that I'll I'll leave
with the clerk
I'd like to share with you our findings
and our reasons for supporting HB 1137
So based on the governmental records
that we were able to obtain and identify
we made three findings
the first finding is that none of the
examined school boards fully performed
its educational duties required by rule
Ed
303.01 G
the second finding is that there were
some patterns in the performance of Ed
303.01g duties
specifically school boards in general
they determined educational goals
they determined long-range plans and
they identified short-term objectives
though there were some some lapses in
these duties
however in no case was the sdga able to
identify records showing that the school
board and the school board itself
had performed its duties to require the
implementation of educational programs
designed to reflect District the
district's goals and objectives to
review such programs or to make public
the results of such investigation
the third finding is that in some cases
these duties were performed by the
school administrative unit and not by
The District School Board Itself by its
own actions
so the sdga supports HP 1137 because it
would improve the performance of school
board's educational duties in the
following ways
first it would make the educational
duties of school boards more specific
it would make these statutory duties of
school boards more specific and thereby
make these duties more clear to all
and therefore more likely to be
performed
second it would shift the oversight of
Education away from the unelected
administrators and toward the elected
school boards where it belongs
and third HB 1137's promotion of
Parental engagement and school
transparency as well as the requirement
of annual parental surveys would make
the educational work of school boards
more responsive to families and the
public
and so for these reasons the school
district governance Association asks you
respectfully to vote that this ought to
pass
so thank you and I'd be happy to try to
answer any questions that there might be
thank you are there any questions from
yes representative Waltz
I just have a quick question about your
organization are you a 501c3 because I
was looking for your 990s and I couldn't
find anything on file
I I'm not sure but I don't believe it is
a 501c3 it's a non-profit Association in
New Hampshire I either a 501c3 or four I
would presume I don't know the exact IRS
tax status of the organization
okay thank you
for the further questions
thank you very much for coming today
I'd like to
invite forth Ken uring
is Ken here
all right thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh for allowing me
to speak and honorable representatives
for allowing me to take some of your
valuable time I also want to thank
repcor Deli and all the sponsors of this
bill I believe that this is a very
important bill and I support this and I
encourage you to pass it
I am a current
former chairman I'm not current I'm a
former chairman of the Windham School
Board so I'm speaking from experience
one of the reasons that I ran is because
our school board was not responsive to
parents
they did not allow them to speak during
board meetings
and I think that's a travesty because
our constitution
says that we the people or the
government
and when school board members were sworn
into office they take an oath to that
Constitution
article 8 says that all power resides in
the people
and that our officers and magistries are
our substitutes and at all times
accountable to us
and when that doesn't happen there needs
to be consequences
so I want to talk about just a few
things
parents know what's best for their kids
the schools are there to educate their
kids and when these school boards are
implementing policies and curriculums
that go against their values and their
principles that they should have a right
to express that and school boards Across
the Nation are shutting parents down and
that's wrong because we are the
government they work for us and I say
that with respect but that's the deal
that's the arrangement and they swear an
oath to that arrangement
so I agree that um
that all the information should go
online we did that when I was chairman
it's not a big deal don't believe what
you're being told
it may takes a little bit of extra time
but this is part of accountability we're
talking about tens of millions of
dollars and sometimes over 100 million
dollars depending on the school district
taxpayers and parents have a right to
know how their money is being spent
they also know how their money is being
implemented in the classroom putting the
names of the textbooks and the reading
materials lists and the instructional
materials in the curriculum online is
absolutely necessary for parents to
realize what's going on in the classroom
when I was chairman I had parents come
to me and complain about two teachers
it was regarding
um what was taught on Constitution Day
September 17th
by federal law schools have to teach
about the Constitution
now Mr
Christina
said that we don't want to micromanage
the teachers
well you need to provide some guidance
as to what's being taught
it's not just teaching the Constitution
but it's teaching that it's a great
document as the founding document of our
of our government and it's and it's
teaching it in a positive way
one teacher said that
I'm supposed to teach you
that today's a day to celebrate the
Constitution
and his follow-up was but there's
nothing to celebrate about it
that was taught to our children in 12th
grade that's unacceptable
another teacher in high school said I'm
going to take five minutes to talk about
the Constitution because I was told I
have to
that's disgusting
so you know when you say you don't want
to micromanage people I understand that
you don't want to tell them every word
that they're going to relay but you have
to tell them the message that has to be
conveyed and then let them do that in
their own way
that's important
so I want to talk about some of the
things that Mr Christina said he talked
about some policies and a lot of the
policies are good they uh it's a it's a
pain in the neck to write policies I was
on the policy committee for three years
and every word means something but they
also have policies or they recommended a
policy jbab that mandated employees
withhold information about their
children that's unacceptable
absolutely unacceptable and there were
violations to the and if employees
violated that policy they would be held
accountable
he said multiple times that the solution
to this is just vote out to people well
some of these terms are for four years
and you don't realize who you just voted
in until maybe a week or two after
they're in office now you're supposed to
wait four years when they take office
they swear an oath to the Constitution
Article 8 as I said before
means that they will be accountable to
the people and the and the alternative
to that is or or state law 40 call in
one says it vile that's the oath that
they must take and and the solution to
that is that they shall be forthrift to
remove from office
right but that costs money that takes
time and it takes the right judge to do
that and they're getting legal advice
from organizations like the nhsba like
the nhsaa like their legal counsel to
tell them they can do what they're doing
and that gives them plausible
deniability so if you try to take them
to court and have them removed from
office they're going to say your honor I
was just following the advice I was
given
that's unacceptable too we have to have
a way to hold our school board members
accountable it's it's part of the
process of our constitutional republic
so I agree with the uh with the public
engagement when I was chairman prior to
me becoming chairman there was
three-minute limitation for parents to
come up and talk when I became chairman
people could come up and talk I did not
put a three-minute time limit on it I
allowed them to talk on every agenda
item because we are there to serve them
it's their children that are being
educated
that has to be kept in the front of
everybody's mind
we're talking about children being
educated and parents having as you said
representative Ladd parents being a
joint venture in this process
mm-hmm
now
Mr Christina also said that these
meetings can if you allow people to talk
and you got to remember these are the
people paying okay these are the
shareholders these are their children if
you allow people to talk on all the
agenda items meetings can go to midnight
well you know what these boards meet
twice twice a month usually have more
meetings we're running a multi-million
dollar business to educate children
that's how it has to be looked at if you
don't have enough time in the two
meetings that you meet every month then
schedule meeting as often as you need to
allow the shareholders to have their say
into how their children are being
educated that is of the utmost
importance and that's what's being
ignored and they're getting support from
organizations like the nhb nhsba and the
nhba who as you all know
you know coerced with the federal
government to have them defined as
domestic terrorists in America who would
have believed that that type of language
that our federal government would be
weaponized against parents going to
school board meetings because they're
frustrated about Mass policies
whatever side you stand on is fine you
should have a right to express your
opinions and how your children should be
handled in school and the fact that
you've got Mr Christina up here and
you've got some other people whoever
they're learning about the language
point of water please
I like the question through you we have
this generally has the right to speak to
the bill multiple times I have no
problem with that be happy to listen to
them and learning things but I do object
them continually referring to Mr Katina
in his testimony we can't do it here we
can't refer to another representative
he's not discussing the bill he's
discussing the representative already
spoke with the person who spoke I
appreciate it I'd like to clarify one
one point here that the New Hampshire
school boards Association
withdrew from the national as a result
of that acrimony on the national level
so our association we should be saying
thank you
in that regard they recognized that what
was stated
was on the national level was not where
they are policy wise or believing in
so and yes can we just please try to I
don't want to limit you from speaking
that's fine I have another big one right
after this as well okay
um but prior to that domestic terrorist
statement they were aligned with all of
the policies and all of the and all of
the direction that was given to our
school board members and
and that's where CRT policies came from
that's where many other policies their
parents are
objecting to came from so let's not just
sever it and say that there that that
everything's good and hunky dory and
Rosie there are things that came prior
to that one-term domestic terrorist that
parents want to have a voice in and I
just want to point out that in the 1964
Supreme Court ruling New York Times
versus Sullivan and this is about
sometimes
the adversarial language that people use
I don't like using the words Nazis or
calling people Communists but they have
a First Amendment right to do that and
the 1964 Supreme Court ruling upholds
that it said the court emphasized the
importance of allowing citizens to
criticize the government side in quote a
profound National commitment to the
principle that debate on public issues
should be uninhibited robust and wide
open and that it may well include
vehement caustic and sometimes
unpleasantly sharp attacks on government
and public officials unquote that's
constitutional state law so I believe
that you should always be respectful I
should believe that you should always
have an open dialogue but the problem is
is that our school boards are not
allowing open dialogue people getting
upset people are spending a lot of money
through their taxes 70 to 75 if not more
of home tax real estate taxes goes to
your schools that's a lot of money and
when people don't have the right to
represent their children
their children who they know what's best
for
the frustration levels are easy to grow
so I think I got in most of my points I
want to be respectful of your time
I'd just like to say that one of the
things that I'd like to see added to
this bill and you know or our penalties
for when people
don't follow the law you know there's a
lot of times where the law is skirted
and then it's a slap on the wrist and
then nothing's really done about it so
um
so I think with that you know I think I
got most of my points and I want to
thank you for listening to me and and I
hope that you support this bill it's not
it's not rocket science it's not
earth-shattering these we implemented
most of the things when I was chairman
it's not disruptive to the school
district at all
thank you very much
are there questions
not seen any from the committee thank
you very much thank you
Mariah Ryan
director
should I just go ahead yes please so for
the record my name is Maura Ryan I'm a
parent and a New Hampshire constituent
and I'm here to support HB 1137
um
it's been there's evidence-based
research per Harvard University that
shows that school districts with high
parent engagement rate have better
outcomes than any other school districts
parent engagement and parent
participation is a critical key to the
success of Any Given School District
um
the relationship between parents and
school districts has become adversarial
as of late
um there were several instances in our
school board meeting which I go to
fairly regularly because I'm a very
involved parent where public comment was
eliminated or left to the end and
parents who wanted to comment on voting
items were not able to do so until the
vote was taken afterwards there were
parents who were disparaging other
parents and um you know the police were
involved and I think when The Police
become involved then it's even more
escalated
some of the issues that I think with the
school board and the school district are
that it's very difficult right now to
delineate between the school board and
the school board and the school district
our school board is represented by our
school district attorney which in my
opinion is a huge conflict of interest
because the school district Mr chair
is this on the bill
I believe so keeping it to the as
opposed to conflicts with the school
district
attorney I believe that this bill
delineates some of the responsibilities
that those that line is not as fuzzy
that's what I would say
okay please continue
um keep it to those points sure
um
right now with our schools we have a
self-policing model which is not
appropriate because it doesn't work
James Madison recognized that over 200
years ago is when he wrote The
Federalist Papers
um and the school boards have the same
model so it doesn't work because when
parents go to the school board to bring
up issues and these are legitimate
issues we've brought up issues about the
math curriculum several times they don't
want to discuss them or address them
many parents aren't able to come to
school board meetings because of work
and yes virtual has made that easier and
they can't come here because they're
working many parents feel that their
voices are discounted many parents today
because of our New Hampshire school
system have college degrees and advanced
degrees I personally have four Advanced
degrees and you know when I go before
the school board they treat me like I'm
I work at McDonald's and I don't think
that that's respectful and I think that
other parents don't perceive that as
respectful
um
school districts don't need
the school boards need to to make sure
that the school district is performing
appropriately and in line and I think
that this bill sort of
puts in codification what they need to
do and a lot of school board members
don't know what they need to do they're
Flying Blind when they come into the
role
um
some of the wealthier school districts
too you know people say that there are
issues with that but that's more related
to their individual Geographic areas as
for
parents being allowed to observe in
classrooms that's already in federal law
under Essa section 8101 and section 1116
they should be given that opportunity
already and federal law does not is not
trumped by School District policy that
is kind of a ridiculous argument
parents have been marginalized in school
participation to fundraising which is
not appropriate because that doesn't
help the school get better they have
many different voices which should help
diversify what the school is doing to
improve it
um excuse me could you please keep to
the bill which is what the school board
should be doing and not what
your problems okay well I know some
school districts are holding meetings at
unreasonable hours for example the
curriculum committee is held at 6 30 a.m
I don't think it's reasonable to ask a
parent to come to a curriculum meeting
at 6 30 a.m I think a lot of times
parents come to school boards after
they've exhausted the chain of command
they've gone to the teacher they've gone
to the principal they've gone to the
superintendent and the superintendent
will often not get involved because he's
advised not to in the event that there's
an investigation so they then go to the
school board and when they don't get
resolution there it just increases their
level of
frustration
um and I think if we lay out exactly
what a school board is supposed to do
where a parent can look it up easily and
understand it because parents don't know
these laws parents have been looking for
these laws there are parents who have
you know we had two school board members
appointed by other board members and
these parents want to recall those board
members and there's nothing in the law
so if we made the law clear I think it
would be beneficial for parents for the
school district and for the school board
that's that's what I'd like to say I
support this bill I think that it's
easier for parents to understand it if
it's in black and white it's easier for
school board members because they're not
lawyers and it's easier for school
districts and I just like to make a
comment before I open it up on meeting
times remember these people on meetings
are also working and they so they fit in
the hours that they can either at night
or in the morning so you gotta remember
they're working too at other jobs in
most cases so anybody have any questions
okay thank you for your testimony thank
you
now I call
Jamie Wilder
yeah
good afternoon my name is Jama Wilder
and I am a parent from Hollis
um the hollow school district my
children go to Hollis Brookline High
School I first want to thank you all for
listening to me I'm here today to
testify to give you an idea of what's
really going on in our schools because I
heard a lot of comments today and I
think there's some false information
that's going around
I have five children I sent the older
two to the high school this year where I
asked for a complete list of curriculum
because I understood that I could opt
out of things that I wasn't comfortable
with
I tried to be proactive with this
knowing um in our in our culture that
there's things that I just might not be
um aligned with the teaching
I was refused that on multiple occasions
since August I was told that I could go
to Google classrooms through my
children's
account and look up what the teachers
were posting on that
like children started coming home with
questionable items and they would take
screenshots of it or get the list the
name of it it was not on Google
classrooms I met with the superintendent
I've met with the assistant
superintendent I've met with the
principal on multiple occasions and the
assistant superintendent and had
conversations with the um
with the other principal who handles uh
discipline so he has not been involved
as much in the curriculum issues
so I I voiced my concerns and they were
going on deaf ears I was going to school
board meeting after school board meeting
policy committees and budget committees
any way that I could get my three
minutes to talk to the board and I was
being ignored all the way around
so I went through the process of
volunteering I did over six hours of
volunteering to basically get an
opportunity to be more involved in my
children's education
through this process
um my children were coming home like I
said with several issues there was a
suicide in the school and I don't know
if all of you are aware of it but many
of our children in the state and
throughout the nation right now are
drowning because of the fact of the
lockdowns and there there's overdoses
there's depression there's anxiety
based around many different issues and
our kids are not being educated right
now and that is my main priority for my
children
so after the education after my
volunteering time was done I was told by
the school that they had no
opportunities for me and that if I
wanted to volunteer I needed to get in
touch with the parent student teacher
Association
I asked specifically for observation
time which I was denied by the principal
assistant principal and superintendent
citing the fact and I mentioned the Essa
law that was was mentioned earlier I was
told that because of their contracts
with the teachers union and child
privacy I was not allowed in the school
building during school hours
I have never had a meeting with a
teacher in person they are now telling
me and I have this all documented in
emails they're now telling me that I am
not allowed to question any curriculum
with the teachers without an
administrator there
they said that because of how I've been
approaching the situation that they feel
in light of what's going on in the
nation that I'm not
um that I am going to offend the
teachers
so basically where we're at right now is
I am pulling my children out of school
they got kicked out of school
um for two weeks because they refused a
mask mandate which our superintendent
put in place when we were not in school
could you please keep it with what
I can prepare how that goes with the
bill in question so the reason I'm
painting the picture is because I've
underlined all of the ways that I would
be able to get involved what is going on
right now is if you don't have an RSA to
support what you're doing it doesn't
matter if there's federal law or there's
the school board's policy or their
handbook I have gotten every single
policy and I'm I'm scouring through it
right now they have broken so many of
their own policies and laws and I have
no rights
so my only right right now the only way
to take back my children's education and
just so you know when my children got
kicked out of school I started reading
books with them my sophomore is reading
books at a lexicon level of 700 which is
a fourth or fifth grade reading level
these kids are not being taught and I
and I I want this stated too the way
that you're getting your information for
their standards is the national
um report card the federal government
comes in and tests a select group of
students and they use that as how
they're telling us our schools are doing
I will tell you
the reason I want this to pass so so
much is because I care about my
children's education and being involved
I am a parent and I want to help the
schools better educate the children
I want there to be evidence-based and
measurable methods for assessing the
student performance
I believe that there should be ethical
standards of behavior for these board
members as it stated before there's not
nothing to hold them accountable I could
wait a decade before I change this board
over
the conduct of annual performance
reviews of the district superintendent
as an employee of the board he is an
employee he's not the boss and he acts
like he is a king in our town and he
doesn't listen
I want to promote parental engagement
and participation
I have gone to public meetings
I've made public comments and I've been
cut off
I have had parental engagement I want
classroom visitations
the opportunity for parents to review
and select selection of printed or
digital textbooks or reading lists I
just want transparency and I want the
schools to be educating our children
to a high standard
Hollis Brookline High School which I
graduated from in 1999 is known
throughout the state for a great school
system it is not one now
and there is no way that I can hold them
accountable I pay over twelve thousand
dollars in taxes a year to be told that
I cannot be part of my children's
education and it's wrong
so I stand here before you pleading that
you would pass a law that allows me to
stand up for what's right and my
children's education and for the other
kids it's not just our town I know of
several sau's throughout the state that
are dealing with the same thing I've
been in contact with these moms I we are
collecting journals of information on
CRT and other things so that we can
share it and say this is happening all
throughout our state and no one's
listening because you want to keep it at
the local level but they make excuses
and say if there's not an RSA we're not
breaking any laws
this is why it is so important for me to
that this passes
thank you
okay thank you we have any questions
okay with that thank you for your
testimony and we have no more pink cards
so I guess we'll
close this
hearing and move on to the next one
care back
that's okay
phone's already been cracked
the sea still warm here Ralph
okay let's see where are we
we have uh for the committee we have one
more Bill going here I know some have
appointments for this evening whether it
be school board or select board or
something else if you do
please feel that you do not have to
remain you know if if that applies to
everybody if you have an appointment
please get to it
okay uh
thank you
so we're going to go ahead with uh House
Bill 1169 that's relative public comment
inquiry inquiry during school board
meetings uh we have representative Aaron
here as a prime spots I believe yes
representative Aaron is here welcome
to our committee
thank you Mr chair and thank you
cheerful
why not well that's right
um and thank you committee members for
sticking around you've had a long day
and I've been there I appreciate all
your work and attention and
and all the work that you do
so today I present to you HB 1169
and this bill is somewhat similar to
what we were talking about with the
previous bill this Bill establishes
requirements for public meetings by held
by a school board
to include a designated time period for
questions from the public and answers
from the school board
the bill also allows an attendee of a
meeting of the school board to demand
which New Hampshire statute or
administrative rule gives the school
board The Authority described in a
school policy or operational procedure
with the introduction of this bill to
your committee I want to First establish
that school board members are elected by
the voters in their District as per the
statutes under RSA 671
elections are defined under RSA 652
colon 1 and RSA 652 colon 9. because
school board members are elected
officials they are therefore answerable
to the public that they serve as elected
officials they are elected to craft
policy for the school district and
represent their constituents and they
must be held accountable to those
constituents
this bill was born out of many
unfortunate and sometimes ugly
situations that have happened in school
board meetings across this state over
the past year
parents have essentially been shut out
of participating in school board
meetings
have been summarily ignored at these
meetings and have not been given their
rightful chance to question discuss or
voice opinion regarding School Board
policy for the schools that they pay for
with their taxes
this is a wrong that must now be
statutorily corrected we cannot allow
school boards to be dictatorships they
are elected to serve the public not
ignore them
members of the public must be given
their time to voice their concerns
question and give comment at these
school board meetings regarding school
policy procedures and any other function
the school board performs
this bill makes sure that they get that
time
this is not an unusual or unreasonable
requirement yet some school boards do
not make this important time available
when questioned about school board
policy or the authority of school boards
to make certain policies they must also
provide an answer to the public
it is the right of the citizen to
question and receive an answer
especially since members of the school
board were elected to represent the
citizens and these citizens are funding
the schools with their tax dollars if an
answer is not known at the time of the
question then it is not unreasonable to
require the school board member or
administrator to follow up and provide
an answer within five business days
again as elected officials and policy
makers they are answerable to the public
if answers are not provided to the
public then complaints to the
commissioner of Education are in order
the public should also be made aware
through school board minutes which
members of the school board refused to
answer questions
that is sure to be a useful that is sure
to be useful information to the voters
the next time School Board elections
come around but it is also a matter of
public record
it is also not unreasonable to ask
school board members what administrative
rules and state statutes that give them
the authority to make certain school
policy
this ensures that school boards are not
just doing what they want whenever they
want without the authority to do so
an elected official should not be given
themselves power and authority where
none exists
this is a bill in my opinion that makes
good sense
it allows public input into important
local policy making and holds elected
officials accountable
I hope that you'll pass this bill out of
your committee with an OTP
recommendation and I'd be happy to
answer any questions
thank you very much representative are
there any questions from the committee
you're off the hook
okay thank you thank you very much
well as a courtesy
we're going to invite the officer not
the NCO
so Senator Guida you're up
thank you Mr chairman I'm not sure that
that was a compliment but I'll accept it
for the record Bob guide a state senator
for District Two I represent 27 towns
crossing the boundaries of three
different counties Grafton Belknap and
Merrimack uh and I have a lot of small
school boards I am a school board member
uh I think my third term six years
um and uh and accordingly I
I think that what I have to say is
apropos our small town we have two not
two public sessions at every school
board meeting early on
and at the end that's for the
convenience of the people who ask us to
serve them
I'm aware of numerous stories of school
boards that have a slightly different
orientation upon the definition of
service
and have caused significant problems and
mistrust amongst the people who pay the
freight
I've been at school board meetings where
things start to get unruly that's why
you have a chair the chair is
responsible for the governance of the
conduct of the meeting
if things get unruly you wrap the gavel
you take a recess everybody gets a
breather and then you move back into the
conduct of business
there's no need to use unruly Behavior
as a means to truncate the First
Amendment rights
of the citizens whose children for whom
we are responsible
virtually every component of the
education structure has a representation
in an organization that is highly paid
and very skilled at defending their
respective positions whether it's the
administrators Association School boards
Association
or the teachers in many cases unionized
but in most cases organized anyway
we are
we are the lobbyist for the parent and
the child
we the state legislature we have
constitutional obligations we know that
the child's benefit is in the hands of
the parents primarily
truncate the ability of parents
at any instance on any agenda item
to interject their thoughts and direct
Those Who quote unquote serve is a grave
disservice
we need to fix that problem and we can
fix that problem constructively
the issue here is one of accountability
school board that has three members
will take at least three years
to repair if the conduct of any member
or or the aggregate of members is not
satisfactory
meantime a child has advanced through
three more years of whatever the policy
might be that was considered
objectionable
I would suggest that perhaps one way to
accomplish this
is to require a public hearing
after a public meeting after the school
board meeting
by law school meetings do not have to
have public input but hearings are in
fact designed for that purpose you can
also design meetings to have a business
component and a time element for that
followed by
agenda items that are non-business okay
policy changes and so forth so there's
ways to do this if there's a will I
think we as elected members okay of the
legislature of New Hampshire
in accordance with our constitutionally
sworn obligations and the fact that we
are the lobbyist if you will for parents
and children in an arena that is very
much punctuated by other interests that
are special to their own Specialties
whether they're administrators teachers
or School boards okay we are the ones
that should set the policy and requiring
public input
at a meeting in which the future of our
children is at stake I think is the only
responsible thing to do and I ask you to
please support this bill is ought to
pass thank you Mr chairman thank you
very much Senator do you care to take
any questions any questions yes sir
representative Porter your hand is up
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
senator for taking my question
um you said you served on a school board
still am okay
according to
change lines 15 through 17 in this bill
18 in this bill
says during any public meeting held by a
school board an attendee May demand
which New Hampshire statute or
administrative rule
gives the school board The Authority
described in a school policy or
operational procedure the school board
shall immediately respond with a
citation to its Authority could you do
that
I think there's also a provision in the
law that says I have a time frame if I
can't no it doesn't
if the school board is unable to respond
affirmatively
um
the procedure shall be immediately
withdrawn until such time that the board
can show it has such Authority could you
do that in three days
I would make it a point to do that
because I serve I would also state that
understanding as a small school board
member okay many times what happens to
school boards given the incredible
volume of administrative rules
is that the SAU and superintendent
become de facto
okay the deciders of policy and they
present things that school boards don't
understand
okay so again we have a we need as as a
legislator Our obligation is to make the
process transparent
and comfortable or not to ensure that
the accountability is there I would
submit that a question that was asked to
me that I didn't know the answer to
would present me with an opportunity to
learn and therefore become a better
qualified School Board member follow up
yes go ahead in our committee meetings
here in the state house we're not
allowed to question each other back and
forth we're not allowed to have a
dialogue between ourselves the 10th
person who's testifying takes questions
and responds to one person at a time but
if this policy were enacted would it be
possible for a member of the audience to
question representative leckis on a
specific thing in the middle of a school
board meeting or would she have to go
through the chair as we do or how would
that work I think I'd refer to Chairman
lad's comments in the last bill that's a
local issue and the chairman can control
that however he or she chooses all right
bill is pretty specific
I would also offer that there are
amendments possible to the bill thank
you
that is correct we can amend areas where
we see a change May improve the bill
or modify the bill
further are you done representative
Porter is that thank you are there other
questions from the committee yes
yes representative Ford then
representative representative Walt
school first because I I saw your hand
up first and then I'll go to rep Center
Ford
so uh Senator Garden nice to see you see
you thank you um we have a procedure in
the state whereby when people have
questions be it at a state level or a
local level they have a right task and
the right to know law and in the right
to know law if the state doesn't keep
that data it doesn't have that data or
the town of the school district they
don't have to compile that data you know
if I ask for some obscure long list that
the school district doesn't keep they
don't have to compile that data for me
but by opening this up to questions and
expecting that the school board is going
to answer all these questions within
five days within no limitations that
even if they don't have the data or
those kinds of things aren't we going
against the long tradition of the the
right to know law and aren't we creating
perhaps enormous amounts of work for
school boards and school districts
I'm not sure I understand the context of
your question
I want to know
everything that's going to be taught to
my child this year in third grade you
know
the teacher hasn't even put the lesson
plan together yet okay but there's an
obligation of the school district then
to come up with that lesson plan for all
180 days of school the way I read this
bill that if somebody asks for it you
have to provide it and what I'm
suggesting is that under the right to
know law if that information doesn't
exist you don't have to provide it yet
the way this bill is written you're
going to have to create that information
or have somebody create that information
there is no exit for the fact that that
information doesn't already exist with
all due respect I would disagree with
your interpretation of 91a it says if
it's too onerous you get a bigger time
frame and if it cannot be produced then
a letter to that effect is sent back to
you okay
uh representative Ford
microphone Oliver
it won't come any further he had to
change links
this way my concern is for those issues
that rise to the point of
I'll call it incoherence in a public
meeting to where the abuse the verbal
abuse becomes abuse
physical abuse almost and the threat of
physical abuse
and in a prior conversation I was
talking about at that point I think the
chair should simply cease that
discussion
that's what I meant when I said shut
down the discussion and continuing it
when there's sufficient order to have a
rational dialogue
is how does that fit in
your understanding of Our obligation
dealing with the public school boards
dealing with the public and that sort of
thing thank you for the question I think
it's it's entirely appropriate what you
say again it's within the role of the
chairman or chairwoman
to control the conduct of the meeting
when things start getting unruly we're
going to take a five-minute recess
people calm down and we'll get back to
the business of the board again it's
it's in a matter of how the meeting is
conducted someone gets unruly you stop
the meeting a threat that rises to the
point of potential physical harm is
actually a crime
all right and a person might need to be
reminded of that
Again part of running meetings is
understanding the parameters and and the
rules and regulations relating to the
interaction of people when it gets
confrontational which sometimes it does
but again the chairman a good chair will
in fact manage that meeting in such a
way that as he or she sees conflict
starting to arise
bang the gavel take a couple minutes
calm down and and uh I've never seen a
situation where that doesn't work
thank you very much are the further
questions for the
for the are you pointing to yours oh
okay
not seeing hands thank you very much
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee thank you Happy New Year
yeah representative baldacero
because he's a Marine right right
for the record uh first of all thank you
Mr chairman and the rest of the
committee there for your loyalty and
dedication and staying on with us here
and I know what it is to be here for
late nights for the last so 15 years of
my time but but anyways representative
alball the South Rockingham County
District 5 which is Londonderry I was on
it I didn't even know one of my
constituents coming up here and I
actually kind of fit in what I was going
to talk about that this isn't a
Republican or Democratic issue
especially in my town okay because one
of my fellow Democrat rep uh
constituents came up here to speak out
and I was honored to see that because
this is a parent issue okay that's going
on in Londonderry and and I made a clear
to him at a meeting that if you could
not fix the public comment this has been
going on not just for covert for the
last five years we had a chairman in the
town there who didn't run okay who used
to stop public comment now we hold
legislation uh earrings here for public
comment to come in before you pass the
hearing the school board would pass all
the policy and everything that going on
that they wanted parents were sitting
out there came to speak against those
agenda items and then at the end of the
night at 10 30 11 o'clock at night then
get to speak
I've seen sometimes where kids sleeping
on their laps I see many parents go home
I've been involved with this in a long
time going in and out uh the school
board because I you know as you know I'm
a quiet guy and my constituents asked me
all the time to come to the board and
try to help them out and speak up for
them because they're not getting any
satisfaction
this legislation in my opinion is a form
of redress of grievance
for the people it's a constitutional
issue they're speaking out I've seen
disrespect I've from my board I've seen
them not answer questions on parents on
a kid who got in trouble that got no
voice from the superintendent from the
teacher anyone else go to the board and
ask for help and they refuse and they
look at them and treat it like you're
garbage why are you talking to us
questions are being asked and they're
ignoring them then you wonder why
parents are getting aggravated
we put a committee in place in my town
for the school board and they came up
with a plan of optional mask
but it was a waste of time because they
School Board went the opposite of what
that board's recommendation was where
you know its Master the school uh
naturally parents are mad okay this this
is a major issue here but like I said
the the public climate has gone on a
long time before and so it's just been
building up because what my town did was
two people resigned they brought back
that same chairman before that stopped
public comment
that made it to late at night and then
all of a sudden now public comment is
late at night so people cannot speak
against anything that's on the agenda
until it's already passed and it's too
late when they ask questions about the
laws they won't answer them when one
mother said I wrote the superintendent I
wrote the teacher I got nowhere
I once spoke myself a few quite a few
times of course they sent me to the
ethics board nothing happened but you
know because I told the vice uh the
deputy superintendent there that you
should resign okay because y'all failure
to tell these parents what's going on
with their children answering their
questions would save a lot of problem we
have the same problem in the VA when a
nurse or a doctor does not call a
veteran that Veteran's sitting home
going crazy why you didn't call him why
aren't they report returning my call
why are they doing this that's sometimes
suicides and other stuff imagine a
parent who sends to a teacher or to a
superintendent this is what I'm hearing
all the time from parents why they're
aggravated they don't answer me you
heard that mother you've heard uh my
constituent that came up here
they're not answering them so naturally
they're sitting in their home getting
aggravated because they care about their
children I've had five kids go to
Londonderry schools two at Masters to a
bachelor's one within the Marines okay
uh the education was great but since
covert now our education stuff is going
down and down we're ruining our children
and many people don't even care that all
they care about is hey don't worry about
it we'll we'll make up for it later on
okay I got a kid right now my nephew On
The Run okay with issues in school and
other stuff he ran from his brother I
mean from my brother that's going on
right now tonight so I'm asking you to
re think this this is our duty to fix
this and make damn well assure their
parents have a say I know firsthand
about this because I was stationed in
Delaware they were going to bust my kids
into a bad school I moved to Aberdeen an
hour and 15 minutes away so my kids
could get a good education when they
moved here to New Hampshire okay my kids
were four or five months behind ahead
they were so bored they wanted to go
back to Maryland because New Hampshire
schools were were so far slower than
where they came from they went to
military schools in Aberdeen so my kids
were well educated but I'm just saying
what my children went through when I
moved them here after I retired from the
Marines we owe it to the children we owe
it to the parents I'm I'm telling you
right now I'm involved I'm at these
committee hearings that I'm watching and
listening how these board members are
speaking Republicans and Democrats so
it's not just one party doing this the
way they're treating these parents then
you wonder why they're getting
aggravated and it's a disgrace and there
was a couple of notes that I made my
here
I remember there was a movie that we
once uh once watched it might have been
a military one where they said there's a
failure to communicate and that's what's
going on right now the failure to
communicate is through the parents in
the school board School boards failure
superintendents are too busy we have all
these administrators we got more
administrators today that I ever had
when I was in school and that's where
all that money's going okay right versus
it should be going to the teachers
in closing
let me tell you I sat here and I
listened to the union I I could never
ever understand why taxpayers money are
paying like a union guide was here today
I respect them and God bless them but
taxpayers money are paying these groups
to go against the parents got to speak
against the parents like up in here that
makes no sense I don't know why
taxpayers money a paying lobbyists
something's wrong with this picture we
should be protecting parents I thought
there was a law somewhere around that
but I may be wrong but that's all I have
get back I am I'm getting back it was
aggravating to see that but uh that's
all I have and I I hope we do the right
thing and protect the parents and the
school board school boards need to be
educated and understand that you have to
have dicks in when when you do this big
job thank you thank you very much are
there any questions for Al baldacero
not seeing any thank you very much
uh Barrett Christina
foreign
thank you again chairman thank you again
chairman Ladd uh bear Christina School
Board Association uh to start though he
did have to leave I want to publicly
thank Senator Guida for his work on his
local school board as we always try and
do we are opposed to
um the bill number here opposed to House
Bill 1169
um mandating public comments um again as
I think we talked about this uh perhaps
the last bill I spoke
um we should do that for every public
body then
uh City councils towns this body
um I think it would also be prudent for
this committee to know that the State
Board of Education has not taken public
comments for I believe the last year or
so if I'm not mistaken
um so
um uh you know um if we were trying to
set examples for local school boards we
should start there and require State
Board of Education to take public
comments as well too
um the other aspect I'm on uh the middle
I guess on page I think it's page one
line 16 where it talks about
um an attendee made to man which New
Hampshire statute or administrator of
rule gives a school board authority
described in the school board policy
that would mean that we can't have
policies that relate to federal law if
you're only limiting this to policies
have to be based in New Hampshire law
it's also
um
it also doesn't make any sense and make
any sense in the context of of a public
body there's nothing in the law that
speaks to a school board having a
chairperson or electing officers does
that mean they can't have a chairperson
or elect officers I've got dozens of
sample policies here that have no basis
in particular statute or or or
Department of Education rule
reconsideration of instructional
materials so we'll get rid of that
policy and we won't reconsider our
instructional materials
evaluation of support staff there's
nothing in law that requires support
staff be evaluated
tutoring for pay
nothing in law that prohibits or
specifically allows teachers to tutor
students on their own time for pay I'm
going to get to some of the more basic
ones volunteer involvement School Board
show encourage the involvement of
citizens to fulfill the mission of the
schools nothing in law that allows
volunteers to come in the school
district so we won't do that anymore
um
school board self-evaluation and goal
setting there's goal setting there's
nothing in law that requires or allows
for a school board to self-evaluate
roles and duties of the school board
chairperson as I talked about there's
nothing in law that specifically allows
a school board to elect officers or
appoint a chair so I don't know who's
going to run the meeting
board organizational meeting the board
shall organize at its annual meeting
annually at its first meeting follow the
elections every member shall be notified
of the meeting meeting shall be called
to order by the superintendent who shall
preside during the election of the
chairperson there's nothing about
election of officers and the law
School Board officers
agenda setting and preparation there's
nothing in the law that requires a
school board a set an agenda for a
meeting so I guess setting an agenda
would be illegal if this bill were to
pass
Rules of Order nothing in law relative
to Rules of Order for school board
meetings so that would be illegal
approval of handbook handbooks and
directives there's nothing in law that
requires a school book create a handbook
I guess we're publishing those illegally
I think I made my point
happy to answer any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions for Bear Christina
yes
you tired huh I'm tired too
um so here's my question
I had always been trained over the I've
been a chair seven out of nine years and
I I actually allow public comment being
at the end of the meeting because I feel
very strongly we're going to address it
you know I mean you need to have that
chance but that being said
um one thing that I had always been
trained on was that school board meeting
specific well any type of town meeting
is a meeting held in public and not a
public meeting therefore maybe public
comment did not have to be allowed or
the public cannot interrupt my question
to you and I don't even know if it's
really for you and I have to apologize
because it's late and you're probably
tired too like I said but um but I've
I've heard a lot of pushback in the past
year that that is actually not a that's
not a correct mindset it's not a correct
statement and I was wondering if you
could please shed some light on that for
me thank you thank you very much
representative I mean it's a public
meeting under the right to know
obviously but at its most base level
it's a business meeting of your regular
school board meeting is a business of
the school board where the Board needs
to get its business done approved
contracts receive reports adopt policies
in your budget season while you're
hopefully your budget's just about done
you've got your budget hearing was
probably this week if I'm not mistaken
or yeah so um you know is public common
period advisable absolutely nobody
disputes that many boards do one at the
beginning and one and after where they
can comment on the agenda items or
what's going to happen at that meeting
and then at the conclusion of the
meeting club members of the public can
come back and talk about something that
was discussed or a vote that happened or
whatever it was during the course of
that meeting that you know again if that
works for your school board and that's
what your community wants and I'd say go
ahead and do that
um so you know the responding to the
questions and whatnot I mean you know
you know is the question being prose as
a legitimate question or is it you know
being posed as a way to take a swipe at
a school board or a superintendent or
whatever the case may be you know of
course on hsba Advocates that that we
should have public comments the
parameters of of what we do with public
comments that's a First Amendment matter
that you could spend a a three-day
seminar doing you can go from open-ended
public comment come and say what you
want to you know very restrictive two
minutes per person only talk about these
topics so on and so forth there's a lot
of play in the middle and you know my
experience is a lot of school boards do
it differently yes we have a sample
policy I can probably we probably got 10
on file though
um we've also just to make it clear as
well too when school boards were facing
the issues last summer and fall
specifically over the masks and whether
or not they were going to do in person
and and or remote
you know we tried to counsel school
boards we said look don't put the mask
issue on when you've got 6 000 other
things to do at your board meeting if
you got 300 people showing up at your
board meeting and they're angry about
whatever decision you're making maybe
hold a second maybe hold a separate
meeting all right we're gonna spend two
hours tonight and we're only going to
talk about masks if you want to come and
tell us your opinion on mask we're going
to do it we're gonna do it outside of
the meeting where we've got to approve
the contracts and adopt the policies and
it's an extra meeting we talked about
how many more times but that's one other
way to sort of you know let the public
have their voice um you know a public I
don't want to call it a hearing per se
but almost a public forum about this
particular Topic in person versus remote
Mass versus no Mass you know sometimes
you have the same way that we have
separate budget hearings to talk about
only the budget we're only talking about
the budget tonight let's only talk about
masks tonight let's only talk about
in-person versus virtual tonight some
boards were able to do that some words
some boards weren't
hope that helps
thank you very much thank you are there
any other questions for the school
boards
not thank you very much and have a good
evening thank you you as well everybody
thank you
okay uh we have Laura oh Oakland is it
okay
oh
okay Laurie
I'm sorry Lori but oh totally all right
I have
I couldn't read that supper
thank you very much for giving me this
time to speak with you my name is Lori
ortolano and I'm from Nashua it's been a
long time since I've addressed an
education issue or been gotten involved
um I live I'm the vice president of
right to know New Hampshire and we're
supporting this legislation
to enhance public comment at school
board meetings
25 years ago I served on the Litchfield
School Board
um for about five years and that was a
different time in a different place
it's difficult to witness the
argumentative dialogue between school
boards and parents and read the
contentious articles about parents
teachers children in schools the Nashua
School Board has become a hotbed of
issues in Parental frustration is high
and understandable
the language of this legislation does
not impact RSA 91a but it does hold
elected school board members to a higher
degree of accountability to respond to
community questions
there are many important curriculum
issues today and parents have questions
regarding the administrative rules used
to create policy and procedure they
cannot question what rules or
regulations apply because this Falls
outside the scope of 91a and a records
request some elected boards will respond
to questions and we'll get answers to
those who ask
school boards are shutting down or being
advised to do so
and the result is we're building walls
and not Bridges
this public input legislation
specifically for school boards will
benefit all schools in the state the
sdga has requested one public question
comment question period for this new
legislation but we would like to see two
public common question and answer
periods Donna green who's a member of
the sdga and right to know New Hampshire
submitted amended language for this
legislation which we support at right to
know New Hampshire
um just to go over quickly what she
submitted that you received in an email
was that they would
um there would be one designated period
um for interactive questions and answers
um the public would have to be allowed
to sign up to speak in person or
remotely and they must be given time to
speak before this substantive public
business of the meeting public questions
and comments can't be censored or
preempted and sufficient time must be
allotted to give each member of the
public who is signed up to speak at
least three uninterrupted minutes unless
the board votes to impose a total
comment time of no less than 15 minutes
in section two
um the sdga amended it so that in the
end
um when it talks about members of the
public assembling to meet so long as the
information is not protected from
disclosure under RSA 91a or other
legislation and section three
um the citation if the board does not
answer a question or provide an
administrative rule that the school
board would have five business days to
respond just like they would under RSA
91a and if they don't have a citation or
a policy with which they are operating
under they would address that at the
next school board meeting and provision
four
um
additional additionally members of the
public may also file a request pursuant
to the right to no law under RSA 91a
colon 4 to the school board to obtain
documents relative to questions right so
it's just a document and so those that's
the substitutive changes that were made
by the school district's governing
Association that supported by um right
to know and I just wanted to add a
couple thoughts to what I listened to
here some comments the it looks like the
School Board Association gave guidance
to cities or towns you know on how to
deal with public input and when you have
a contentious issue like masks maybe
don't take it on when you have 20 items
on the agenda you know what happened in
Nashua is the mask issue got put on the
agenda right at the meeting and public
input was shut down there was no input
allowed I can tell you that was a bad
move I wasn't at that meeting I've never
actually gone to a school board meeting
in Nashua I've watched them on TV I was
going to go to the last one and it was
80 people out there and I decided to go
home I drove and turned around and left
um because it was a heated meeting again
but
you know the the actions of the board in
Nashua to Simply cancel public comment
and not even have the mask item on the
agenda just put it on live in the
meeting vote on it and not allow open
comment that's a disaster
when I see that happening and it just
creates a lot of hardship
um I also heard um the association talk
about you know what school boards have
to endure and I was a school board
member
um
and and social media wasn't around when
I was a school board member thankfully
and it is now and it's you know social
media is is the opposite of prayer
that's for sure there's not much good
going on on social media so
you know you have to
either tune that out
you know tune it out it doesn't matter
it's everyone can have their own
platform to throw whatever they want
around ignore it
um but I have to say and there are
parents that put things up on social
media that's frankly just horrendous and
citizens horrendous things being posted
but I have to tell you my take in Nashua
is I have seen school board and elected
officials post things that were just
outrageous it's both ways and what's and
it's more concerning to me when it's
coming from elected officials honestly
the standard has to be higher you have
to avoid that and I think there ought to
be policies established on the use of
social media by elected officials just
like companies establish those policies
because I I had heard a few things about
some board members never tracked it
maybe two months ago I happened to
somebody directed me and emailed me a
copy of what was posted on social media
I was flabbergasted that that was an
elected official well okay that'll cause
a lot of problems
so you know I'm I'm very sympathetic
about the needs of parents
um you know I homeschooled my kids I was
a school board member for five years and
I homeschooled my kids
um and I always felt like I served the
interest of my citizens and towns
completely it was never about my agenda
at all and I never professed my choice
to anyone or um you know it was all
about building a good school system
um
in it
things are very difficult right now and
I always say you know sometimes it's got
to get worse before it gets better you
just gotta let it go but I'm concerned
about that when it comes to schools and
education because every last year is a
lost year on a child and you know if it
takes three or four more years of
fighting and and you let that go or
another three-year election cycle you
just you lose a lot of quality education
and you and Nash was lost 10 percent of
its population virtually and I will tell
you I really believe if they had three
more private schools that opened up
Catholic schools they would be filled
because they're brimming right now
parents are looking for choices big time
and um I love the idea of holding
hearings or just I actually wrote an
email last night and said it would be a
gesture of Goodwill for the board of
aldermen to hold once a year an open
meeting for the public to come and ask
questions and just talk to you just
don't want one meeting and I would
recommend the school board do too
because the school board really needs
that just have an open Forum come on out
it's a great gesture of Goodwill I did
it up at the assessing standards boards
therebylaws require that it be done up
in Concord and they actually held it in
Manchester I went to that a few months
ago there are only three people there
um so it wasn't a killer for them but
it's a great gesture of Goodwill and I
got four or five questions answered so I
loved going and getting my answers you
know in document requests under 91a and
the way 91a is written it's about
records and documents terrific I
understand all of that but sometimes you
have to be able to ask questions to
understand what documents you want you
have to have a basic understanding to
know how to go after the documents
and depending on how contentious it is
they those walls can exist in
communities where just having a basic
understand communication on how the
records exist isn't happening because
you can't ask a question
so with that becomes very very tricky so
you know I don't
I don't envy your position and and the
decisions and what you're looking at
here and um I hope and pray for better
scenarios in our state when it comes to
education and all that we've gone
through but in general our right to know
New Hampshire committee and the sdga
stand behind putting more information in
the hands of parents and if it's through
questions
um so be it thank you thank you very
much for your testimony are there any
questions
yes representative boom
get ready okay
go ahead it's been 25 years since we've
had fun on the budget committee I know I
did the budget committee after the
school board with representative Baum
for a few years of that yes
yep
that was your question
thank you I should have put the gamble
down
thank you very much
uh we have one left uh
yep Eric power
there you go
hello this is uh Eric power I'm here for
the school district governance
Association that was just alluded to and
I'm going to keep it brief because you
heard most of what we talked about I did
email to the committee the school
district governance association's
recommended amendments the sdga is very
much in favor of this bill for all the
reasons that were stated it's a very
important bill it will help a lot some
some school boards are doing this as a
good practice but there's others that
aren't doing it at all and so by putting
it into law I think you can see the need
for it it complements the previous bill
that was put up here and I would ask
that you could the the Amendments that
we put in are a little more prescriptive
you can decide whether to use them or
not but as a as a whole I would like to
see in the school district governance
Association would like to see this ought
to pass or ought to pass with Amendment
so thank you thank you very much
are there any questions let's see thank
you very much
and that does close the
this hearing down we are now finished uh
our work for today
no don't what you got there
we did two
I know we okay we can take care of that
yeah so we are we're done we're doing
everybody have a safe ride home please
yeah yeah we've yeah they've got that in
their calendar so okay so what do we got
here
yeah
you won't get that majority report right
now though that we'll get that done we
have a uh we did two today and we won
from the other day and we haven't
written the majority report yet
yeah
okay but no
no I just unplugged it
foreign